[Laughter]
okay supposed to give this to you now it
come up till exactly just the end of the
day it's fine no I can I can hold it
over here it's fine roll okay so we had
the first public hearing House Bill 83
and and uh I'm just I'm waiting for my
clerk cuz she didn't have her her sheets
so okay you want to do you know anything
about this bill I don't okay uh is there
anybody here uh who wants to speak
it you do okay why don't you come on up
on check one there you go okay introduce
yourself please and hey uh good morning
representative hunt and members of the
committee thank you for your time today
I was not expecting to be the first
person to testify at a hearing I
normally used to seeing other folks go
ahead um I'm here representing myself I
live out in uh seab Brook New Hampshire
come out I drove an hour to the seos
just to come and testify I thought what
did you say your name was I'm sorry Matt
Matt what Sabor D Schwaner uh okay you
will F out a pink card afterwards yeah I
think we gave you one can make sure we
get you that's okay um okay so fun fun
story I wanted to share before giving my
conclusion for the bill is um from
August of 2020 to January of 2021 I was
briefly a member of an organization
called infragard which is a public
private Partnership of the FBI which is
which is stated mission is to uh you
know protecting critical infrastructure
in the United States um I lost
confidence in the way that the country
was going in January of 2021 and I
actually canceled my membership in the
uh in the organization of infragard it's
a nonprofit um I wasn't active I
received emails from them I didn't
attend any meetings but it seemed more
like infragard is almost like a nanny
State kind of thing where it just has
private citizens walking around looking
out for their own uh you know
look looking out for their own or
watching I'm sorry um private private
citizens looking spying on each other
almost that's that's the impression
that's the way it felt you know because
no one had I never heard of it before
until I had to join as part of an online
degree uh I lost confidence in the way
the direction was of the country was
going in January 2021 and I canceled my
membership because I didn't trust the
incoming Administration and about you
know 3 weeks after the new inauguration
there there was the executive order that
was issued that kind of allowed China
access to the electrical grid and I did
not appreciate that I lost confidence
and I was like I didn't I'm glad I got
out of this I didn't want to pay didn't
want to be part of it doesn't make sense
um that's a fun backstory you know on
principle we shouldn't be selling land
in our state to a foreign country it's
we should sell it to uh private citizens
of New Hampshire first and private
citizens of uh of the United States
first and then other American owned
corporations uh we should not be selling
um know our land
or or industrial critical Industries to
a foreign country I'm sorry guys I
stutter um my recommendation for this
pass okay great thank you very much you
do know that one of our biggest
corporations in ASA is a British British
company
I was listing priorities on where it
should go but thank you okay okay thank
you all right uh next I have a card from
did did you put a card in I mean
really okay well I I I'm going to now
I'm going to call up Robert Johnson
who's from the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau as a federation's policy director
F Bureau as a Federation of New
Hampshire's 10 County F bureaus our
members are Family Farms close to 2,000
of them we have another close to a
thousand supporting uh members and we
are in uh opposition to the bill is
introduced proded um if uh if you plan
on moving forward uh we would ask for a
at least an amendment that would uh uh
the way the Bill's written it's so broad
that would enable uh land to be leased
for research and educational purposes
and we we say that with one particular
entity in mine um senta is a uh
worldwide leader in crop protectant and
Seed research and as well as well as
sales and we would hope that if there
was the opportunity at our agriculture
experiment station in Durham or the in
the university in some other way that
that that senta wanted to uh fund some
research that we would have the
opportunity to participate in that
um so I got since senta is a a company
that is is uh was was founded and today
is still uh headquartered in Switzerland
and back in
2017 it was purchased by uh the the the
Chinese National Chemical Corporation so
it it it is it is controlled by in the
end uh by uh the the Chinese government
um this has been as you're probably
aware it's a big issue Nationwide our
National Organization has been involved
in this quite a bit and done a lot a
good bit of research I've left with the
clerk and I have some more copies of
some uh uh study that that they did uh
real helpful that you just email those I
will I have the electronically and I
will do that that would be great is
there if and just let me know there's a
particular uh email that I should use
house Commerce we'll do and so that is
one and then uh just a little bit of
extra data I did contact American Farm
Bureau with the the the data you in that
report it's not State specific but I
asked for some State data in particular
I asked for how much farmland or uh is
is is does China the Chinese Nationals
own uh in New Hampshire and there there
is none uh the the only uh land that is
reported is this just under 100 acres
reported in penobscott County Maine and
we take that that's probably Forest land
and and that you'll see it in the report
but it it kind of gets to one of the
issues that that requires uh the
reporting is self-reporting and the
self-reporting is to the USGA Farm
Service Agency and and and that um kind
of uh shows you uh uh uh you could
question the accuracy of the data SC and
it is voluntary compliance in reporting
and beyond that if an entity is is
supposed to have reported and reports
late they are fined at a substantial
amount so it discourages self-reporting
after the fact
um- which which kind of leads me to a
question with the bill I see there's no
fiscal note so to to uh uh to police
this and such you you you're you're
going to need some some
funds lastly uh I I will say that also
and I provided a copy to the clerk but
the USDA has has uh um opened a docket
on this uh seeking uh comments on their
current process and that's open until I
believe it's February mid-February I
think once say the 16th I again I I can
provide you a copy of that uh uh docket
that that I registered notice uh
electronically and and I guess the final
thing is that just to you're probably
already aware but there is a similar
bill over in the senate senate pel 366
on this that is being heard next Tuesday
in Senate Commerce I'll leave it at that
and I thank you for timeing attention Mr
chair great any questions from committee
question I'm a little a little confused
in the sense that uh the the Chinese
purchase of the the organization in
Switzerland um does that
um I don't the bill to me is is you
don't sell land or infrastructure to uh
China that's the that's the aim of the
bill I mean I am I missing something if
you read the bill a little clearly if
you see that they're they're they're
looking for the long arm anything that
you have any connection any company that
has any connection with the People's
Republic of China or the uh the party is
is what it says in the bill you have the
bill in front of you there yeah but but
but the but what they bought was a uh um
a scientific organization
uh as opposed to a landowning
organization it says any part of
ownership part of ownership in other
words because that company has invest
has China as as an owner part owner yeah
that means they would be barred from
under this legislation they would be
barred from buying land in New Hampshire
they they own land and facilities in
order to conduct their research it was
you may have heard of it in Arkansas
recently where they passed the law and
uh then and senta owns a seed company in
Arkansas that employed a a vast majority
of of people in a particular community
and they required that they sell that
facility and that happen and that that
particular Senter happens to be the
largest contributor to FFA Future
Farmers of America organization the
state of
Arkansas and you're saying that when
Arkansas passed this legislation they
were forced to sell the yes yeah whether
I get I should whether it's been sold
yet or not I don't know but they are
being forced
to they have a a deadline to meet okay
in one particular Community it's going
to devastate them because they're all
they live in the community they need to
go elsewhere so I have a follow on
question you know why further question
meire further question is uh so is is
this uh membership in the Swiss
organization uh critical uh to the
United States I mean in terms of the
science of uh the the company was
founded and is now owned in and
headquartered in Switzerland like it's I
would say it is
critical okay so we don't we don't have
an alternative further question yes for
the question number three and I'll stop
there we don't so we don't have an
alternative uh organization in the
United States to to do this
research well there like yeah there are
competitors uh Senter like Bayer if
you've heard of Bayer
Monsanto a couple of the other comp any
entity that's that's that's
manufacturing is German yeah yeah
correct but and any company that's
manufacturing uh producing or
researching crop protectants seed that
type of thing would be a competitor so
yes we do have Alternatives in this
country but Senter is a leading entity
and they may be I just use Senter as a
prime example right that was just an
example great thank you we have any
other
questions all set thank you very much uh
anybody else would like to
testify did you did I get a card from
you Tim okay here we
go represent
hgan opposition to the bill yes well I'm
certainly um I do not consider myself a
communist so I'm certainly glad I don't
live in in in China but the uh what we
used to call Red China there is actually
they are very good at capitalism and um
they're the second largest economy in
the world we do have to coexist with
them and um so even though communist is
a dirty word on both sides the political
Spectrum here um I think this bill is
overly overly broad because um you know
we we have have to coexist the Chinese
are uh you know as I said they're the
second greatest biggest economic power
in the world we're in a symbiotic
relationship with them like I apologize
my phone went off by accident I believe
that phone was mostly components of
phone were in fact manufactured in uh
the People's Republic of China so
U and uh C especially uh as and I see
the concern about the Farmland also the
critical Industries there's also the
whole issue of uh you know Battery
Technology that we're way behind the
Chinese have been uh much more so than
the capitalists here in the US
aggressively investing in in electric
vehicles and other battery technologies
and um the other thing I might say the
communist country that really scares me
is Russia because Putin even though
economically he doesn't uh even doesn't
follow the economic policies of the old
Soviet Union he up that's obviously what
he's up to he is trying to reconstitute
the Soviet Union and I certainly think
we should be doing U even more than we
are now to stop that I mean there's some
people seem to even want want to let
Putin go ahead and take over the former
Soviet republics but that's U that's a
subject for another bill or another
debate so I I mean I I'm not eager to
vote for an itl if it comes to the floor
but I think um probably passing this
current form it's very Broad and um it's
it's it's very Broad and it's not not
not ready to be passed and probably the
basic idea behind it has some flaws
certainly a uh certainly your best bet
would either to amend it so it's not as
broad or um or put it send the interim
study and I also like to add as others
notice there are many foreign or
corporations here in the US like Bae is
based in Britain um in my area there's
six sour major manufacturer Firearms
they're uh they're based in Switzerland
so I I just I I I think understand the
concern behind this bill and I share it
but I just don't think actually putting
this language into law would be a good
idea so uh that's uh and I probably make
probably probably wasn't a good idea for
me to come here on YouTube uh you know
doing anything other than totally
condemning communist China which has
many many problems but you know they are
good at capitalism probably they're
probably uh better at us at being
capitalists so sort of like it's a it's
a society which is very oppressive in
some ways but it's some way some other
ways it's uh less oppressive but anyway
so that's I would say don't pass the
bill as introduced at least we'll see
what the alternative is and I'm sure you
thanks
okay thank you very much is there anyone
else here would like to speak on
Hospital
1183 okay you will fill out a pin card
thank
you good morning Mr chairman and members
of the um Commerce Committee my name is
Jonathan Leslie I am speaking Pro to
this bill as an individual um I'm an
army combat infantry veteran from seven
years I have a master's degree in
terrorism and counterterrorism studies
and my wife and I both run a small farm
over in Deerfield um I'm supporting this
bill to a long-term threat of continued
Chinese purchases of both Prime
agricultural land and American
infrastructure I'd like to read a quote
from a book titled unrestricted Warfare
which was written in 1999 by two
Colonels in the chines Air Force if one
party is at war with another and the
other does not realize it is at War the
party who knows it as war is almost
always has the advantage and usually
wins Waging War on an adversary with
meth methods so benign that the party
being attacked does not realize it's
being attacked um China's been waging
economic Warfare on the United States
for close to 20 years um and we have
minimal protected policies within our
law China's responsible for close to 90%
of the industrial Espionage committed
against us companies according to
various studies which causes billions of
dollars in damage annually this bill is
vit ly important as both PRC and Chinese
companies controlling either our
agricultural land or critical indust
Industries would reduce both our
security and resilience at the state
level China already owns the largest
pork producer in America which is
Smithfield and due to its production
contracts approximately 25% of American
pork and pigs while New Hampshire's
agricultural production might not be
huge we do need to protect what we have
can you imagine allowing Soviet
countries as the prior rep talked about
owning land or critical Industries
during the Cold War venting this common
these purchases is common sense to
protect our nation leadership in both
parties consider China at this Federal
level the most exential threat to our
country there should be bipartisan
agreement on this bill future of our
country is at stake and we need to
ensure our children and grandchildren
are able to grow up in what we what will
continue to be the best country in the
world and please think of the future we
continue uh considering this
bill great thank you uh do you mind
having a copy for the clerk she would if
you leave that for said great do we have
any questions from committee members see
none thanks is there anybody else would
1183 okay seeing none we'll close the
public Hearing in
1183 and I had the blue sheet the blue
sheet uh has uh Tim kahill is in support
I represent kahill and Jason stock from
conquer from New Hampshire Timberland U
sh
yeah
for
chair all right good morning chairman
and members of the committee I'm
representative Jim Summers I represent
Rockingham District 20 today I'm
introducing HB uh 1232 an act
prohibiting New Hampshire state and
local governments from using and
applying a ban on Central Bank digital
currency
what is Central Bank digital currency
Central Bank digital currency also known
as abbreviated cbdc is a digital form of
central bank's money with the same value
and function as physical
cash there are potential benefits to
having a cbdc like most if not all of
the
benefits like having a cheaper faster
and more effective Financial
transactions however there are drawbacks
as well some of those positives are when
you receive a cash you take it to your
bank and you know that you have to wait
two or 3 days before it to clear so
it'll show in your
account some of those drawbacks though
however um include privacy may be eroded
at all Financial transactions may be
monitored and tracked in real time also
more personal information may be
collected The Government Can conduct
more surveillance as they can collect
more data and do more tracking and
monitoring cyber security risk may arise
as cbdc has to be online consequently
the network may be vulnerable to cyber
attacks because cbdc needs to be online
a shutdown of the network May collapse
the financial system the closing of
banks may occur as they're no longer
needed to provide these Financial
Services as the central bank would
provide
them they would be this was include
needed for deposits payment settlements
and other Financial products and
Services implementing a cbdc may prove
costly and complex as significant
investments in technology infrastructure
regulation Personnel Etc may be
required a cbdc can be programmed and as
such it may be used to have greater
control over individuals and business
finances the implementation of cbdc will
require changes to the Regulatory and
legal framework that governs the
financial sector Central Bank digital
currencies do not stop governments and
central banks from making bad policies
continue creating money as they wish
having a cbdc does not stop or prevent
economic recessions inflation from
rising increases in interest rates
unemployment Etc a cbdc could undermine
both the foundation and the future of
financial markets by reducing credit
availability
just dismantling Banks and challenging
the rise of
cryptocurrency a cbdc would be one of
the tools to fight crypto another
concern is the Central Storage of
financial information cbdcs can indulge
induce changes in the retail wholesale
and crossborder payments that have
negative spillover effects on monetary
policy through their effects on money
Velocity Bank deposit
um dismutation Vol of Bank Reserves
currency substitution and capital
flows poorly designed cbdc systems could
lead to imbalance of the demand and
supply of money causing EP epon excuse
me economic upheaval regulatory
complexities the revision of the
regulatory framework for cbdcs May
create legal and certainty deter
investors and slow down Economic
Development CB DCS have faced a plethora
of criticisms among those being that a
centrally managed centrally controlled
cbdc is a tool for coercion and control
and that it would allow the government
to spy on the citizenry and what we buy
and purchase and regulate and how we
monitor our money from day to
day states have already passed laws
Banning
cbdcs Alabama Florida North Carolina and
Texas China in fact wanted to control
their people from saving and wanted
their money to be circulated in their
economy so they have put expiration
dates on their cbdcs basically it's a
use it or lose it you can't save your
money in China because the expiration
date you have to spend it to keep it in
the economy therefore a cbdc can be
controlled and manipulated by the
government that it provides
it there's nothing stopping a government
from knowing what you are buying
expiring your currency limiting what you
can buy and instead of printing more
money they simply increase the number
that's
available now I know many folks have
complained about there was heay of where
the IRS was going to document everything
sold for over $600
and many citizens the United States have
complained about that why would have to
report purchases of over
$600 can you imagine that every report
of you buying a 50 Cent 75 cent candy
bar is reported to the federal
government due to this
CA I think not that's why I'm against
this bill I mean that's why I'm for this
bill to ban
cbdcs and I'm welcome to takeing your
questions I have a
question okay yes representative Fe I'm
going to try to keep it shorter than I
usually do that would be
great so I wrote a letter to the Federal
Reserve and I asked them very
specifically what were their plans for
cbdc not rumors I don't want to know
rumors I want to know
facts what were their plans and what
under what conditions could they ever
issue a CD cbdc and what laws are
involved that we would be in violation
of if we tried to stop it and I got
just matter of fact I got an answer back
from them two days ago they sent me a
document 5600 pages
long that included the comments from
everybody from PayPal Google every just
about every Bank in the country that had
an opinion on what they thought a cbdc
should look like that was the major
question some of the evaluations were
incredibly impressive they people went
various organizations especially PayPal
went went on for pages about well it
needs to do this it needs to do that and
I asked and one of the things that the
uh Central Bank said uh Federal Reserve
which is what we call it said that they
are in the process it'll be years before
they get this figur out because they
want to take all of that into
consideration and they are evaluating it
as far as any laws are concerned they
cannot issue according to them they
cannot issue a cbdc without a law being
passed in Congress and without funding
from Congress there are two bills in
Congress right now to stop it those
bills have been put through this is the
second time around for both of them that
are Banning
cbdcs uh they're not getting a lot of
popularity because mostly what everybody
wants to see is what do you think it's
going to look like cuz no one knows
right now what it's going to look like
they've been testing the infrastructure
they've been testing the ability to
maintain security maintain speed
maintain privacy but they have not
characterized it yet so we're getting a
lot of opinions from all over the state
all over the country all over the world
as a matter of fact some of the com com
comments are coming from the UK from
Japan from all kinds of places of what
it should look like so what you my
question to you is you want to ban
something that you don't know what it
looks like don't know what it's going to
do don't know the benefits you haven't
done a cost benefit cost benefit
analysis and yet you want the state to
disobey the Constitution of the United
States and ban something what litigation
what do you hope with going to gain from
that thank you for your question so what
I what I was looking at is actually
twofold one is how you are correct in
the fact that the United States has not
passed the cbdc as of yet in fact it's
still current study and they are deating
it in Congress as we
speak where this bill actually came to
be is following basically four states
that have implemented it as well as how
it's been abused overseas now now
granted we can't take it effect that the
United States would follow China's lead
and put time expirations on our currency
we can't say that we would follow China
to monitor everything that every person
in a household would Monitor and collect
but this I just might say these four
Bill these four laws that pass these
four states this I'm not I'm not talking
about a partisan bill here we passed
Florida 116
to1 in favor it was unanimous in the
Senate it passed Indiana 129
to2 Republicans and Democrats both in
both States voted overwhelmingly in
favor of this ban so it's not a partisan
bill I mean it is a partisan it's
bipartisan bill it's not partisan in
fact of political parties or what the
usage of the thing is it's a simple
basic as far as Florida's law it was one
line ended one sentence added on the end
of the definition of money in their
Statute in this it is adding one section
onto the end of the monetary scope of
the RSA predominately it can be if we
find that it actually is and comes to a
point to where it is suable then we can
actually repeal it it is one section all
by itself not tied to anything else
except for the final add-on explanation
to the monetary use in
State I I I I'm sorry I have one more
question or follow on'll finish yeah yes
sir further question further question
and it will be briefer than the yes this
yeah I'm
sorry I have the bill from Florida and I
have the fysical note on it and the
fisical note on it says and I can quote
it and I can give you the fysical bill
the fysical note for the Florida bill it
says this law is unconstitutional and if
it passes it will cause Untold
undetermined damage to the economics of
the state and they passed a bill that
says that that their physical note says
in writing attached to the bill that it
is unconstitutional and will cause
Untold damage and that's what you that's
the litigation you're putting us in the
way
of would you
believe would you believe you don't have
believe representative kid
thank you Mr chairman um may I ask two
questions Mr chairman may I ask two
questions thank you uh okay uh my first
question is um as I'm sure you're aware
uh a great deal of banking these days is
done online I myself do almost all my
banking online um why would uh Central
Bank digital currency be more in
dangered uh of being uh disrupted by
systems it's actually not more difficult
the the main thing is the centralization
so where where we are divided between
many state federally owned local
business small business Banks where all
of our money is Diversified among many
different things you might have an
account at at Merl Lynch marac Valley or
at Morgan Stanley the fact is with the
central bank is it po puts everybody in
the entire country's money into one spot
and so all you would have to have is one
target to be able to hit
Nationwide thank you for your answer uh
second question is um if uh cdbc were to
um go into practice um which I gather
from the uh previous questioner um is
not likely anytime soon uh but if it
were to go into practice uh you've
you've mentioned dangers of uh Federal
tracking and control um which honestly
I'm not sure I understand but uh for the
for the sake of argument um taking your
your position um would anybody be forced
cdbc honestly that's still open because
as of the cbdc does not exist as of yet
I'm sorry could you talk a little slower
I couldn't hear you oh sure um as of
right now it's unknown because the CBC
does not exist as of yet if we are
followed to where other countries that
have implemented cbdc like Nigeria which
it failed and like China then everyone
is required to use it in
China thank you and then Nigeria
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
our questions um your your bill uh has
uh a definition at the end uh it says uh
Central Bank digital currency means a
digital currency used by a central bank
and made available to the public get get
closer did you hear what I what I said
Central Bank uh digital currency means a
digital currency used by a central bank
and made available to the public and I
want to focus on to the public parts so
that sounds like a retail uh Central
Bank digital currency but not uh one
that's intank uh would you agree with
that that is correct so there's two
different divisions of cbdc and how
they're utilized there is the retail and
there's the wholesale the wholesale is
generally defined as money and how it's
transferred between countries or large
scale where retail would entitle the
money or the banks that us normal
exchange and so a retail Central Bank
digital currency has the potential of
making our current banking system
obsolete uh potentially right that's
yes okay great thank you very much thank
you uh let's see Tim
Morgan in
opposition
um thank you very much I'm so I'm
opposed I am opposed to this bill I
although I understand the concerns
behind it I think the first reason why
I'm opposed to it is it's massively
premature I haven't read 6600 pages of
of like a ran spear did but like I've
seen some of the uh documents the
Federal Reserve point out there a long
ways away from doing it they have a lot
of doubts about it they also like know
that it wouldn't be universally popular
if they did it
um and um two other and one of the fears
that's being ProMag about it is that
we'll eliminate all cash and there's um
I was listening to AM radio the first
time in a while because I was listening
to a UNH basketball game on way back
from Manchester so I heard all the ads I
had on WG am which mostly runs uh I
guess conservative talk show programming
and you know they had um you know Fox
News host saying you need to buy gold to
protect yourself from the cbdc and they
had the whole thing about how you won't
be able to have a yard sale or Etc and
so the part about cash I think is uh it
would be a very bad idea to abolish cash
but although we are kind of moving
towards uh less and less use of use of
cash and actually one of the reasons why
the Federal Reserve is unlikely to
abolish cash is because um the well the
entire money supply is uh is a debt of
the US government and that includes uh a
trillion dollars worth of $100 bills
which are mostly held overseas so I
don't think they're uh I don't think
they're too eager to repay that uh
interest free loan of of a trillion
dollars that they've uh that the uh the
holders of those dollar $100 bills have
very generously made to the United
States so that alone is a reason why
they're probably unlikely to abolish
cash and they don't want
they the wording the FED they're not
eager to move forward with this they see
a lot of problems with it and then one
of but then one other point I want to
make is we already have a centralized
cbdc only it's decentralized so we most
of us use mostly uh online payments so
that's um that's
uh that's monitored by that's being
operated by very large um and rather um
not at all C organized uh Consortium of
banking institutions and others and
those those institutions are uh you know
politically very powerful so there' be a
lot of push back uh to anything any
attempt to like bring in a cbdc so
that's not something the Federal Reserve
can really do unilaterally and it
also it's also extremely profitable to
people who are operating those online
systems um there's you know you probably
we've had some bills about swipe fees
they're a very large uh you know they're
very large uh portion of the economy and
maybe and this bill of course uh doesn't
do anything one way or another about
that that is one of the rational for
cbdc is in that would uh eliminate the
swipe fees and also make it easier for
people who currently don't have bank
accounts um and the uh other thing is we
already have the surveillance um like we
had the tragic incident in conquered
year where uh two people were two people
were murdered and the uh murderer and I
do remember his name but I don't want to
say it here um we he was making a lot of
efforts to live off the grid and um he
was trying to stay underground as much
as he could but nevertheless we were
able the prosecutors when he murdered
those two people and figured out he and
he became a suspect they were able to um
they were still able to very effectively
track just about all of his transactions
in great detail all of his movements so
um so that that's happening all that's
happening already and that's nothing new
like even quarter of a century ago when
23 years ago when we had the 9911
attacks we were they were also like uh
trying to fly under the radar and once
again um once again after the after the
terrorist attacks we were able we were
able to like figure out a great detail
who these people were where they went
what they spent money on so the horse is
probably already out of the barn in this
issue so it's just a question of uh what
form the electronic payments system
should take and I don't
so I think this bill the concerns behind
it are valid but I think it's premature
and also we these the Federal Reserve is
the uh 12 federal reserve banks are
collectively the Central Bank of our
country and we are in the United States
of America the United States dollar is
our currency so these things that POS a
lot of legal difficulties because they
uh the cbdc deposits would be uh
presumably legal tender just like uh
just like Federal Reserve notes are are
now so
um I hoping to keep under the two
minutes on the pink card but I didn't
but anyway that's uh that's why that's
why I'm opposed to the bills so and you
can ask me any questions if you want
whether I can answer them or not I don't
know but I don't think there's any
questions oh good thanks thank you thank
you okay chair we'll call in
representative
bill
thank you Mr
chair I wanted to start off just by
answering some of the some of the
questions that were asked or some of the
statements about we don't have enough
information we have more than enough
information to know how bad this is you
know we're talking about decades ago
where there was a quote by Henry
Kissinger that said who controls the
money controls the
world one world government and agenda
2030 is full underway and has been for
over a
decade there's many people in this state
one is actually out of state right now
that's speaking on this cbdc this is all
he's doing his name is Aon day he's an
expert he's written a book that's called
The Final Countdown crypto Gold Silver
and the people's last stand against
tyranny by Central Bank digital
currencies
cbdcs I will get every single one of you
that book I'm a little disappointed that
we're missing 10 Representatives here
because this is such a huge issue I also
wanted to speak about Florida's bill um
Aaron day actually had a one-on-one
conversation specifically with our
governor DeSantis of Florida's governor
Dan santis about this
because representative Spire you're
actually correct spear sorry um you're
actually correct in that bill doesn't do
anything there's no protection there's
no true Banning of
cbdcs um Aaron day also spoke with
representative uh I mean uh Senator Ted
Cruz in Texas about this in their bill
and even though it goes further it's
still not enough but Senator Cruz
specifically said and he's there so he
knows that this is happening no matter
what there's no one that's going to be
able to stop it it's coming down the
pike I really I would appreciate you you
you reading the the book If you're
willing I will give it to you this is
about global Finance change
so you know there was a question that
you said about what is it what does it
look like and in the first chapter of
his book I'm going to read this and then
I will be uh I'll be done is this though
the work of fiction in the first chapter
the story draws inspiration from
surveillance technologies that inade our
world today if left unchecked the
scenario painted within this first
chapter could be hauntingly could be a
hauntingly accurate reflection of life
in the not so distant future this book
aims to shed light on the truth behind
the tale unearthing the grand designs to
bring such a reality into existence even
in places like the United States more
importantly the bulk of this book seeks
to equi you with the knowledge and tools
necessary to combat The burgeoning
Tyranny cuz it's coming the time to act
is now the power to change the course of
our future lies within our
grasp so this is what it would look like
this is your scenario the price
basically of submission it took barely a
decade for the world they knew to
crumble after a series of planned
economic crises and the rise of
authoritarian re regimes the world saw
the widespread adoption of social Credit
Systems and Central baked digital
currencies by 2032 New York City Once A
bustling life with energy had been
transformed into a dystopian nightmare
the United States previously a symbol of
freedom and democracy had succumbed to
digital tyranny Despair and hopelessness
filled the city with a Relentless
onslaught of propaganda on the airwaves
and the constant hum of drones overhead
casting dark oppressive Shadows on the
streets surveillance had become a way of
life with security cameras on every
street face scanners in every building
and tracking built into every mobile
device the very idea of privacy had been
erased supplemented by unrelenting gaze
of government now capable of monitoring
controlling and manipulating citizens
lives with chilling
Precision I won't take up any more time
of the committee I will offer that I
will pay for the book for you at for all
of you but I will also give you um Over
The Last 5 Years where the the
government in regards with surveillance
not just on money and the control that
they have had um in in in many many
citizens lives and I'll give you even
real world examples in New Hampshire so
you know that this isn't just something
that is made out of thin air it's been
happening it's been Progressive and we
need to do something to stop it thank
you
thank you uh is it possible we can have
your uh with your testimony so yes I
will I will email that to you in the
file that' be great appreciate it all
right thank you very much oh oh we do
have a question I do not a book please
don't count me yet okay okay all right
all
right representative MCU has a
question would you
believe rep a thanks um would you
believe that all the bills in this
committee go to subcommittee and have at
least one subcommittee meeting and at
least five out of six or eight of the
subcommittee that'll hear that'll work
with this bill are actually here just in
case in case you didn't know no I did
not know that but that makes me feel
better okay but it it I am sad that you
know you're declining learning about the
information why wouldn't you why
book
I'll take the book
question okay thank you very much little
question little question you really have
a question yes okay you prefaced this by
saying that was a work of fiction that
that you what you described and you want
us to make decisions based on a work of
fiction
no would you
believe would you believe thank you very
much thank you very much
okay I have still one more card okay um
Melissa e
iess okay welcome to the house Commerce
Committee thank
you
okay well I am in support of this bill
um to prohibit cbdcs in the state of New
Hampshire and well look at us here we
are C talking about
cbdcs I knew this was
coming um
so if you could look up the Hamilton
project all you got to do is just look
it up online just write it on the
Hamilton project it was with it was
announced in 2020 it was with the
Federal Bank fedal Central Bank of
Boston with MIT they did a whole
research program on cbdc
so please look that up it's called The
Hamilton
project then look up fed now program the
FED now program was became active
in July on July 20th
2023 that allows the Federal Reserve to
be able to receive transactions in real
time they're going to make it come
across like it's it's for your safety
for your security for your convenience I
mean really do we really need more
convenience right now um in place of our
freedom it's really about control the
cbdc is
programmable you you will be controlled
on what you buy and what you sell it's
Society I mean first you're going to
have to have your digital
ID to get your C to get your digital
currency I mean we might as well go into
the metaverse and buy digital
property I mean that's where we're at
right
um this is not good for the American
people it's not good for our state it
it's it's it will control us all and if
you love your kids or your
grandparents I highly suggest that you
support this bill and you know what even
if you oppose this bill or even if it
goes straight up to the governor and the
governor opposes it I'm not
participating in it I refuse to be
controlled and I hope that everyone will
not comply because it's
acquiescence is where we got is how we
got where we are right now and you if
you know the history of the Federal
Reserve that should tell you something
okay it's controlled
by the walberg's the Rothchilds the
rockefellas who developed it in
on I don't I don't understand if you if
you don't understand that
um basically they just want to control
us
and we'll be sorry if we don't support
this
bill
great thank you very much for your
testimony any
questions I I think they're questioned
out thank um if you could please look up
the Hamilton project just read about it
it's so easy all you got to do is just
type it on your phone and and it'll
bring up the Hamilton project type in
the FED now
program please fair enough thank you
thank
you okay having no more
uh in terms of what I see here is um
representative Elvin C is in support
Ryan Hil from New Hampshire Bankers in
support uh representative Michael
Granger in
support
uh Kelly already she already spoke uh
Matt s Sabrina something is in support
um Jim Summers in support uh Janie
Bernardi is uh is in support uh Jonathan
Leslie is in support and Gary York uh is
also in support and with that I will
close the public hearing and we'll now
go on to
our well we're pretty close to time
amazing
okay um so House Bill
1674 Keith did you fill out a
fine we're doing good on time I'm GNA
try not to ruin it okay great for the
record my name is Keith Ammon represent
Hillsboro District 42 the towns of New
Boston lineboro and Mount
Vernon and honorable members of the
committee I am introducing House Bill
167 4 relative to establishing the New
Hampshire legal tender act and
establishing a state bullion
depository so this bill does three
things uh and I want to say this is a
novel bill this this uh approach has not
been tried in recent memory in the state
so uh this is not one of the perennial
bills that come before our committee but
it's a a new a new
bill and uh My Philosophy is that a bill
is just a
conversation until and unless the
governor signs it into law so I think
you'll hear some uh pros and cons about
this bill uh and I know the committee
will be open-minded uh and and I think
you'll hear some new information that
that we may not have heard before the
bill does three things it
establishes gold and Sil silver as legal
tender uh other states have done
that it it uh suggests uh politely to
the state treasurer to set up a state
bullion
depository and at least one state has
already done that that's Texas and a few
others are proposing this
idea and then the third thing which is
uh what made me interested in this
concept is it uh allows for the issuance
of digital tokens that are backed by the
bullion on deposit it and when you think
about uh gold and silver have been
valuable for 5,000 years nobody disputes
that gold and silver has value and will
very likely continue to have
value and uh over time it it keeps up
with
inflation uh and we know we've
experienced some inflation recently but
if you if you tokenize
it and you allow it to be tradable on
the internet now all of a sudden instead
of carrying around gold or trying to
physically trade the gold you're trading
a representation of the ownership of
that gold and that token can operate 247
it can operate globally it can operate
through space and time which physical
gold cannot and so the idea would be the
state treasurer would be responsible for
overseeing potentially Contracting out
to a third
party uh the over s it of the Boolean
depository and making sure that audits
regular audits of that bullan depository
match up with the tokens that are
issued um and so you know one concern
might be that more tokens will be issued
then there is gold on deposits but with
something called proof of reserves on
the blockchain you can make sure that
that's Ironclad that that never happens
uh which would uh give trust uh to the
whole the whole system
one other aspect that's interesting is
it's possible to that this could be
self-funding and be a source of revenue
for the
state and I think we're GNA there's
going to be some experts coming behind
me that can explain this in more detail
but with the Advent of something called
a smart
contract it can be programmed into that
token that every time it changes hands
uh a small transaction fee can be
automatically uh you know deducted from
the total could be a half a percent or
something very small but over time every
time those tokens tra trade hands it
would transfer a little bit of that
ownership to the state and make the
depository self-funding and
potentially if it was uh happening on a
global scale that could be a significant
source of revenue for the state so um
it's a big
idea um I ask that you give it
consideration and uh you know maybe some
parts are things we we can act on and
some parts need work and I know this
committee does a good job of uh slicing
and dicing up bills pretty good so uh
please please be open-minded that's my
request so I I'm not going to take
questions because I I uh I think the
questions that you have will will come
behind me and I'm concerned about the
time I've already taken up eight minutes
the uh the only question I have is
should I even ask any questions or can
we just wait till we just get back in
the committee and do it then well
because I've got a lot of questions I'm
going to I'm going to
respectfully not take question I have a
question about the purp I have some
questions about the purpose of the bill
that I think should be answered by the
prime sponsor not experts on blockchain
anyone who is testifying I'm sorry
anyone who is testifying if they are not
interested in taking questions that is
their prerogative I can't force them to
take
questions so I can all I urge is this
bill is just the beginning we're just
getting our feet wet we have a long way
to go as you know we're going to put
this to subcommittee and there was going
to be a lot of work on this bill okay
but I I understand that we all have lots
and lots of questions and evidently I
got tons and tons of cards here and I'm
sure there'll be somebody in this pile
who will be willing to take your
question but I cannot force people to
testify okay but will somebody test will
may I follow up a question to you Mr
chairman will somebody be test ifying
regarding the purpose purposes of the
bill rather than the technicalities yes
I I got the purpose pretty clearly from
represent amm that is but I have
question they would like to use the our
blockchain concept technology to use it
in a way that people can pay their bills
or use an exchange using gold and
silver and I have questions about did I
get it right and I just heard this just
now and I heard that so I I I think
we're pretty straightforward on what the
what they're trying to do it's just
whether you whether you buy into it or
not is another story so let's
listen Okay um I have a fair amount of
cards and people in support of this bill
but what I want to do is I have several
cards that they didn't say they're for
or against so I'm going to just get
through that crowd and then we can hear
from everybody who in strong support of
the bill so first I have is Katherine
Heck from The New Hampshire Municipal
Association
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to testify for the record my name is
Katherine heck and I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association or the
234 cities and towns in New Hampshire
happy new to you all and welcome back um
the reason um I am here today is because
I have spoken with the prime sponsor on
the bill and we had some concerns around
whether this was mandated language that
municipalities comply with accepting
silver and gold as legal tender or
whether it's a May and it's enabling
legislation and after speaking with the
sponsor we have identified several areas
of the bill that could be cleaned up
because our concerns are that silver and
gold are not um currently federally
recognized legal tender they're not
currently accepted at local banks and
they're traded on the Futures Market or
comx so with that the price changes and
it fluctuates daily and our concern that
we can't seem to cure for in addition to
some of our internal controls around how
we would Safeguard these dollars or how
we would use them in our day-to-day
operations are really around how we
would value that in our books because
it's much like going um on vacation to a
foreign country and using the exchange
rate especially if it's physical silver
and gold bullion and that price can V
vary every single day so how would we
would cure for that in our our tax you
know in taxation when we need to protect
every dollar which has a US dollar value
so that was our main concern around the
bill in addition to some of the storage
and some of the deposit issues if the
state treasur is the only depository for
us to accept that that could be up to
two two and a half hours for some of our
cities and towns to get to and we're re
re ired by law to deposit $1,500 or more
on a weekly W within 48 Hours of receipt
so we had some really logistical
concerns around the bill on the digital
side well that certainly alleviates our
physical um internal controls around
that commodity it would be really around
again how do we cure for needing to
justify dollar for dollar and having
almost like that foreign exchange rate
um occurring within our Municipal
Financial accounting on a regular basis
so I just wanted to address those
concerns but I look forward to working
with the sponsor um and the committee
and subcommittee on any issues
municipalities may have moving forward
thank you thank you we do have a oh you
just no it's a question
question the last page you want to pull
it
close the last page of the bill uh
indicates overall there would be a
significant increase in local
expenditures starting in FY
2025 that's correct because currently as
the bill reads without any amendments or
modifications someone could pay their
property tax um as the bill reads
currently in in so or gold bullion and
therefore we would not only have to
create highly technical safeguards
around the physical asset right itself
um we would also have to have additional
internal controls we would have to hire
specialist to help us understand when to
trade the gold or silver to to not lose
any dollar Ford dooll value because
right now gold is down $7 today so if I
bought it yesterday or someone paid
their taxes yesterday because it's not
based on the US dollar at the moment um
which is the the current disconnect it's
like that foreign exchange rate so those
would be our costs in trying to cure for
that as well as hire the appropriate
expertise that we would need um at the
municipal level
any other questions see none thank you
very much thank you okay next is
uh uh Mr Wong I I I guess I have trouble
with your Keen Keen is your yeah yeah
Administration
good morning Mr chair and good morning
members of the committee my name is Keen
M Wong uh tax policy Council of New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration um we the Department of
Revenue was asked to prepare a fiscal
note on the spill and we prepared it and
what I'm handing out around is a uh
fiscal noqu guide of the uh the f going
to be prepared um the department does
not have a position on this bill um the
the the reason why we are here today is
just to um sort of bring to the
attention of the um of the com committee
that um that some of the concerns that
the department has on the bill
specifically in regards to um
the for the the currency not the
currency but the exchange rates that's
being used used between the functional
currency and the US dollar uh when the
when the business unit is trying to pays
taxes there is language in the bill that
refers to uh that the the business unit
are able to maintain their books in
certain functional currency and then has
the option to pay taxes in that
functional currency or to convert it to
to US Dollars um so the uh the the
department feels that there is some kind
of maybe some kind of tightening of
language might be helpful to to indicate
how that's that's being managed because
uh the department is concerned with um
the that the performance of the or the
financial performance of uh of a
business unit within one functional
currency may not be fully represented
throughout the full taxable period um if
it's kept in one functional currency and
then being converted back back and forth
uh throughout the throughout the period
um and then raises the concerns of okay
um is there going to be uh a currency
exchange gain or currency exchange loss
that occurs during that conversion and
how that is recognized I believe the
language current language in the bill is
that there is no recognition of U of tax
impact um which might um which might be
in conflict with uh with how uh the
federal government treats the um the
exchange transactions
um and essentially the other concerns
that we have is just uh may not be as as
significant probably it's just more of a
uh administrative cost concern in terms
of um if taxpayers are will be going to
use um species gold or silver um we
might incre additional cost in terms of
security transportation in terms of
trying to um secure those
um assets when when it's being paid to
the Dr um the the rest of the um the
rest of my comments will be in the um in
the notes that I passed out in more
detail um and um and I'm happy to to
take any questions and also if um if the
the committee wish to work with the Dr
in terms of trying to you know figure
out um areas of our concerns and trying
to alleviate that um and we be happy to
to work with the committee as
well so so I have a question um I'm sort
of hearing this whole issue is exchange
and and and at what day they pay the
bill based upon what the gold is worth
that day right so I'm thinking how now
corporations International corporations
are struggling when it comes with
currency problems and when they pay
their bills and when they just so that
that I could see that if there was all
of a sudden one day the current this
some other stock was currency was worth
a lot more that they suddenly would
flood making their payments and then and
then other times they wouldn't and then
they have to make that decision well how
much penalty will'll take if I don't pay
on time so I was wondering how much of a
problem does Dr have with that kind of
uh currency fluctuation issues uh that's
a very good question I right now we
don't really have any kind of issues
with that because uh firstly the um the
taxpayers are keeping the records in US
Dollars although they they might have
transactions abroad um their books in in
in the US is in in US currency um and
then if they do have any kind of Foreign
Exchange transactions um any kind of
gain uh from that for let's say if they
were trading in foreign currency the
gains in in the foreign currency would
should be a taxable um item and should
be reported as some kind of a as a gain
that's reported on
oh yeah interesting
okay okay so just the price of gold
might be effect whether they're
profitability profit interesting because
because a taxpayer might see might be
reporting their um the activities in in
one currency and or in in one commodity
and then um when it comes times to when
it comes time to report their us numbers
they might just wait until all the
opportune time say oh yeah now the
currency exch exchange rate is really
low let's convert it to US Dollars and
just report that there you go a little
bit of scheming going on I assume yeah
okay thank you very
much all right uh last Brandon uh Garren
Justice and uh first to seen you this
year and I assume we will see you some
more going on with this
future this the rest rest of this month
and uh Happy New
Year Mr ladies and gentlemen my name is
Brandon I
am I am a senior Assistant Attorney
General also the chief of the consumer
protection and anti trust Bureau at the
New Hampshire Department of Justice um
the Department of Justice takes no
position on hb1
1674 but uh we flagged in a fiscal note
a couple of dueling concerns that we
have with the bill as currently drafted
I thought it would be prudent to expand
on both of those concerns today uh so
those concerns are you know overly Broad
and unclear enforcement Authority that
is assigned to the Attorney General's
office under the bill as currently
drafted and as a result of that and very
much related um the potential for a
significant fiscal impact on the
Department of Justice if this bill were
passed in its current form so I I'll
start with the the first issue which is
the overly broad enforcement Authority
typically statutes that anticipate the
Attorney General whether it's the
Consumer Protection Bureau or another
division of the AG's office enforcing a
statute um they have specific
enforcement Authority as to what
provisions of a statute we enforce and
how we would go about enforc enforcing
that so the statute that you all hear
about most frequently is New Hampshire's
consumer protection act so I'll use that
as an example under the consumer
protection act if anyone engaged in
trade or Commerce in the state were to
engage in unfair deceptive Acts or
practices as specifically
um defined by that statute the consumer
protection antitrust Bureau has the
ability to go into court um seek an
injunction to stop that behavior to seek
specific civil penalties to punish that
behavior to seek restitution for those
that are grieved and also to bring
criminal charges if
appropriate um this bill as currently
worded just very broadly assigns
enforcement of the entire Bill to the
Attorney General's office without any
specification as to what specific
sections of this Bill we would enforce
or how we would go about enforcing it if
we were to receive a a complaint from
anybody about a potential violation and
that's really problematic that you the
way that we approach enforcement of all
of the the numerous statutes that are
assigned to our office folks submit
complaints to us whether it's the
Consumer Protection Bureau or any other
Division and our process is to look to
see whether the facts that are alleged
in the complaint um specifically allege
a violation of any statute that we are
tasked with enforcing and the way this
is currently drafted I mean there are
certain sections of this bill which you
know you could look at and you know
determine for example you know there's a
Prohibition on certain tax liability in
certain circumstances there's a a
Prohibition on individual's ability to
compel versus not compel others to do
certain things so like step one we could
look at that and say you know yes there
is or isn't a violation of something
that we enforce but then
our calculus is what can we do about it
as the Department of Justice what tools
has the legislature given us to remedy a
violation of a statute it's completely
unclear and undefined by this statute so
any action that if we were to take it we
would basically have to guess and say
you know well under the consumer
protection act we're able to you know
seek civil penalties for example so
perhaps we can seek civil penalties here
anybody who we attempted to seek civil
penalties against would be able to say
this statute doesn't give you the
authority to do that and they would
likely have a compelling
argument so you know there is three
sections in this bill where the Attorney
General's enforcement authorities
specifically identified one is just
broad overarching enforcement of the
entire um bill which I think is really
problematic for a number of reasons one
of which is you know there are a number
of sections of this bill that you know
like the establishment of a depository
that potentially we would be responsible
for overseeing the enforcement of just
the establishment of a depository that
is well outside the ordinary law
enforcement role that the Attorney
General typically plays but there are a
couple of more specific sections um that
assign attorney general enforcement
which I I highlight for you and have you
know additional concerns on um I'll
point to looks like Roman numeral three
under Section 5 d10 conflicts of
interest the bill as currently drafted
would have the any violation um of an
allegation of any person overseeing this
depository who had a conflict of
interest in administering that
responsibility um this bill would assign
the Attorney General to determine um
fines or other legal penalties
determined by the attorney generals that
we could use in potentially removing
somebody from that position the
overseeing of folks that are in certain
positions in this case it would be State
positions is certainly uh you know can
be an attorney general function but here
this this would be an enormous
responsibility anytime anybody were to
file a complaint with the AG's office
and say anybody who's overseeing this
depository has a conflict of interest of
any sort we would have an obligation to
then go in and investigate that and that
that sort of gets to the second point
which is there's a potential for
significant fiscal impact on the
department in order to carry out that
role um we would need potentially and
it's it's hard to Define because it's so
Broad and it's unclear what sort of um
complaints and what sort of obligations
we would have but it's easy to see a
world where this could result in
significant increase in the number of
complaints that we receive um which
could result in the need for additional
paralegals to review them attorneys to
review them and investigators to go out
and investigate these things in order to
determine whether there has been a
violation that we can enforce and so the
other section that you know has attorney
general enforcement which I think may be
the most problematic of the three um is
Roman numeral 4 under Section 5 D20
confiscations requisitions seizures and
other actions void so at the very end of
the section under Roman numeral 4 states
that the depository shall refer any
matter relating to an action described
by subsection a to the ad Journey
general for
resolution and so I I have a couple of
concerns here it references subsection a
um any action described by subsection a
I have looked at this section at least
five times to try to figure out which
subsection a that is specifically
referring to and I don't know um I think
that there is a significant lack of
clarity in a section that is supposed to
be limited to a very specific subsection
of this bill um and the reader cannot
easily Define which of the sub many
subsection A's contained in this bill
the Attorney General would be able to
resolve disputes under um which gets to
the the second problem with the use of
the word um they'd be referred to the
attorney general for resolution
resolution is an incredibly Brad broad
term um that could be interpreted to
mean mediation um alternative dispute
resolution of various different kinds um
could be interpreted to mean enforcement
could be inter determined to mean
criminal prosecution I mean there are
many ways to resolve a dispute but this
bill does not provide enough Clarity for
the Attorney General to understand what
responsibility it has under this
specific subsection it's I think all of
that collectively has the potential to
significantly increase the the fiscal
impact on the doj which would
necessitate I think potentially
significant additional resources to
carry this out but I I also think that
even if those resources were provided
likely there would be multiple
challenges in ter determining what
specific enforcement Authority we have
if this were passed as currently written
and happy to take any questions that
you
uh Christopher
Russo and I asked Chris better five
minutes can you do it in three two to
[Music]
threey prepare testimony be great okay
we have it we have it here
and yeah
yeah so is if is representative Granger
here oh you are here okay I'm sorry we
just we lost your card but we'll get you
next
s on thank you uh I'm a fast talker so
I'll do my best to get through this uh
chairman hunt Vice chairman Ammon and
honorable members of the committee my
name is Christopher Russo I'm an
economist with prior appointments at the
US Congress Jo economic committee the US
Senate Banking Committee the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York and the F
Federal Reserve Bank of Chicago
I'm currently completing my doctoral
dissertation in economics at George
Mason University I also hold a MERS in
financial mathematics from the
University of Chicago thank you for
inviting me to testify this morning
about the New Hampshire sound money act
if enacted the ACT would declare gold
and Silver's legal tender it would
establish a state depository for gold
and silver bullion and enable a digital
currency for Bullion back digital
payments I hope to inform the Committees
that deliberates over this bill for
creating alternative to the US dollar
and for sake of discussion I'll refer to
this alternative as the granite coin
after your great
state my expert testimony can be
summarized by three key points first the
dollar has lost most of its value since
the US left the gold standard in
1933 ultimately the erosion of the
Dollar's value was due to unsustainable
deficits and debt incurred by the
federal government over the past 100 or
so years and that was sometimes enabled
by the federal reserve's easy money
policy policies last week the US
national debt reached an all-time high
of $34
trillion the Congressional budget office
projects that the national debt will
continue to soar under current law
unless Congress acts to restore fiscal
responsibility the Dollar's purchasing
power will continue to deteriorate over
time my second point is that a granite
coin could offer New Hampshire citizens
a hedge against inflation by design a
granite coin would be fully backed by a
fixed quantity of underlying species
like gold or silver for example one
Granite coin might be defined as one
gram of gold the consumer purchasing
power of a granite coin would fluctuate
as been uh pointed out earlier in this
hearing as gold rose or fell in
value but if the granite coin was widely
adopted as money then competitive market
forces would tend to stabilize its
consumer purchasing power over time my
third point is however a commodity money
is not itself a panaca for inflation the
market forces that tend to stabilize
consumer prices might take years or in
some cases even decades to fully operate
and only if the coin was adopted as
money moreover commodity money could
incurs own economic costs uh as with all
policy choices choosing a monetary
standard involves tradeoffs between
imperfect Alternatives as you consider
the potential costs and benefits of a
granite coin two stylized examples might
be helpful to show how a commodity
standard to work in principle I'll just
stick to one of them because I know
we're limited on time this is the
example being my prepared testimony
suppose there's a decline in the
Public's demand for money um say there's
a local recession and so declining
incomes lead to people choosing to hold
less money that might reduce the value
or the purchasing power of granite coins
below their non-monetary value for
example their value in the creation of
computer chips or jewelry the
interesting thing about competitive
market forces in the case of a commodity
standard is that firms or individuals
would then take their excess Granite
coins excess in terms of what they Des
desire to hold not in terms of how much
species on deposit and redeem them for
species and in doing so there's this
nice type of equilibrium in which the
declining level of granite coin in the
economy would tend to restore its
purchasing power back to where it
was uh so in addition to considering
these sorts of costs and benefits of
creating a granite coin uh I'd really
urge the committee to consider how the
granite coin would fit into the broader
Federal regulatory framework and again I
know we're Limited in time so I'll just
very briefly mention uh there's
considerations around how this would fit
into Federal anti-money laundering laws
there's concerns or at least
considerations around what this would be
considered at the federal level and who
would regulate it is it a currency is it
a commodity is it a investment
contract uh could Granite coin be held
by people uh aside from individuals
could it be held by Banks or money
transmitters or asset managers uh again
I don't have time time to address these
in detail but they're important things I
urge you to consider as you you continue
to deliberate um and finally I hope that
this hearing serves as a wakeup call to
my friends in Washington DC A Century of
inflation has made
Americans skeptical of uh the United
States dollars and you know you know
from my history I I sort of have a
professional obligation to be a partisan
for the US dollar but uh in this case I
think I can appreciate why people are
skeptical and so I POs to my friends in
Washington DC will we fairly compete for
the space in the Wallace of the
residents and citizens of New Hampshire
by restoring fiscal responsibility at
the federal level or will we return to
the Crooked politics of financial
repression and inflationary Finance the
American people patiently await our
answer thank you again for the
invitation to speak I pleas please to
questions uh representative Gibbs has a
question uh thank you um I'm honestly
not sure that the witness is the right
person to answer these questions but I'm
going to uh ask them as best I can and
may I ask three questions three
questions okay thank you are they short
brief simple questions I'll make them as
brief no big story along each one right
just yes I'll make them as brief as I
can thank you Mr
chairman uh first question is um are New
Hampshire citizens clamoring to card
around gold and silver to pay their
bills
ma'am I think you're exactly right I'm
not the right person to answer that
question I can talk to you as an
academic as an expert in monetary
economics I can tell you that uh
historically one of the costs of a gold
standard commodity or any sort of specic
monetary standard is that uh there's
wear and tear on the physical goal
that's a cost uh it's costly to try to
uh as you describe card around gold and
silver I think one of the potential
Promises of this legislation is that
people would not be cardig and gold and
silver they'd have a app on their phone
a digital wallet in which they could
exchange on the blockchain uh quite
costlessly uh uh uh claims on gold held
on deposit and that leads me to my
second
question uh which is apparently um these
uh digital this digital currency based
on gold and silver is not clear to me
from the bill uh who issue this digital
currency so my question is why would we
want to trust a digital currency which
could be issued by private persons or
organizations uh which would the
currency would supposedly be backed by
gold and silver uh which is in the
possession of these private persons uh
why would we want to trust that more
than the dollar backed by the full faith
and credit of the United States of
America representative I think it's a
very interesting question I I'll again
just say that um I did not draft the
bill but on my plain English reading of
it and maybe this can be clarified in
subsequent amendments the coin would be
issued by the state government um you
raay a much more fundamental and quite
interesting question about historically
why were people willing as they were uh
to trust the money issued by private
Banks uh that were claimed to be backed
by gold and silver um one one reason why
historically people were able to trust
in those promises say you have a bank
note issued by a private institution
that's claimed to backed by some amount
of gold or silver why are you willing to
trust that that money is actually there
that underlying species there well
because it can be redeemed on demand
people would regularly take their Bank
notes to their um uh local banks and uh
redeem in terms of the gold or silver
value that's a type of Market discipline
that helps a system like this work and
again my plan English reading the bill
suggest that that Redemption would be
allowable under the wall if this was to
pass thank you I'll reserve my third
question for another witness thank you
ma'am thank you very
much and and your your testimony yeah we
passed
it it's this one this one here you got
this you got it okay okay all right now
represent
Granger I apologize is not calling you
sooner but I'm not a co-sponsor so it's
okay okay no but oh theoretically we we
always supposed to take
reps first because you we know you have
to go on to another your own committee
and so we're not supposed to hold you up
in here so I I appreciate it
um so uh thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is
representative Granger I'm uh here
representing straford District 2 I'm not
a co-sponsor of this bill uh because I
but I like the bill and you guys were
talking about cbdcs earlier this is a
much better alternative to cbdcs if you
if you if you want a digital currency
that has a lot of the benefits of a cbdc
uh when it comes to convenience and
everything else but you don't want to
have a federal bank uh pulling the purse
strings and uh destroying your savings
by printing money and you want it to be
a little bit more tied to reality uh
then I believe that this is a very good
alternative uh so I want to talk a
little bit about uh Reserve current over
history right now the US dollar is a
reserve currency um and what a reserve
currency is it's basically a currency
that is used to back other currencies so
if you have a country it's a smaller
country you can take us doll and you can
store them in reserve and then you can
print your own money redeemable on
demand for US dollars for instance and
the US dollar used to be uh backed by
gold as was mentioned previously uh it
currently is not uh as a result of that
it's uh gone crazy and we've had some
significant issues with inflation and uh
the decimation of savings accounts and
all the problems that uh ensue from that
where uh regular people who are
incapable of uh making an actual return
on their savings from a bank uh they're
forced in order for their retirement or
for saving for whatever and they need to
go on play on the stock market because
if you put your money in the bank and
it's only earning 1 and a half% interest
but inflation is higher than that that
means that you're not actually saving
any money you're losing you're losing
money by keeping it in the bank and uh
that that's a serious problem and now we
have a large population of of New
Hampshire as well as the rest of the
country young people who are incapable
of affording houses uh they cannot get a
loan to buy a house and they wouldn't be
able to afford their mortgage and this
was the case even in 2019 this is before
anything like that anything that
happened in 2020 would have changed that
um and we also have a big problem where
uh elderly people are incapable of
paying for their own retirement and it
forces them to depend on Social Security
and Social Security it's it's it's not
being keeping track with inflation
because the dollar keeps losing its
value faster than we can we can save and
so gold is a historical means to prevent
all these problems but I wanted to make
a point on reserve currencies more
specifically so I got several Reserve
currencies here as you guys have a
Graphic that shows how long they last
before it doesn't quite work anymore uh
so the Portuguese real um that was
around in the uh that started in the uh
mid
1400s um that was used for about 80
years before it was supplanted by the
Spanish raer the Spanish dollar and that
you might know that that those were the
Pieces Of Eight that the colonists used
uh that one had a really good run that
lasted about 110 years before getting uh
replaced by the Dutch Gilder and uh the
Dutch Gilder lasted about 80 years and
then it was replaced with the French
Fran and that one had a had a better run
than most it had 95 was kind of mediocre
before it was replaced by the pound
sterling um there's some questions as to
when exactly the pound sterling stopped
being a reserve currency um it lost most
of its value in World War I but it the
it definitely died at the end in uh 1944
um it was uh that's when uh the Breton
Woods there was the Breton Woods
agreement and all that jazz but that's
when the US dollar became a world
currency um and so depending on how you
measure the start of the US Dollar's
reign as the world's Reserve currency
we've either been doing it for 104 years
or 80 years uh that's a pretty good run
but we should expect that that will not
last very long because historically
Reserve currencies kind of don't last
much longer than that and we're started
seeing the uh economic throws that sort
of come through when a currency is not
going to last very long we're already
seeing competition from bricks uh the uh
Biden Administration keeps referring to
dollarization
um these are all just fancy ways of
saying we know that the the show is over
but we need to sort of sell it and find
a away where people don't panic uh
because the dollar is it's not in good
it's not in good shape um takes a couple
generations for people to squander uh
the uh the fundamentals that made the
currency a good candidate for a reserve
currency in the first place I do not
think that the US dollar is going to
last very long but if if such a
situation occurs where the US dollar
just dies or uh the plan to Institute a
cbdc fails and people reject the new
cbdc or whatever the case may be it
would be really nice for New Hampshire
to have a backup so we can still have
government services run we could still
have uh towns and municipalities able to
provide services by having a currency
that is backed by gold gold doesn't die
gold has been a reserve currency for
Millennia it has there there's no such
thing as you know they had in order to
make the dollar or the or gold die as a
as a currency whether legally or not you
know there's questions as to whether
legally counts as a currency but
economically speaking it making gold no
longer valid a currency you need to be
able to find some way to make gold out
of nothing so right now if you have a
dollar you can or the Federal Reserve
they can go through their processes and
they can just make new money like that
um but the expansion of the monetary
base means that whenever they do that
they're not actually creating more value
in the economy they're just decreasing
the value of all the existing dollars so
you can't really do that with gold maybe
Fusion reactors in the future will be
able to do it I don't know but as of
right now it has a pretty good track
record and I think that gold will last a
very very long time into the future as
it's lasted a long time into the past so
we're due and so I think that this uh
legislation is very important
specifically because it isn't just a
make gold legal currency bill uh it's
also make it use usable in the modern
day bill so if if you just had a bill
that made gold legal currency and you
wanted to buy something from Amazon you
would have to take some silver coins put
them in an envelope lick it put a stamp
on it and then mail it to them and then
they'd have to send you the product
that's obviously not workable in this
Modern Age so having some sort of
tokenization which uh allows you to
transfer ownership of the Gold without
having to physically move the gold
itself is the Boon and that is exactly
why paper currencies backed by gold were
so popular back in the day people didn't
want to carry around a jingling bag of
coins everywhere they went so they would
it was much more convenient to carry
around a piece of paper that is
redeemable for gold at a bank and so um
that's uh that's basically what I have
I'll take uh I I suppose I better not
take questions because it's not my bill
but uh thank you very much I do remember
the silver dollar the the silver paper
dollar yeah it wasn't that long ago
right okay thank you very much all right
so I I have spoken to the treasure and
she's willing to come up and share a
little bit of given that this would be
under her statute of
authority and I thought maybe she would
have some insights for us but if nothing
else
she'll tell us
bill
good morning good morning thank you Mr
chairman uh and members of the committee
uh for the record State Treasurer Monica
mapelli I was not plan to testify
however I am prepared I was prepared for
questions so uh that's the reason I'm
here but um you know based on um uh
chman uh request um what I am prepared
to to share is um first uh we we we take
no position um on on this bill um uh we
will certainly follow the direction of
the legislature if if this bill were to
pass um so so this
proposal as uh represent am U mentioned
in the beginning appears to cover three
different topics so I'm going to try to
stay at a higher level and just focus at
a I guess um from what appears to impact
the treasury um directly so the first
one is the uh the establishment of the
depository
um so a depository will need to be um
built in in in my opinion um currently
the treasury does not have the
infrastructure to to hold gold silver
metal uh precious metals um so it will
have to be
um a new facility will have to be built
and created uh and it will include that
and it will have to have the the
elements needed for this type of
infrastructure um security um um all of
the different components um that will be
required to to maintain a facility like
this one um So based on our
understanding of the bill that's not
this bill does not appear to provide
funding for that initial uh facility and
um this part of the bill this is this is
what appears to be the foundation of
what this proposal um is uh is in our
view uh intending to do uh so with that
uh we are required to administer
um this
depository um currently the treasury
does not have the resources for this we
will have to uh either hire staff and
and and and what is needed to be able to
run this uh this depository or we will
have to contract with a third party
provider in order to do that um again um
it does um this proposal appears to
establish ability or appears to provide
the ability to establish fees for the
storage withdrawal and transfer of
bullion um but it just does not appear
to um to provide the funding required
for an initial investment um to be able
to again um establish the depository and
really launch this
program um so so that would be again uh
the question how we will have to how we
would is unclear to us how we will um
implement this program according to what
what this proposal is um is describing
um and then the Salvage of the
electronic currency backed by gold and
silver um that's clearly a a new um it
will be a new an Initiative for the
straight treasury so we will have to
have the resources um needed to be able
to run an operation like that um we
would either have to again hire experts
uh to assistance with this um other
departments will have to uh also provide
some guidance Department of Information
Technology uh Department of Justice will
have to be involved uh to to um assist
us with the implementation of this
program um and again the requirement of
we um I go back to the um the
requirement to have a depository it
appears we will have to have this
facility in order to really uh be able
to implement um the electronic currency
backed by gold and silver or another
speci um uh to be able to again
Implement uh the electronic currency so
so based on our understanding of of this
bill um it does provide the ability to
charge fees there are a couple of
Provisions that mentioned that so it
sounds like a program like this one uh
in order to run the operation uh or this
operation it will will have the ability
to charge fees and is clear is very
unknown um what those fields will look
like but again it really does appear to
require significant resources in order
to launch this um in in the funding is
not apparent uh from a review of this
bill um so that's what I would like to
share and and i' be happy to answer any
questions you may have so I stay away
from um you know the exchange rate all
of those questions are
just there we can go more in depth into
the conversation but at a higher level
those will be our initial uh concerns in
order to to operate a program like this
one
okay okay thank you I do see the fiscal
note the million million plus was that
your number or or I don't know what and
that's just a number to to to cons if if
the state were to build a facility you
would require millions in order to do
that right and then uh just out of humor
because we we're tearing down a bank
that probably had a vault in
it but uh but did would at some point in
time I don't know if you know our
history but did we ever ever store gold
in our in the in the State House there
in in that Vault that we ever had going
I guess yes I mean we have a vault as
our vault is very old uh is is it does
not have the um it's not a modern vault
as you mentioned the Department of
Justice probably has a better Vault than
we do um certainly um I think yes likely
we had gold at some point there we go
thank you very much I appreciate you
thank Mr chairman thank you very much
and then again I'm I'm apologize again
Yuri I I did not see your card some got
it mixed in with the uh with all the
pros
so uh Mr chair dear committee members uh
for the record representative Yuri of
representing Mar Mark 10 hookit and Dan
Barton uh uh I'm speaking in support of
this legislation I'm very thankful for
your time considering this bill and let
me concentrate on experience of my
constituents uh hookit residents are
receiving significantly increased tax
bills this month mine being an average
increased over
$1,400 uh for many constituents on fixed
income
uh it is not sustainable some have no
choice but to be priced out of their own
homes and leave hooks it forever uh and
inflation is the largest contributing
factor giving our mirima County a little
choice but to follow the wage increases
and hookit had to pay more to school
teachers so this legislation will give
my constituents real protection against
inflation especially for those on fixed
income uh I received testimonies from my
constituents both Y and old supporting
this bill and I will not uh read those
here in full but to give you an idea uh
I had a family of retirees crashed by
said price and tax increases uh and
asking for this bill to pass to give and
I quote individuals a way to access
stability and security during this
uncertain times uh I also had a young
family uh ready to start investing and
valuing precious metals and exciting
that actually a growing number of
establishments are accepting gold and
silver as payment one
problem uh and a brief quote from my
constituent here but we do need to pay
taxes to State and local governments
currently the government only accept
dollars if if we could pay our taxes
with real money gold and silver it would
make our lives easier and better it
would also improve New Hampshire's
Financial Health
immensely uh thank you for your
consideration please support uh this
question uh I think we're all set thank
you very much thank
youy yeah thank you great okay so uh we
have uh one two three four five cards
left um you're all in support so all I
can ask is please uh if you try to make
a point that we have not heard yet if
you're just gonna you know want to say
ditto
that's Rush Li you can be a ditto head
you can just say uh that you don't you
know but so Daniel Diaz citizens for
sound
money
we will take care of it just give them
around
okay
two three
four Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
speak in favor of HB uh
1674 my name is Daniel Diaz I'm the
executive director of citizens for sound
money I'm also the CEO and co-founder of
a crypto Mining and blockchain
consulting company called mining life
prior to my uh current career I was a
former insurance agent from the Knights
of Columbus and a stock broker with my
Series 7 license where I learned a lot
about how the global economic system and
the Fiat monetary system works I'm also
a contributing analyst to investing
daily.com as our crypto and sound money
analyst um my entire professional career
in finance has been focused on helping
people protect their wealth and
increasing their financial literacy and
that is why I'm here today HB 1674 will
protect Granite stators from the
devastating effects of
inflation um if you turn to the first
page I I I asked the question what is
inflation the simplest definition of
inflation is the expansion of the
currency Supply so if you look on the
chart look down to uh January of roughly
of 2020 through November of 2023 our
national debt increase by 10 trilli
777 billion from January 20 the total
debt was 23 Bill uh trillion dollar and
by November of last year it was 34
trillion that is an increase of the
monetary Supply by
46.4% as new currency is purchase that
dilutes the current purchasing power of
all currency in circulation so we've
lost around 4 almost 50% of our
years on page number
two um and you'll see in the chart that
in 1971 Nixon took us off the gold
standard effectively making the dollar a
fiat currency just it's unbacked just by
the full faith and credit of the United
States throughout all of recorded human
history there's never been a single and
there's over 6,000 recorded references
to Fiat currencies unbacked by any type
of precious metal or or base metal not
one single fiat currency has survived in
all human uh human history if you look
at the chart you'll see that most
current currencies were flat because
they were pegged to the dollar the
moment that the currencies were unpegged
in
1971 most currencies dropped in Val
value by 90% or more if you go to page
three the next uh two charts is it two
three charts next three charts will show
um the difference between assets um
compared to the dollar versus gold in
this first chart we'll see the uh that
the C gold has protected um against
inflation you'll see at the beginning of
the chart it's 1971 where gold and the
dollar were combined and then from 1971
to today we have a
667 per inflation rate in the dollar
that's a loss of purchasing power uh if
you look at gold gold is actually
increased in value compared to the
dollar by 84 almost
85% gold has protected purchasing power
for
Millennia the next chart on page number
four we're comparing gold um to oil uh
you'll see at the beginning in 1971 when
we were pegged to the to Gold oil was in
in the dollar was pretty much the same
price but as we deeg you'll see that you
can buy more oil with uh with gold
throughout the last 53 years versus the
dollar oil has gone up 600% just like
the inflation of the dollar while gold
has actually increased in in value by
50% and finally the last chart um real
estate so we go back to 19 1 where the
dollar was pegged and when it was uh dep
pegged you'll see that the value of
homes have gone up 9
65% uh compared to the dollar while it
this gold has maintained its value in
fact in 1979 you the average price of a
house was
$73,000 which was 268 ounces of gold
today the average price of a house is
513,000 Guess How many ounces of gold
268 cuz gold maintain is purchasing
power so I share all this information to
you to explain the value of having a
gold back currency and uh citizens for
sound money my organization along with
representative a are the ones to help uh
write this piece of legislation and um I
know some of you have some detailed
questions if you have any questions I'm
more than happy to answer them since we
were the ones our legislative committee
wrote this bill and it's currently in 20
different states in different
okay representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chairman um I'm sorry
I uh had to step out to the restroom so
I didn't hear all of your testimony um
but um my question is uh doesn't the
state of New Hampshire um have enough
work to do without uh setting up a
depository for gold and silver thank you
for that question representative Gibbs I
think that's the great question and we
have some experts behind me and also I
have a written testimony by one of the
companies that would be actually bidding
for to run the depository and create the
electronic currency uh load Labs is uh
it can't be here today but we have
another company the president of Kinesis
which is another gold and uh uh company
that will also manage the depository
there won't be any additional work added
um the significant work added to the
state because these private companies
will manage with their contracts with
Brinks or other private vating companies
and also they've already created and
they're already working um across the
world uh using cryptocurrency in fact I
have a debit card in my pocket I could
show you that's backed by gold and I can
spend it anywhere right now buy you a
cup of coffee buy uh dinner with gold
and the merchant won't even know because
at the moment of swiping that card the
gold is sold at market prices which I
think answers a few of your concerns and
the merchant will even know I pay with
gold because they'll receive dollars
followup question well I was that you
you hit it right on the nail what's in
this for the State of New Hampshire to
spend millions of dollars to do
something that Private Industry can do
is already doing why why do we want to
muck around compete with you that's a
beautiful question representative hunt
because Article 1 Section 10 Clause one
of the US Constitution gives the states
the authority to cre uh to make gold and
silver legal tender in the state right
now there's only four states in the
Union what but why would we want to do
that if it's
if it's going to cost us thousands and
millions and millions of dollars to have
an infrastructure for it what's in it
for New Hampshire load and uh that's
great question uh load and Kinesis will
actually uh provide the technology and
the infrastructure for free and uh and
I'll let the president of Kinesis in
this statement right here explains it
the only thing they request um since
they'll be putting up the money for the
infrastructure is potentially donating
20 load is asking for $250,000 in gold
and silver to Kickstart the depository
amounts of gold and silver but all the
technology will be provided and the way
and and after the companies recuperate
their uh fees for creating the
infrastructure then there's a split
Revenue model where the state will
receive revenue from every transaction
using the the digital
currency uh okay represent gives you may
have your question uh thank you uh uh
follow-up question uh you mentioned a
debit card based on on gold um who
administers that de debit card system
and why do you trust them well right now
the debit card I have is is partnered
with a bank in the United States that's
FDIC insured um and I know Kinesis and
lo have debit cards in other countries
and they will be coming uh debit card
will be coming to this country soon I'm
sure uh Eric main who's the president of
Kinesis can give you a little bit more
information about that but it it's
partnered with the banks and the Master
Card I think is a card I have in my
pocket I think Visa is uh also an option
but they have fees yes any any it's
about uh 22 to 45 basis points for using
the system um and for instance I I don't
want to take too much time repres uh the
president Eric will be able to discuss
how their fee system for merchant work
but by having the merchant system
Merchants will save between 200 and 400%
on credit cards charges if they accept
the digital currency because it's only
22 to 45 basis points versus 2 to four%
which is 2 400% uh 400 basis points so
there's a savings to Merchants if they
decid to accept gold and silver
currency okay I'm missing something here
but that's all right all right any other
questions see thank you very much thank
you uh so Eric is it is this Eric Maine
sir well good afternoon Mr chairman and
committee um yes so Eric Maine I'm the
president of two global companies uh one
is allocated bullion exchange which is a
um a online um institutional exchange
for for the trading of of spot physical
gold and silver uh based out of
Australia um and the president of
Kinesis which is a Global Financial
Technologies company that has built an
end to-end monetary system um based on
uh digital gold and silver currencies on
the
blockchain um we're very vertically
integrated so there'll be a lot of
questions that I can answer um we own a
gold Refinery we uh have built and and
operate depositories around the world um
we have vaulting
um accounts um with the major thirdparty
uh vaulting providers in 13 different
countries
um and so you know I'm here to answer
questions what what we've done
um one of the things you know we've done
our own organically of grown um our own
custom race Etc but maybe more relevant
here is we we've done public private
Partnerships um with national
governments um to implement you know the
kind of thing you're looking to do here
so the most advanced one that is
operational is with the um the
government of
Indonesia where we have um integrated
with um the local banks there um the
payment systems Etc so it's it's our
digital gold and silver currencies sit
side by side um the Indonesian rupia uh
through debit cards as uh Daniel was
explaining there's an option Within
These debit cards where the people can
use the existing Fiat or the digital
gold and silver um what we do is uh fee
based um and what we do with our
government Partners uh it is a fee
sharing model we're happy to take on the
um the infrastructure cost of creating a
a a platform for the government that's
basically a white label of our existing
platform uh together with um the
vaulting and depository infrastructure
and what we ask for in return is a
certain uh a certain amount of the of
the funds that get transacted through
the system come to us first and then uh
after we recoup our cost for doing it
then we share with with um with the
state um it's a model that is um very
welcomed in in these countries that
we're doing with um and it's actually
has the potential to be quite a robust
Revenue stream for uh for the
states I'm happy to answer any
questions okay we do have several
questions representative
spe you downloaded your
book okay I haven't seen that one but
okay yes that's that's say kesis and
Isis monetary system yes yes ma'am one
of the things it it points out in here
is that the model that you the model
that you have works well in countries
where banks are not that prevalent and
people can't get to banks that easily
and so it's an alternative way of
Distributing I guess funding without uh
the infrastructure that we have in the
United States where we have two banks on
every corner so that part of it is we
can't
what's your question I guess the
question is in this model you talk about
making money it's not easy to describe
if you have not read
this if you
have the way you make the way it talks
about this if you don't have a lot of
money to put into it which a lot of
people don't then the way you uh recoup
money on it is by referring other people
kind of
like uh yeah kind a little bit like that
is that what you're saying and what do
you get out of this what does the state
get out of us being a front for this
kind of an operation why do you even
need
us well because of the trust of the
state so you have you have citizens that
trust the state and and when you do a
public private partnership it means just
that you are publicly facing with a with
a private company that has the
experience and the ability to do what
you're looking for but at the end of the
day the state is the state and people
people trust your state um and that's
that's true in in these countries
they're doing it I would say on the fees
look it's a very small amount of fee
that happens every time uh somebody
sends or spends on this on the debit
card or buys at a merchant it's 0.22%
that's 22 basis points um and you know
the for us it's the amount of adoption
so you have you have adoption um by a
large amount of the citizens doing it it
creates a lot of money there's a lot of
money that flows through I don't what's
the GDP of ofhs your 90 billion Etc
whatever U but if you take a small
percentage of that using this system um
you can generate a lot of Revenue and
it's ongoing and what is it for the for
the individuals well the model that we
set out is a fee sharing model so it's
not only the state that participates
Ates in that Revenue share um it is the
citizens themselves so what we do is all
those transactions that happen um uh
within that ecosystem is collected into
a Master Fee pool and every month we
give back depending on how you utilize
that um to various people within that
within the ecosystem so some are for
people that have just spent it of course
off the top line is the the the um the
split with the state so they get their
the state gets their piece let's say
it's
5050 uh then out of the other
50% um there would be um a certain
percentage that goes to people that just
are holding the holding the token as a
savings and then there's a different
percentage that goes to to those that
are actively spending it it's what we
call velocity we're trying to create
velocity and moving money just like you
question in this in the um pamphlet it
talks about that the money that's made
is a um in fees goes to the Cayman
Islands and the books are kept by you in
the Cayman Islands and we get whatever
you guys tell us we're supposed to get
uh is that how you see this working here
no no no that's not how it works ma'am
so Kinesis we have 27 different entities
uh around the world and because we're
facing different regulatory regimes
um what uh the holding company is a is a
Cayman Islands company but what we would
look to do here as we have done
elsewhere we have a local entity that's
locally
regulated um and so it wouldn't be
anything to do with the Cayman Islands
for example so in Indonesia or in Panama
where we're doing it we have a local
Kinesis entity that is and and have to
say on the regulatory front because
that's has been a piece that's that's
been brought up
um by multiple multiple people so we
welcome um being part whatever the
regulatory infrastructure that makes
sense so uh in Indonesia it's with the
um the commodity regulator and the
banking uh regulator in Panama it's it's
the central bank and and the bank
supervisory regulator so all those
components um are are put together um
and we're just providing the
infrastructure it's up to the state to
run it we we can you know support it um
and provide the the uh the people Etc
but on the depository piece um what
we've done with other partners is you
know no gold can come in no gold can
come out nothing can happen without a
multi signature that would mean a
representative of the state and the
depository operations sign off on it
electronically before anything happens
so the the state has as as with our
other partners um a lot of oversight
have a real
question representative two seconds next
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
testifying Mr main my question what is
the value of storing money in gold or
silver bullion before spending it as a
debit card yeah so this is this is a
classic thing called gresham's law that
that uh bad money drives out good so if
you think of it of having a piece of
your silver coin in your hand versus a
paper dollar which one you going to buy
coffee with I'm going to use the paper
dollar right I'm going to keep the
silver I'm going to keep the gold and
this means bad money drives out good
that's gum law the way you defeat that
in our model is through this fee sharing
uh system where people are getting a
yield on just holding the gold they're
getting a yield on getting cash back by
spending it uh and we share these these
fees um with them and so it becomes an
income generating uh and there and
there's income to be generated at every
level the merchant level the individual
level the corporate level um and of
course the state and you know our level
but that's as long as gold keeps going
up in
value not I mean theoretically the rule
of Economics is that that the reason why
gold keeps going up value because it's a
limited resource there's only so much
gold out there so therefore you're bu
betting on the fact that there's only
going to be a handful of gold out there
there's no no no you know like someone
was talking about new alchemies you
we're we're not g to have somebody can
turn lead into gold and suddenly change
everything but you're the whole thing
you're betting on is the fact that gold
will continue to go up because it's a
limited
resource well Mr chairman I would say
not necessarily that it continually go
up but that over time it is a
stabilizing Factor
basis against the US
dollar well I don't know if it's
stabilizing because it keeps going up in
value keep keep taking more dollars so
so that that's you know look it's a it's
a perk that it goes up but it doesn't
have to go up for this model to work it
will work over the long term if gold is
stable compared to the value of the
dollar you certainly don't want it to go
down don't want to go down all these
people who are all depending upon that
revenue of of that that growth yes but
as you just pointed out it is a limited
resource and so the inclination it can
well stable or go up for a long all
right Senator Herbert my question is
sort of related to to the
Chairman's from your perspective what
happens based on fluctuations in mining
in other words is the gold production
pretty steady over time but I know in
the in like in the 1890s there was a
huge huge fight uh because in
agriculture you borrow and then you pay
back and if the and if the gold for
whatever reason comes out you know goes
up much higher it causes severe problems
so I'm I'm just wondering how do you how
do you how do you well how do you manage
this this because gold is going to be
high and low it's going to be higher and
low but it it it is relatively stable
over long periods of time so mine
production is a thing that is you know
yes there is new mine production comes
on board all the time and you have some
big blips where somebody um you know has
something that's a big resource but it
costs a lot of money to bring gold out
of the ground um as you deplete those
that are closer to the surface you have
to Dig Down Deeper and it's harder to
get and it's more expensive so there's a
point where mining new gold is not even
worth it now it's worth it where it is
now U but you get down to $800 an ounce
or something like that it's not worth to
to mine anything anymore um
so there's not going to be a whole lot
more gold out out of the ground um it's
going to be a deep leading resource over
time there will be some you know some
upticks and some production but over a
long period um gold production will go
down which means one other question it's
related do we're getting H my question
to you is um where is the uh where does
the rubber meet the road in your
business I know I understand I think how
you make money but where is the uh the
uh fluctuations in the currencies you
have to deal with I mean how is that uh
moderated how do you how do you keep up
with currency fluctuations is it
something you have to like you know pay
a lot of attention to or
okay this I think that's it's a Forex
you know I don't how is how is how is
how has this all worked out is this all
Forex well yes so normal way that any
company would would manage their
business if they're doing business in
multic
currencies great thank you oh no the
currency makes the exchange all right
thank you very much for your testimony
all right I got three cards here but I
hope we can go quicker here all right
Exchange thank you you going to make
sure yeah aha very good uh my name is
Adam Van I represent the alapine gold
exchange uh what we are are the uh we
are a gold and silver company that also
provides vaulting Services we are the
member service representatives for the
United precious metals Association the
upma is uh has a membership of 53,000
members 7 1,00 of which are Granite
Staters and what we do is we uh provide
a platform that provides similar
services to what banks are already
offering but we do it with gold and
silver so you can deposit you can
withdraw you can exchange you can put it
into other savings programs and gain 2%
interest very similar to what you might
think of as traditional banking but we
do it with gold and silver we are a
repository for gold and
silver we are already here we have a a
management office in Manchester New
Hampshire um and we are
currently um already transacting in gold
and silver with member-to-member
transfers and other members come to us
buying and depositing gold and things
like that and the Commerce is already
there The Exchange and the market is
already there and we have 100 businesses
that are openly accepting gold and
silver as payment we have thousands of
people that are transacting amongst
themselves in gold and silver and the
question that we get frequently is what
are they supposed to do with their taxes
what are they supposed to do with their
fees and how do they manage that so what
we're asking for from this bill and I'm
in favor of this bill but um what we're
asking for is Clarity uh out of this
bill and and what to do with these
transactions that are already happening
there's already things being purchased
um and there's
also thousands of granite Staters that
are sitting on holds of gold and silver
and they have no idea what to do with
them so one of the things that we've
discovered since uh coming here and
working with the local Granite Staters
and I am a granite Stater um is that
these folks when we do contact them
they're relieved that they have some
sort of a service that can take this
gold and silver that they've been
sitting on for years and years so there
are Untold millions of dollars worth of
value that are already inside the
granite state that are not being used uh
as as um as funds and not being used in
the marketplace because they're just
sitting inside family Collections and so
forth and so if we can provide them with
practical applications and practical
services for being able to manage those
gold and silver uh then they're able to
put that into the marketplace as um a a
um oh I'm getting lost in words here I'm
getting hungry as well so but uh but if
we can get that into the marketplace for
trade then there's going to be uh a lot
of benefit for the State of New
Hampshire and for granite Staters to be
able to uh put more value into the
marketplace for trade and that equals
High you know more Revenue through taxes
and fees and so forth and we are also
the um representation of how this can
work at scale we do have 53,000 members
uh we do um have these transactions we
do operate a vault uh these are are
we're already here we're already doing
it and we can
um we can just show that it works and
that you can transact in gold and silver
and it's already happening great thank
you very much thank you uh Jason uh
D Zer
Zer hi there thank you my name is Jason
dner I'm a software engineer in
Portsmouth and I've been working in the
digital currency space since
2013 I led the design of the world
world's first Multi-Device Bitcoin
wallet and I invented a number of the
technical upgrades uh to a to the smart
Contracting system of one of the world's
largest cryptocurrency networks I'm
deeply familiar with this space and with
the technical and operational
requirements of the sort of digital
currency proposed in this bill um I'm
also here on a personal basis I don't
represent any companies and I have no no
products to sell um I am excited about
this bill because uh I believe it would
create an opport
opportunities for companies to build
digital project digital currency
products uh with a with with a reliable
American asset um I think it could
attract significant investment and
create thousands of well-paying jobs in
New Hampshire um here's why tokenized
real world assets like this uh matter
tokens enable open payment networks with
lower fees and faster settlement than
proprietary closed Networks lending
systems that don't suffer from the kind
of cascading failures that we saw in the
2008 financial
crisis free and open crowdfunding
systems that allow nonprofits to reduce
their
overhead and give donors more visibility
into the flow of
funds and ultr transparent asset
exchanges where large investors don't
get cost or timing advantages versus
smaller
investors and more um American companies
are are building the the plumbing the
tools and services to make these
Innovations happen but here's the
problem uh due to Federal regulatory
uncertainty American assets are very
rarely flowing through those
pipes this bill would solve that problem
by giving us a trusted American asset to
power these applications with American
companies um so with that in mind let's
talk about how the depository is funded
uh the token tokens Can automatically
assess and ACW fees over time
uh upon redemption or when transferred
between networks it's possible for the
depository to generate Revenue both from
those direct fees and from activities
like Market making and liquidity
provision and decentralized exchange
protocols and and I'm happy to talk more
about those technical details but for
now I'll just note that smart contracts
the algorithms that run on these digital
currency networks can really reduce the
overhead of collecting that
Revenue there are both us-based and
offshore entities offering depository
services like this that collect millions
in Revenue annually and with the added
stability and legal certainty of New
Hampshire's seal we can expect that a
New Hampshire issued token uh would
expand that market and generate
significant revenue for the
state to summarize this is a profitable
business and I expect the depository to
fully fund itself um and I also want to
note that uh initial startup costs um
could be supplemented or or funded by uh
the state selling a note or possibly
crowdfunded uh the this is something
that can maintain itself uh over the
long term so it's the initial startup
costs that are that are in question um
thank you very much for your time and
I'm open to answering any questions yes
I have a question about um Have you
communicated with the New Hampshire uh
Treasurer and the uh doj no no I I just
wanted to mention that in this comment
because we had spoken with it earlier uh
I I do believe I do believe that this is
the the kind of operation that could be
funded by selling a note uh to investors
who would who would fully bear the risk
of whether or not the operation
ultimately was was
successful rather than it touching
taxpayer funds that that's why I wanted
to mention it in this Bond but they that
uncollateralized um no no that loses
your whole benefit of the of the state
putting its name to it I I don't see how
that would work I'm sorry uh I I wanted
to bring that into to the testimony but
um no it would it would be a New
Hampshire run uh depository in digital
currency um I'm I wanted to mention that
I think that this can be a completely
budget neutral project and and could
ultimately be a significant source of
revenue for the state from an industry
perspective it is already a profitable
profitable business the issue is that uh
due to regulatory uncertainty and in in
federal federal regulatory uncertainty
American businesses are not able to
meaningfully compete in this area uh uh
European and Asian businesses are doing
significantly better they're able to to
um to work within those regulatory
Frameworks much more clearly uh to have
European and Asian assets working in
these digital systems so we can have
these these uh these Innovations like
open payment networks with very low fees
and exchanges where where larger
investors don't get advantages over
smaller investors but we're using them
with assets that are not American and it
would be uh I believe a a huge Boon to
New Hampshire for New Hampshire assets
to be used in that market I think it
would bring thousands of well-paying
jobs to the state and attract
significant foreign and and domestic
investment great thank
you thank you very much thank you all
right one card left Daniel tinman tinum
from citizen for sell
money
yeah are you going to read from it no
please don't read too much I mean if
we've got it to you me just give us a
executive summary of why what of what
something we have not heard yet it would
be helpful yep well Mr chair and
committee thank you very much for the
opportunity I come here as a concerned
granted State citizen um Alan Shepard
once said that any Landing you can walk
away from is a good one and I believe
the same thing can be said about the
economic and monetary crisis that awaits
our nation which includes the citizens
of New
Hampshire um thank you very much for the
committee um until today I've never
testified uh to any political body nor
have I ever been part of any local state
or federal politics but for my
children's sake I have five children um
the stakes are too great for me to stay
silent any longer my name is Daniel J
tinum I'm a lifelong resident of New
Hampshire I grew up in East dery where
my love of numismatics the study of
coins and paper money began at the age
of 14 I attended Pinkerton Academy where
I excelled in academics I was treasurer
for the future Business Leaders of
America I was a member of the Academy of
Finance securing a banking internship at
TD Bank at just the age of 16 I attended
Southern Hampshire University graduated
in 2010 from the three-year honors
program in Business Administration I
also received my Masters in Business
Administration with a finance
concentration in 2014 in my five years
at Fidelity Investments in marac New
Hampshire I was two-time President
Circle winner I also spent seven years
at empowers retirement division uh which
happens to handled the New Hampshire uh
retirement system um I now work in
private Equity raising capital for King
operating an oil and gas company
operator based out of Dallas Texas I'm
also a major investor in a private
company based in Orlando Florida that
focuses on first player entertainment
specializing in Virtual theme parks and
virtual entertainment um House Bill 1674
would go a long way towards building a
trusted bridge between the digital and
physical worlds in my opinion the idea
of gold and silver circulating as real
money has been lost for many generations
some of you may even remember getting
silver in your change however the
recognition of gold and silver as
constitutional money is making a
remarkable comeback in recent years this
committee should proceed in passing the
legal tender act the state should find a
way to build a bullion depository in my
opinion or partner up with private
companies which we've already talked
about here today with the know how to
start an operative facility not passing
the bill will hurt residents in the long
run as the purchase power purchasing
power of the US dollar continues its
precipitous decline there are other
States who are working on passing
similar legislation and being an early
adopter would give New Hampshire
significant first mover advantages
against other states who may choose
Outsourcing to other states or private
companies or who will do nothing at all
although many bulling depository
transactions would be physical deposits
and or withdrawals they would not have
to be settled physically billions of
transactions are settled already on a
daily basis across a broad spectrum of
payment options and Ledger systems the
state should work with competent
partners with experience in establishing
depositories and payment systems to
ensure that New Hampshire is the gold
standard when it comes to establishing
the functionality of precious metals and
payment systems pun intended to provide
one such example to this committee the
state of Texas retirement system helped
their state establish the Texas bullion
depository for the benefit of all Texas
pensioners and retirees after realizing
they were spending many millions of
dollars per year in unnecessary fees to
faceless corporations like Black Rock
and Vanguard those shares were
ultimately redeemed for cash that cash
was used by the Texas state treasurer to
purchase physical gold and silver
ultimately for the Ben benefit of all
pensioners any cost incurred by New
Hampshire with the bulling program
should also be compared against the
annual cost of its Wall Street money
managers and how much of that savings
would be repatriated by moving these
proceeds directly to New Hampshire
vaults in the form of gold and silver
when it comes to New Hampshire citizens
we prefer options and the free will to
choose what is the best um for our needs
whenever possible House Bill 16 1974
provides citizens with choice and would
not affect anyone who does not wish to
spear the gold bullion deposit I spoke
to someone at the Gold a representative
at the bullion
depository it cost them 2423 million to
build it and the reason they buil it
built it was because they thought they
had 86 million in gold from the
University of Texas and the uh Texas A&M
in the middle of building it they sold
off that gold because it wasn't liquid
enough and the schools needed the money
so they had nothing as of this summer
they had $140 million in assets that's
all that's all they've got they never
got what they said they were going is
that great that they already did that so
we can learn from that and that's why
private companies are here today in my
opinion um was it mishandled or handled
improperly or I I don't know I don't
know the details of the Texas case
specifically other than um that they
started it um you know but I think
there's probably a lot to learn from
that um at the same time too I think uh
establishing private Public Partnerships
um if you go down the highway you can
see Common Man chains you know there's
plenty of you know opportunities that
private Public Partnerships have worked
in the state um in the state
particularly with the liquor stores um
you know there's different models and
you know the fact that we're all here
today talking about it is a great
start we are uh debating right now for
the marijuana is to a private public
partnership and it's still having a lot
of
troubles okay thank you very
much all right that closes the hearing
uh I guess we get the a blue sheet the
blue sheet okay uh 1674 the New
Hampshire Bankers Association are
opposed and
representative is for every uh m
four Jonathan Leslie's four Daniel Diaz
four Daniel tinman four Eric M four all
these are people who spoke already and
and Katherine heck is
neutral the the Hampshire Bankers are
opposed okay I am very apologetic about
the delay here and having this final
bill
1444 um did did you put in a car I I
I see Matt's got a card
here no okay well why don't you come on
up and testify and you can just do a
fine wrong way no C okay and this is the
blue
sheet sorry I need my
glasses
right so thank you chair um my name is
representative Kelly Penza straford
District 19 I was contacted uh this
summer um to put in a bill concerning um
actually the previous Bill and which my
bill actually included some from the
previous as well as um this uh
regulation of digital Mining
and it was actually my bill was split
and so this now is a
standalone uh just because of me made
sense because there was another um with
there was other legislation in there so
I have to say I am no expert on this at
all and um so I've you know I'm very um
appreciative for the representative
that's going to speak next to me because
he is well-versed in this so in regards
with like I had to understand what is
digital asset mining I'm going to read
just
um just a couple things for you to
explain what this is doing
so um in a world right of
cryptocurrencies you know you might have
come across the term digital asset
mining perhaps you've you know heard of
mining Bitcoin or ethereum maybe you've
heard of you know if there's profits
that that is made by you know generating
such operations so I'm going to break
down just a little bit about what it is
so digital assets set mining you know in
a sense provides rewards for work so you
know whether it's like Bitcoin or
ethereum Dogecoin render filecoin or any
other cryptocurrency at its core digital
asset mining really is the act of being
rewarded for expending computational
resources so these are you know in a
sense think of minable assets so those
resources can come in pretty much any
form of computational work we've seen
uses from processing power and file
storage to broadband Network provision
um and then there's air quality
monitoring so to kind of understand some
of these um I'm just going to go when I
worked for a company where we had a
server room so that server room had to
be monitored uh with air
quality um mostly for temperature and
stuff like that because it's a big power
source so uh there's some stuff that's
talked about in the bill that you know
is a little confusing and I'll and I'll
go to that in a second so while some of
these you know it's like ventilation and
air flow is what we're talking about so
some of these mining protocols require
um specialist Hardware others can be
performed by anyone like on a decent
home computer um that's usually lesser
of um a couple of others allow for
mining with smartphones um that's that's
fairly newer each day like a new mining
protocol emerges from the blockchain
ecosystem many trying to kind of like
tap into the latent computational power
sitting in an average you know modern
devices and computers however the
profitability of some of these mining
operations um you know it's not so
rewarding uh it's usually done with
larger entities uh which the fellow
representative will talk about so
they've taken to um basically T so
there's a lot of miners that will come
together they'll group together uh and
then work for a bigger
entity so um so usually the process of
like beginning mining is actually not
really uh it's not difficult at all and
it's not prohibited difficult um and
that's the reason why this bill has been
put into place so so after you acquire
like the appropriate Hardware um one can
usually access uh like the software um
from a protocols website I got a lot of
my information from a a it's they're
called arer Digital Labs they are a um a
company that's out of Australia so so
you can get that from like I said a
protocol's website or a company's
website code repository and offer and
often after like powering up you can
start mining straight away and some of
these things that you're purchasing are
like going to run on their own so um so
it's like you load into the software and
then it does the work for you um so
lastly because I know we're with time
here um there's different types of
mining so the proof ofof work mining is
really what I wanted to talk about so
that's kind of the original and most
common form really the best form of
mining so proof of work coins Le let's
just say like Bitcoin some of the
world's largest cryptocurrencies can be
minded like Bitcoin Bitcoin ethereum
Litecoin Dogecoin so for a bit of like
Conta
blockchains keep their Ledges secure and
immutable using consensus algorithms
systems that ensure that the majority of
the network agrees on a list of
transactions and events proof of work is
one of those consensus algorithms so by
expending a large amount of processing
power guessing the solution to a
difficult uh crypto graph
cryptography oh sorry problem miners
that correctly guess the answer first
can earn the right to add a new block to
the chain a correct guess and a valid
block added to the chain rewards the
minor with a certain amount of
cryptocurrency so I'm going to give you
in December of
2021 um Bitcoin miners for example were
rewarded with like 6.25 Bitcoin for
adding a block to the chain so since the
global computational work effort uh
excuse me since the global computational
effort being spent on proof of work
mining is so great it's common as I said
earlier for smaller miners to join um
others in pools where their combined
effort is more likely to yield more
consistent rewards they can share so the
last um thing I will say is you know the
difference between proof of work is like
you could talk about distributed um
Computing that's like the ne next
largest sector of digital asset mining
outside of proof of work um by market
cap um and that is basically it's a form
of distributed computing so for the
purpose of what I'm reading um you're
going to I'm going to Define that as
like the internet spread across a
network with utility Beyond securing a
blockchain's transaction data and adding
blocks to a blockchain so the the field
of digital asset mining in itself is
very diverse um you know distributed
files storage you know hotly contested
Market distributed app hosting content
serving um and they have a their own
sector of cryptocurrencies and
distributed rendering is emerging with
potential for growth to serve alongside
metaverse I think the most important
bill is line six item
two any person engaged in home digital
asset mining or digital asset mining
business shall not be considered a money
transmitter under RSA 399 G that's the
most important part of this bill because
this is not about transmitting money and
I had to educate myself on it because as
I told fellow representative uh who I
begged to speak on
this I said this is like a foreign
language to me and I will definitely
email my testimony um but the reason why
I put this in is for like I said a
constituent um that is very interested
in this and is I I you know in another
state he was in was working on this and
wants to do this here and just kind of
wants to be protected for it um in this
latest of technology so I think that's
say uh that's great I'm glad you pointed
that out um and clearly I put this in
the wrong grouping because we have a
whole another day where we're going to
be dealing with money the money trans oh
really yeah so I I I screwed up and I if
I had seen that I would have put it in
there but all I saw was local digital
Mining and so is that what the zoning is
so uh she in terms of um the zoning goes
through all kinds of things you I mean
there's there's there's something that's
re you the Pu does did you know sets
rates you know zoning but we don't know
if there's actually been a zoning
problem have we ever had anybody who got
told they couldn't do digital mining in
a town so it's really not a zoning issue
the money transmitter issue is is I can
see that potentially being a problem um
and uh but uh ironically I can tell you
that that the bank Department would
never do that because the bank
Department was very adamant that
cryptocurrency is not money okay it's a
commodity and so they would never ever
try to regulate uh cryptocurrency it as
a as a matter of fact we specifically
took the statute that did relate to it
and repealed it correct several years
ago so um in that sense if you're
worried about that I can't imagine that
being an issue but I
we could we do have a money transmitter
Bill we canop throw that in there if
that's if it's an issue but other than
that I mean uh um if you don't have any
actual zoning problems then we'll we can
figure out how to but like I say the
money transmitters should not should be
a non-issue because we we made a whole
point that that that the banking
department does not regulate
cryptocurrency correct in this process
the the digital asset mining is is
actually it's it's not transmitting
money it's not that's not what they're
doing exactly so whoever thought whoever
said was worried about that it's really
I I can't imagine they never been found
I mean are they are they registering as
a money transmitter now no yeah no so
this is not this is not problem so the
the last thing I wanted to say before um
and then if there's any other questions
um so of course as we know you know
we've got statutes laws that are on the
books that have been on the books for a
long time right so we're talking about
very modern day type things where you
know there's still certain laws on the
books that that when you slip something
in um you know that it applies so I just
have to say that if you look at line
number nine where it talks about
limiting the sound decibel and stuff
like that so think of um think of back
in the day when we had there were
humongous computer system I get to stop
you this is a zoning issue correct but
okay so zoning right now they have they
do have regulations I mean of is about
decb okay so to say is well would they
change that would they say well because
you're doing this particular Enterprise
different from the zoning debate we had
in my town which was was atire Warehouse
that has a drill that
goes was that was that auto repair or
not and why were they complaining about
the sound okay so that zoning you know
for us is to get into you know to
debating zoning in terms of sound and
Zoning you know that that's already set
and that's that's lots of case law
around that already but I just wanted to
tell you that OS specifically we had
this conversation right I'm like how
does the supply this goes based upon old
computers so if you look at B based upon
like NASA computers back in the day
those big huge I mean they would take up
you dream right they were loud that
doesn't apply anymore so that's the
reason why this is in here of decb it
doesn't even apply but it's old it's
like old stuff that's still on the books
is why I wanted to you're saying there
is that's no that's not on the books
there's no there never it was never any
regulation of noisy computers I can say
that because I was in the personal
computer business for a long period of
time so I can tell you that uh if
anybody was to complain that I mean
there was no no zoning regulation Rel
related to that but there are there are
local noise ordinances so that's why
they put this in here because they're
going based upon like this would be
something that would be loud I'm saying
there's no sound on local the noise I've
never seen one that had anything to do
with computers or Electronics all I've
seen was the one I know about
was okay when when it comes to Tire okay
so yes Town some towns definitely have
sound decimal ordinances yes and that
and that would means where your Zone
where you can do those activities but
okay we you guys really have questions
for very very quick question
representative buroughs has a question
um just quick question have you talked
to anyone at Dees or any other any other
organizations deals with environmental
concerns about what the impact may be of
digital
mining no because the only um the only
time that you would have any sort of
environmental impact would be if if
you're talking about and I can show you
pictures of where there are big large
companies that have you know uh their
Stacks basically of servers that are
running and that would be that's mainly
for um the
power actually takes a lot of
electricity the biggest noise maker is
the cooling correct because you have
it's all about
Cooling and and and big refrigerator
units and big cooler units just like you
see outside of of a but that's not in
somebody's home I'm that's big that
those are big companies that are doing
that that are literally stacking up
supercomputers to do this we don't we
don't have that so they would have to
follow all of our current regulations
which there are some um there are some
companies so I'm not even there yet with
Dees because those would already fall
under um all of those environmental
things if you're if you're building a
you know you're building a business of
this here in the state representative
Gibs thank you Mr chairman uh noise
issues aside isn't uh digital asset
mining highly energy intensive
correct it is so there's so for example
um but those people that are doing it
are paying for it so if this is
something that you want to put in your
home um there's certain times of the day
of course um that that are running that
are you know uh less cost for
electricity and things like that but
that is of course on the person that is
um they have to take that on right
follow clearly that's a pu that's a pu
issue it's not a zoning issue yes
question okay follow-up question uh and
this is related to representative
Burrow's question if something is highly
energy intensive uh aside from the cost
to the user might not there isn't there
also an environmental cost to adding
something that is highly energy
intensive well because of the high cost
of energy especially that we experience
in New Hampshire if someone is going to
do this they they have there's a lot of
different options for them with using
other types of energy that can help them
for to to offset the cost so I can
provide that and do a little bit of
research I did not go down that for
other um for other entities other states
countries that are doing this using you
know solar using geothermal using those
things like that which basically makes
um you know they they're almost a null
so cuz it's being it's being provided
for from actually some of those energy
efficient ways it's a quick question uh
really we have zoning laws that Rec that
talk about the uh the sound like we
talked about is there any belief that
the these uh mining operations could not
meet those zoning
laws not not to my knowledge so why do
them what do you mean why do you want
she's asking why why is this bill here
if there's no actual zoning regulation
or anything going
on okay because because you know
perception is reality right so we we're
putting something in basically making
sure that this can happen here in the
state they're still going to have to
follow under all our regulations under
all our zoning but they should right
correct and they should
um okay I I think a lot lot of this has
to do with the unknown aspect of this
new emerging uh computational business
and technology and I and for those
reasons this is the the bill that's put
in there's a there's a bill in Missouri
for example that passed um that is
identical that has the digital mining
part of it as well as um uh as well as
some of the currency pieces so this is
just this is really just protecting a
new and emerging industry and um and
making sure that they're allowed if
someone wants to be able to do this that
they have um um preventative
preventative legislation okay
representative Anon I I just wanted to
do uh would you believe uh would you
believe that uh digital asset mining is
actually could actually be beneficial to
the grid because it it uh it uh
encourages over production of of
generation and can be a flexible load on
the grid so that when there when
windmills and solar panels are producing
electricity that the grid doesn't need
it can go into digital asset Mining and
actually subsidize those projects and uh
if you look at the governor's crypto
commission report there's a whole
section on digital asset we had experts
come in and testify about how it can be
a tool to make the grid even Greener
which is kind of counterintuitive to the
narrative so would you believe no I do
well I do believe and I think that's
fantastic and I'm glad glad that you
pointed that out because I will cut
those sections and then send that out to
um just for further support of this
because we have to have all sides on
this which would be great okay thank you
very much thank you uh all right so um
Matt you want to come up
and please don't take five
minutes well I'll be quick but all right
so I was asked to uh come testify and
support of this bill and I think the
noise stuff and all that's a little bit
uh absurd just it's computers how much
noise can these things make it's the air
conditioning units to cool them okay um
but the the the bill the part that I
really want to testify in support of is
uh line six any person engag in home
digital asset mining or digital asset
mining business shall not be considered
a money transmitter um so I actually
think it is valuable because the
government has this tendency to treat
cryptocurrency as money when it's
convenient to them and and commodity
when it's convenient to them when
Prosecuting people I am very proud to
say that this
committee went out of its way to
absolutely
remove cryptocurrency from the banking
Department who was regulating as money
transmitters and we have that
legislation is got to be going on five
years now it was a while ago we passed
that we made it was under my name so let
me let me just tell you I'm damn sure of
what we did
okay and that is that no it it is that
the banking Department doesn't want to
have anything the B Money transmitter
like legislation they don't want to have
anything to do with cryptocurrency as a
matter of fact we took it out if you go
onto their web page right now they'll
tell you if you have a cryptocurrency
problem call the Attorney General's
office we do not have anything to do
with crypto okay uh but when someone's
being prosecuted for this you know just
have having that in there might be a
defense that they can use I mean there
there's a lot of CA there's a lot of
questions about this a prosecutor could
argue that Bitcoin mining or
cryptocurrency mining is money
transmission I that is in theory it is
but I'm just telling you under our
statutes that is physically impossible
to occur the Attorney General's office
would never use that because they know
full well that we have removed any
reference to to cryptocurrency from the
money
transfer uh
statute and I will get it I'll get you a
copy of it all right well I'll will get
you a copy was I sponsored the bill so I
know that we did
this uh yeah I I I agree but I mean it's
not like it's not like you know the
prosecution's always uh you know
sometimes it could be disingenuous
workers you know so just man come on
come on come come on let's give let's
give our statute some Integrity okay
they do they hold law and our attorney
general you know who's who was here
earlier okay who the consumer protection
division their mission in life just so
you know the consumer protection statute
is to ensure that if a consumer's been
harmed is to make sure that that you are
been made whole okay it's it's really
about restitution okay uh so this is
sort of unorthodox I was going to
testify on why digital asset mining is
not money transmission we absolutely
agree in this commit this this the
legislature is on record to agree with
you
100% okay uh still very unorthodox uh
testimony but thank you for your
time okay we do have a question for you
I have a question yes digital mining
business is a business so you can't
allow the cities don't allow businesses
in uh local districts that are you know
just
housing it has to be in a business
district I I was going to testify on
this but it's I'm kind of getting kicked
out I mean you could go on and talk
about something else I I just wanted to
make sure don't don't focus on the money
transmitter issue you you have you want
to testify about
business well one of the things that
crypto currency people are concerned
about is
decentralization so that so it
particularly says in home asset digital
mining uh they want to protect basically
small users that's what it looks like
the intent of this is to protect small
users that may have a very small like
just one computer uh at their home and
they want to mine with it they don't
want that to be considered money
transmission so this decentralization is
like very important to these
cryptocurrency people they want multiple
users to be working on this instead of
just a concentration of it and and
thanks okay any other questions do you
have any other testimony you want to
offer up nope great thank you very much
Horgan I have some I have some written
testimony okay so just for the committee
my what we're going to do is we're
basically we'll we'll break after this
for lunch and we'll just push everything
well I I'm way I looked at it was that
the snowstorm is pretty late in the
day
know okay go ahead Tim thank you very
much I'm can be resident Timothy Oregon
I continue unless something unexpected
happened to represent straford County
district 6 um 10 used to be six the town
of Durham and
um we've heard a lot of explanation the
bill represented of uh my gentle lady
from Rochester put a lot of uh lot of
work into it so she did job of telling
us like what it's about it attempts to
give digital asset mining companies
special privileges in my opinion which
other business do good and it's mostly
about uh zoning regulations but I'll
first I I'll skip to the last paragraph
of my prepared testimony about the the
money transmission because we're just
talking about it um
I I think this uh this this provision
appears to be unnecessary so that's a
another enough reason right there to
take it out but I also
uh also think this could be used you
could have businesses that would be
money transmitters might just put in a
digital asset mining um you know just
put a crypto server or whatever on after
your property then claim they're exempt
from it so that's probably another
reason to take it out um I I certainly
support internate homebased internet
businesses I ran I guess I'm still
running it a little bit myself um and
actually virtual currency was part of it
it was a virtual world where they had a
micro payment system where people put
real money you
know put real money into it and then
they use the virtual dollars this is in
Second Life what they call Lyon dollars
they're using that as a micro payment
system sometimes very micro micro
payment a lot of my things I was buying
or selling were like would be about like
a few cents in real money and that um I
said I certainly um wouldn't think
people who are running uh businesses and
second life any virtual should be money
transmitters and we were using third
party uh party vendors so I'm sure that
that would be a non-issue um also of
course in that case and people run out
do all kinds of B run all kinds of
business out of their homes and that
should be protected and maybe we do need
a law to clarify that I don't know what
this is the vehicle to do it or even the
committee that should be doing but
absolutely that should be allowable and
I really don't know of any Community
here in New Hampshire which is uh
discouraging through the zoning
regulations or anything else from people
just running you know sitting at their
computer and running a uh inter a
business over the Internet um
the digital asset mining these servers
uh that's could be a separate issue i'
I've certainly considered doing that
I've looked into schemes actually was
looking at the what the Archer digital
side in Australia which we heard about a
few minutes ago and I looked all the
schemes and they all seem like a waste
of time to me and also waste of
electricity so none of them frankly I
don't none of think really
added I wouldn't be adding any value to
the economy by participating them and
frankly I think that's the uh frankly I
think that's the case with crypto I know
people are making real money out of it I
know it's new and groovy and there a
very fascinating technology um but I'm
not uh I'm not sure if that's something
the state needs to go out of its way to
actively encourage it should be legal
but I I'm just a skeptic about it I just
don't I just think uh I just think a lot
of the claims for it are overblown and
the only value that I can see to
especially cryptocurrency is if you can
sell it to somebody else and get real
currency for it so I don't see how it
has any larger value I mean you can use
it as a um medium medium of exchange um
you can even use the store of value
though I don't think it's a very good
store of value because there's some
technical issues and also like it's very
volatile but that that's just me if you
want to do it you certainly should be
able to do it and you should be able to
do it out of out of your home but I
don't think
um I I don't think it's a good idea to
uh exempt them from local zoning
regulations because I can see all kinds
of situations where somebody's you know
mining crypto or doing you know doing
whatever running a very noisy server
that uses a lot of electricity maybe
creates other externalities um
municipalities should be able to
regulate that and also the way the bill
is written it only covers uh digital
asset mining businesses are located in
um industrial residential zones so
there's different types of zones you
know there's commercial zones rural
zones um and even the industrial Zone
industrial zones are often for a
specific type of Industry so it may or
may not be a good idea to have somebody
running you know a huge honking
cryptocurrency server generating lots of
excess noise and heat using you know
placing a burden on the electric supply
just to uh you know that shouldn't
necessarily be allowed in any industrial
Zone if the industrial zone is for like
some specific type of Industry as most
stars so
um I think um so I definitely think par
sub paragraphs 2 and three in propos RSA
6471 16a um paragraph one might be okay
but it needs some exceptions and I'm
standing between you and my lunch and um
so I would say just the best thing to do
it's interesting bill but I think you
should probably just find your
inexpedient to legislate and I'm sure
this issue will come up again so thanks
thank you very much hopefully hopefully
nobody has any questions so you're free
to fre to thanks closing the public
hearing yes did a very good job of
you
okay so we'll just get started here
because I guess Tony kaplan's not here
right oh he is here when you just sneak
in
sorry go ahead
yep thank you uh chairman hunt and
thanks members of the Commerce Committee
for the record my name is Tony Kaplan
and I'm here to represent the towns of
Haner Bradford and Warner and present
hb12 127 an act relative to single use
disposable plastic food wear
accessories this bill is intended to be
a win-win piece of legislation for
Granite State communities businesses and
the environment we rely on for our
sustenance and
survival this bill contrary to public
opinion does not mandate or prohibit the
use of single-use plastic food wear
accessories instead it seeks to limit
the use of these items except on demand
in restaurants large and small across
the
state many states and municipalities
restrictions Plastics make up about 15%
of our country's Municipal Solid Waste
generation this is due to the increased
manufacturer of plastics and plastic
non-existent approximately only 9% of
plastic ever produced has been recycled
plastic pollution is estimated to be
around 79% of the total waste generated
around the entire planet and Plastics
account for 3.4% of global greenhouse
gas emissions majority of ocean plastic
around 80% comes from landbased sources
namely the garbage that we produce we've
all seen the images of those patches in
the ocean full of garbage floating
garbage so-called dead zones uh dead and
dying as a result of our unsustainable
use of plastic and the plastic
pollution these are truly frightening
developments that are happening unless
you believe that there's somehow fake
news or an attempt to
Hoodwink the
public but the facts are undeniable and
the science is clear we're poisoning
ourselves this should not be a partisan
issue and we who have our hands on the
levers of power and our
state ought to do the right thing for
our
constituents as a matter of fact we are
doing that in New Hampshire we're
attempting to bring down our rates of
solid waste because we're experiencing
the effect of the pollution on our
health and on our
communities the state Solid Waste
Management plan issued last year calls
for a reduction or diversion of solid
waste by 25% by 2030 and 45% by 2050
from the 2018 Baseline of around 1 a
half million tons of solid waste that we
send to landfills or in
incinerators and inevitably poison our
air water and soil in the form of
leachates or air
emissions many of these poisons are long
lived and effectively do not break down
in the environment and their poisons
accumulate and combine in our soil water
food and bodies in ways that we're just
beginning to
understand this bill is not a Magic
Bullet that's going to end the plastic
pollution problem but it is a step in
the right direction
I used to live in New York City and uh I
remember at some point the city
administrators decided to uh try to
fight crime
by by uh clamping down on small
infractions you know you couldn't spit
on the sidewalk anymore and there
so-called uh no broken windows theory of
policing and and the idea is that if
people live in a neighborhood full of
broken windows they act like they live
in a neighborhood full of broken windows
and so if you can prevent the broken
windows you get uh people's behavior uh
improving and so I look at this bill as
kind of like the no broken windows
policy of plastic pollution it's not
going to solve the problem but it's
going to raise our expectations and U
it's something we ought to
do and imposes no costs on food
businesses but instead results in a
direct savings as restaurants no longer
need to stock as many reserves of these
single-use Plastics we're talking about
straws we're talking about cup lids
we're talking about the little stirs
that you that you get you know when on
your tray you're going through the line
and it ends up in the garbage it's not a
huge amount of uh of waste when you're
talking about the the total bulk or the
total volume of waste that we produce
but it's you know it's significant if
you go town by
Town it imposes no burdens on customers
they can simply request these items if
they feel they need to have them and it
results in a reduction of solid waste in
line with the state's official Solid
Waste Management plan
and more importantly it begin as I said
to turn the tide on the mountains of
plastic
garbage I hope you support this bill and
send a message that the New Hampshire
State House supports our official policy
on waste reduction and diversion and
supports Public Health outcomes implicit
you I'll take any qu represent GI has a
question take any
questions
yes thank thank you Mr
chairman I want to say in general I
support the ideas of this spill but my
question is if you have to ask for a
spoon every time you buy a bowl of soup
in say Panera Bread or a stir every time
you buy a cup of coffee isn't that going
to slow down service and impose some
considerable costs on uh the the seller
the the um facility and also um uh
inconvenience on the
customer yeah that's a good question uh
representative uh and I don't have a
figure on you know the time spent in
line when you're asking for spoons and
stirs and stuff like that so I don't
really know if that's a fact or not I
you know intuitively it makes sense but
then on the other hand really how much
time people spend handing over a spoon
you know across the counter is that
really going to affect the line I mean
it have to be pretty huge line to
actually have an impact but then again
you know you might have a point but I
don't have the answer to that so you
know it's a matter of conjecture and
it's something valid to think about for
sure well in terms of the question she's
saying if you're if you're ordering
soup I guess you could pick up the bowl
and drink it this way but you do need a
spoon yeah you should be given a spoon
you shouldn't have to ask you whether
you need
one why not that's what the bill the
bill says you have to add I mean you
you're asking for the soup so why not
say I need a soup spoon while you're at
it and I mean it's it's a simple change
in habit as far as I see you know it's
it's a different expectation of what you
have yeah I guess I was correct because
I I guess I haven't been to Panera Bread
in a while but evidently they provide
silverware they do provide silverware so
that's not a good example so here's my
example okay because you said is that uh
let's let's try to reduce it by not
having so much
available and um I was marveled uh and
I've only noticed this now know a couple
months ago when I was walking out of my
hords they have a this
display and the display has the plastic
silverware it has the forks the Spy the
Nunes and it's now so oh okay so like
these are things that you're trying to
avoid is that their idea that I was I
know they were saying is yeah so when
some someone goes to the salad bar or
somebody whatever they bought maybe and
instead of asking instead of having the
inventory at at every cash
register they have one stand as you
walking
out that provides those civilwar M or
plastic wear excuse
me that seems like a very efficient
effective that's customer asking for it
you know but doesn't have to ask an
employee doesn't have to work about
anybody but if I read this bill you're
saying they can't do that you got that
Ma out only dealing with food it's not
it's not dealing with Supermarket so
it's not not it's really a retail food
store yeah I mean doesn't count as a
retail food store it's a supermarket I
mean I don't know I mean does Hanford a
retail food store I don't think it it is
according to the definition yeah they're
yeah I me they have a salad bar that's
why we would need a
fork so so I'm just saying that it well
in in that case I think think having it
available at one place might be the same
thing as asking for it I mean you know
that's matter of interpretation minut it
and then the only other one I want to
tell you the irony of this bill is that
we've had legislation in this committee
before about um Sal guys with the carts
hot dog
carts and Health and Human Services
insists that they cannot use a little
bottle of ketchup or mustard that they
have to have those little plastic bags
the plastic single Ser packets we
require that by law so here we are we
required a law and now we're going to
make the person have to beg for
it well I mean you know representative
times change we've we've we at the time
that that that the department of human
health health and human services was
requiring people to change from the you
know the plastic the the bottle
dispensers to those condiment packets
maybe that made sense what we're seeing
now is that it doesn't quite make sense
but we're they're not going to change
the
rule no they won't we know we went
through that battle well I mean that
that's outside the scope of this
discussion we're not going to debate
other statutes we're debating know
besides we shouldn't even be dating this
okay but anyway represent bur would you
believe that a lot of not a lot some
Outlets like Hannafords and whatnot will
give you a spoon at checkout and one of
the reasons they do it is because some
people like to NAB all the silverware
the the plastic stuff and take it home
so I mean that's it actually benefits
the supermarket if they don't have
people taking 20 packets of of uh of
things they don't they don't need at
that moment I totally believe that and a
way it's a way of saving them costs
right I they're not getting their their
things stolen they don't have to stock
it every I mean that's kind of the
intent of this bill is to save the
question um
there are um places like um the
conquered Co-op that really is doing a
pretty good job with you know what
they're using and uh my my question was
um have you spoken with any of the
grocery stores uh Hanford that's a big
one in the state kind of try to have a
conversation with them regarding their
policies I I have not representative I
have not had a discussion with
supermarkets
okay represent go thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative for taking my
question um you mentioned that the
restaurants and food service
establishments are highly motivated to
do this anyways because it's one of the
intents of the bill to save them some
money so is there anything in statute
other than what representative hunt
mentioned uh that prohibits them from
already doing exactly what's in this
bill that's a good question I am not
sure if there is any prohibition on
doing something like this I but I
haven't heard heard of that so I would
doubt
that okay thank you very much thank you
okay do I
here right so this here
okay um so
uh I have I guess three people in a post
okay Ben Bradley New Hampshire Hospital
Association
okay so uh he he told me that we in past
years when we had this bill we actually
um Exempted the hospital Association uh
Henry veu New Hampshire lodging and
Restaurant
Association thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Henry veu and I'm here on
behalf of the New Hampshire lodging and
restaurant
Association um we had our government
Affairs call with uh the restaurant
folks on Monday and went over number of
bills this was one of them um and the
reaction we got from folks um was one um
the uh cost of the Alternatives uh to
plastic wear are more expensive uh so
there was a cost factor in terms of what
the alternatives to the the plastic
spoons and forks um the issue of
Sanitation
um the plastic spoons and forks
evidently they're more sanitary than
some of the other
Alternatives um and then uh the last uh
thought and reaction from folks was
while this uh may be good in theory um
if you've ever worked in a restaurant on
a very busy night with so many things
that could go wrong and sometimes do go
wrong if you're adding the additional
factor in there for for instance someone
that wants a takeout order and you
forget to ask them whether they want the
spoon or fork and you just put it in
there anyways it'd be violating the law
um if you don't put it in and the
customer UPS it's just a no-win
situation so just the Practical
implications of all this stuff in theory
it sounds like it makes sense but again
if you've ever worked at a restaurant on
a very busy night um the practical
application of this stuff becomes a
little more difficult um and that's
largely
it okay yeah
yeah uh thank you for take my question
um in a restaurant if you're ordering a
takeout often times you're going back to
your house or back to the office where
they have civilware it's very similar to
you know please don't give me a bag
that's what I say I don't need a bag
there's only one so so I think if maybe
um the restaurants can ask do you need
you know utensils that only takes a
second so that might be something that
we can and I'm sure some of them do uh
to the idea of reducing you know their
costs um I I think just putting in
statute and having ramifications for not
doing it by law is a little bit
different so it's basically education
yeah
any questions see none thank you uh Ben
room thanks Mr
chairman I have testimony I can
circulate but thought I'd just get right
to it please
um so good afternoon my name's Ben
Bradley I'm the vice president of state
government relations with the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all the state's Community
Hospitals as well as specialty hospitals
um I understand maybe you spoke a moment
ago about a previous exemption for this
um Bill I'm happy to share my testimony
but um hospitals have scenarios where we
feel it's appropriate to ensure for
patient care um the use of some of these
products um and would ask for that
exemption
okay any questions from many members see
none oh we do repr brows just can you
give a scenario where a patient would
have to have plastic sure so um for
example what's been used in the past as
an example is um a paper straw um and
the ability to flex the straw so a
water
okay thank you oh we do have another
question
represent thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking our questions um just in the
in the area of exemptions I know you
represent the hospital industry are
there any other uh any other related
industries that you think uh might
require an exemption um candidly I can't
speak for other Industries I'm sorry I
don't represent them stay in your
lane okay thank you thank you got one
card left Jane
Corrections
opposition thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Jane
Graham I'm the Strategic Communications
administrator for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections um we're
opposed to uh HB 1207 in its current
form and respectfully request an
exemption as well um there are
complexities of food service provision
within a correctional environment that
we think this bill would have some
unintended consequences on we understand
and appreciate the importance of
reducing our environmental impact and
promoting
sustainability um however this bill will
adversely impact the safety and
efficiency of our food services in
correctional facilities and in our
security psychiatric unit um Safety and
Security are vital our general
population units for the most part are
able to utilize um
reusable um silverware and Trays however
in some of our higher security units and
in our secureity psychiatric units
they're using um the single use trays
and utensils much more
frequently um the plastic utensils trays
and containers although they're
disposable are designed to minimize some
risk um and this piece of legislation um
inadvertently compromises the safety
protocols within our facility um we also
realized during the pandemic um that we
needed to we have obviously have a
congregate living setting um in
maintaining that hygiene is critical um
we have resident workers that work in
our kitchens and we also have like
regular staff that work in our kitchens
um and if we ban um single use
disposable food wear during when we have
a time like an emergency like that we
would not be able to manage that
situation without the use of some um
single use foodware so and thank you
very much I'm happy to answer questions
so where where in terms of the build you
read that that uh you were banned from
using them allog
together uh we would be we're not
allowed we would have to ask people if
they wanted utensils and that's not
always I got you we don't we don't ask
PR just
well but the problem is is that some
people we wouldn't have an alternative
for some people have to use those
utensils so we can ask them if they want
a utensil but I don't have an
alternative to give them if they don't
got it okay but we do have a question
representa own yes thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question yes
sir I understand you represent the
corrections uh uh
industry well the state I work for the
Department of Correction so not the
counties but
I I guess I misspoke when I said
industry uh can you think of any other
departments or industries that might may
require an exemption um I don't want to
speak for others but I you know Health
and Human Services obviously runs a runs
a hospital as well so I would think that
they would yeah
perhaps okay have
a
yes a question about the single use
trays why would you need to use those
and not plastic
trays um go so sometimes in certain
settings like our secure psychiatric
unit um we may have to use them with
some of our patients there because the
hard plastic tray could be used as a
weapon yep unfortunately and with and
then with the silverware can also be
used for self harm
so unfortunately great thank you thank
you okay so the remaining cards are in
support um so I hope you'll not belabor
too much because I think we pretty
Walter hello thank you for taking my
testimony um I'm glad to be here I'm
glad to be one of the first persons um
so here's how I see this bill um I've
been a waitress and I've worked in
hospitals and I've also taught about um
plastic pollution and and other forms of
pollution as well I'm also a taxpayer
who's very tired of the severe increases
in solid waste that I need to pay for
from my town budget it's a big deal it's
tripled for some towns um for solid
waste so here's what happens and here's
how I'd like to see this bill um move
forward I know I'm speaking to the bill
as it's written but I see in this
bill parts of what I'm about to cover
and I have a a one pager that'll take a
few seconds for you to read and I'll
pass it out in a minute but here's what
happens to me as a person who orders
takeout there's no mechanism in most
takeout systems whether it's on the
phone or on the computer for me to say
that I don't want this stuff it's
takeout I'm taking it to my home in most
cases where I have what I
need and so I get this stuff I get a
wonderful food in here and I can throw
away this I can recycle this bag but I
get this junk now I have to pay my city
to throw this
away it's a waste of my time it cost
cost the the retail the the restaurant
money and time to put this in it costs
them money and time for them to order
and stockpile all this stuff in their
restaurant I've talked to restaurant
people they don't like piling this stuff
together they don't like dumping it in
here finding room for it among all the
foods and so on if it's needed for the
stew or the soup then they they put
right next they can put right next to it
one there now you say well why do they
why don't these retailers and restaurant
owners just do this is why don't we just
let it be optional here's the problem
with that when it's
confusing to the customer like myself
some ask you some don't ask you some
will give it automatically some don't
give it when it's all a mix then it's
too confusing for us and they just dump
it on you anyway so we customers and we
taxpayers get to have to work with this
and I think slimming this bill to a take
out by order by request materials will
save a lot of the problem and not have
to work with that
problem and so I would I know we're
supposed to speak just to the bill the
way it's written but I I do want to say
that those aspects of the way the bill
is written do allow for understanding
this as a benefit for take out and take
out receivers for take restaurant take
out restaurants and take out receivers
like myself thank
you
so I don't know about you but whenever I
do takeout I always open the bag before
I walk out to make sure I got what I
wanted and if they did stick the plastic
silver in there why aren't you just
pulling it out and giving it back to
them often it's stapled to the receipt
often I don't have time um a a
grandchild who's picking it up for me
they won't do that they're kids you know
so I mean you you can't expect the
customer to know to do this and know to
do that all the time in the restaurants
to know to do this and know to do that
if it's
automatic then it helps everybody move
forward and have less waste and remember
that waste is a big burden on our towns
thank
you okay repres Amman has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for
answering our questions um help me
understand the penalty for an
establishment not complying with this
law what what happens if they're a
repeat offender and they keep they keep
putting the silverware the plasticware
$100 a day well I again I I have I
don't I didn't write the bill and I
haven't been able to uh uh um you know
consider that that aspect of the bill so
I couldn't say anything about that I'm
I'm a C I'm just a customer and a
tour representative
Bros I'm I just wonder if you've
explored it I mean might it just be
easiest I mean a lot of us now order
online on our phones or computers um
they can add a a
um a part of the online order you want
utensils or
not well yes but again if it's across
the
board a recommendation or requirement to
do it across the board on takeout orders
whether it's Again by phone or by by by
online then it's a question
of competition here's the issue for
competition if one restaurant does it
and another restaurant doesn't do it
that I'm not comparing the co the the
restaurants based on the quality of
their food the quality of their service
I'm confused by this website and that
website and this yes and no and this bud
this box and that box you see what I
mean we want the best competition to
happen for our restaurants and the best
competition gives me um a standard to go
for um when I get a chance to order take
out with or with not without these these
additions for the question meire um
would you believe there is no standard
ordering form online now everyone has a
different different one and just to me
as a consumer which you believe I'm more
like to go I don't go to I mean I
shouldn't say I don't go to Panera as
much cuz I don't like their packaging so
and I don't like all the plastic so you
know I think it's just a market I mean
actually I think it benefits the um the
establishments to to ask that and you
make the decision
yourself right it's just that you you
don't always know these things until
after they've happened because it could
be irregular I love small businesses not
not chains so I I want to support the
small businesses and I want them to have
this guidance and this Level Playing
Field so that I can compare one small
restaurant versus another small
restaurant based on their food and their
service and not whether or not they're
they're dumping this in you know I just
can't keep up with all that you know so
I I appreciate your your positions here
and I know those are good
counterarguments but I think we need to
look
forward represen m thank you Mr chairman
thank you for bringing the props and for
bringing these issues up as someone
who's travels a bit for business and
I've had more than one occasion where
I've had to Fashion a utensil after
forgetting to check the box because I
too was confused by Uber Eats door Dash
GrubHub Eat24 etc etc what I found now
is they universally do not include
utensils unless you specifically ask for
them so would you believe or do you
think that it's already within their
purview to just not give them to you
like without us telling them that's what
they have to do some C Works where some
restaurants like Panera chooses to do it
out out of convenience because it's just
rolled into their cost and you're paying
for it anyways so do we do we really
need this
bill to get the result that's already
starting to happen actually and they're
already motivated to
do that's your judgment to to to call
thank
you there you go what you
believe thank you very much uh chair
we'll call
ahead
out
uh hello good afternoon my name is
Kelsey Sullivan um I'm a member of the
public I live in Dover I'm also
volunteer with New Hampshire Surf Rider
and the New Hampshire Network and uh my
comments will be very brief I don't want
to be redundant of other people here
testifying but um uh to summarize the
major points of this bill HB 1207 which
would create a skip the stuff policy um
a policy like this um is simple it
simply means that restaurants and food
establishments would not automatically
provide single-use Plastics customers
that wanted those items uh would simply
need to request them and the benefits
would be uh to lower consumption of
single-use plastics to decrease New
Hampshire's Solid Waste burden to
decrease plastic litter in our
communities and to um as has already
been described save local New Hampshire
restaurants money um I don't have new
ampure numbers but nationally it's
estimated that restaurants spend around
$19 billion annually on disposable food
wear um and as has been mentioned
previously with uh lower demand
restaurants would not need to order and
stock as much uh this policy is not a
ban it does not seek to get rid of or
replace single-use Plastics um and
you'll see as it is currently written
there already language there that
provides for the provision of these
disposable items um if there are safety
concerns or concerns about spillage of
the food um that's it for my testimony
before I leave I will hand out two
documents one is a fact sheet um about
skip the stuff and the other some
comments from our local New Hampshire
Surf Rider chapter so that's it unless
there are any
questions I guess we're all
set what is Sur wrer uh ocean protection
and Beach cleanups oh
b middle letter it's a little confusing
for
me
chairman hunt and honorable members of
the House Commerce and consumer affairs
committee thanks for taking our
testimony today my name is Christine
babur um from Dover where I am co-chair
of the Dover plastic reduction group for
the past year we've been working with
restaurants and cafes in Dover on an
initiative called skip the stuff that is
led by Surf Rider Foundation New
Hampshire it essentially engages these
businesses restaurants cafes coffee
shops to voluntarily Implement what
house bill
1207 would
require accessories such as utensils
straws stirrers and condiment packs are
provided by request only I expect that
each of you have at home some drawer
some cabinet some Bag where you have a
supply of these items that you neither
takeout most people end up just
discarding them often without even using
them
the initiative that we're involved in
and I think the the bill that is under
consideration here has
signage that lets people know that this
is an
establishment
that that requires or requests in this
case we kindly ask that you request
accessories if you need them and the
participating restaurants cafes have
these signs both in their windows and
they also have them in areas where you
can pick up the stir the straws whatever
you need but the idea is that there not
automatically
included a report by the Overbrook
foundation in
2020 um called the Dirty Truth About
Food Service disposables notes that the
most that the useful life of most food
service disposables is measured in
minutes however these materials
particularly the Plastics May last in
our landfills for hundreds of years and
these the numbers of these items are
561 billion individual plastic utensils
are used by Americans every year and
most of these utensils are not
recyclable because of their size that
lets them slip through
or
um uh perhaps Jam Machinery that's
trying to do the recycling and because
they are made of different types of
plastics so they're not easily
sortable it's also reported that the US
discards about 500
million straws daily during a five-year
research cleanup study
7.5 million straws were found on us
shorelines
alone House Bill
1207 and we kind of refer to it as the
skip the stuff bill because it is so
close to the work that we're doing
offers a simple opportunity to save
restaurants money since they would
distribute many fewer unwanted and often
unused items by providing these items
only by consu customer request we can
also reduce the amount of plastic and
other unnecessary materials entering our
waist
stream this bill therefore also responds
to the
2022 New Hampshire Solid Waste
Management plans goal number one which
is reducing Solid Waste through Source
reduction some might ask and I I sort of
got this idea from some of the comments
that you made so if if some restaurants
and cafes are doing this
voluntarily why do we need this
bill what we hear from the restaurants
that we've been working with is that
they really need a Level Playing
Field one owner said that he's minimized
accessories that are provided without
request but that if he doesn't include
utensils for example in the Bool that
they uh that they sell for takeout he's
vulnerable to getting rated negatively
online um so we know restaurants are are
still pretty fragile post pandemic I
have not heard um I think representative
Gibbs raised the question about whether
this would slow down service and I have
heard no comments about that um if
people are aware that they need to ask
when they walk in they'll know that
they're not going to get something
automatically will'll be ready to ask
and I I think as representative burough
pointed out a lot of the online ordering
apps allow you to include that question
so that that would be addressed in that
way this bill is very straightforward it
costs customers state governments and
municipalities basically nothing it
saves money for restaurants and cafes
and reduces municipal waste and litter
if customers need and want these
accessory items all they have to do is
ask otherwise we can all just skip the
stuff I urge you to vote ought to pass
on House Bill
1207 thank
you represent
Burrows thank you for taking my question
just to understand the I see that you're
ni skip the stuff low
are you the stores that you're working
with I think you said do are they
putting up this logo in their stores or
this is something that you're promoting
to
educate what we do we um go around meet
with owners and managers we provide
posters like this um some people put
them in their Windows some people put
them on the the areas where they have a
accessories that people can pick up as
they walk out the door um and we provide
them with an educational sheet about why
this is um being
initiated the benefits to them as well
as some other information that might be
of use to the
restaurants followup CH for for the
question so I'm just wondering if I if
if I live in Dover or wherever and I'm
get to know what skip the stuff is and I
see that logo in the window I'm going to
be more likely to go into that store
right um so exactly I mean I'm just
wondering if that's a better way to go
rather than making it a law because I
mean that's what happened with the GMOs
that became you know there that little
no GMOs uh label I think that's been
really effective and I think that might
be even more effective than creating a
law just a
thought
all
much okay uh
Foundation that's
one good afternoon thank you to the
chair and members of of the committee my
name is Heidi trarco at the conservation
law Foundation we're a nonprofit
environmental advocacy group and I'm
part of CF zero waste
team and I am here to urge the committee
to to vote ought to pass on HB
1207 and um it's been mentioned a little
bit um in some of the prior testimony
but I'd like to draw the committee's
attention to our state law which
requires the state to achieve certain
way waste R reduction goals and waste
diversion goals and this law was enacted
25 years ago so in 1990 the legislature
determined that we should have a waste
reduction and diversion goal the goal
was uh enacted later on in the 90s and
for 25 years we've had these goals and
made no progress we continue to permit
landfills and we continue to import
waste from out of state and we import
about 50% of our waste from out of state
for the benefit of private for-profit
landfill
companies we can do something about this
and we need to do something about this
so the waste diversion goal is to reduce
our waste by 25% by 2030 and 40% by 2050
and this is established by the
legislature the legislature has also
enacted our Waste Management hierarchy
which puts Source reduction as the top
tier the top choice for how to manage
our waste and so if we are going going
to do Source reduction we have to take
measures to reduce the S our waste at
the source and this bill is a very
straightforward Source reduction bill so
um following the state's Waste
Management hierarchy this bill should be
a top priority for this committee and
for this
legislature um and in fact the state
updated the solid waste management plan
in 2022 and the first goal in that plan
is to reduce our
waste and according to the Department of
Environmental Services the top goal is
to reduce the quantity of solid waste
generated and the a strategy to do that
is to explore legislation including um
programs such as this to reduce single
use products so
um this is really uh an easy step it
should be in beginning step to reduce
our waste and as you've heard um it is
not a ban on any products and anybody
body who wants these products can have
them and so I think uh it is a pretty
straightforward measure I would not
there was some um concerns from the
hospitality Association regarding
alternatives to plastic wear being more
expensive uh this bill doesn't
contemplate alternatives to plastic wear
it's um an opt-in so if you want plastic
wear you can have it and if you don't
want it you don't need it um so the same
with the sanitation concerns um this
bill doesn't replace the plastic wear
with Alternatives it's just an op in to
use um and with that we have some
detailed testimony about the bill which
I will um circulate but we urge the
pass
okay almost it thank you thank you all
right have no more
cards uh you know do you mind grabbing
sheet
1277 Okay so
um we have Alvin C is
opposed uh Michael Granger is
and um is in support Patricia Betha Nini
was in support Jim demur from New
Hampshire rela retail association is
opposed uh John Tut Hill is
support Bonnie Christie
is in support Bruce Burke is uh for it
Heidi tomarco we just heard from her
Bruce berky is opposed to it and
representative Josh yoken is also
opposed to it and with that I will close
the public hearing on
127 yeah
okay
okay do I have a card from
you did you put a card
in
that's
fine good
afternoon oh okay go uh okay sorry um my
name is representative Sher Duty I
represent nashwa Ward three and I'm here
to present my bill uh HB
1636 so I guess the first question is
what oops let me take my mask down uh
why introduce another container deposit
system bill over the past two decades
several container deposit system bills
also known as bottle bills and I'll
refer to it that way because it's it's
just easier have gone down to defeat so
why this bill and why
now um this is a bottle bill um this is
the first bottle bill that I have read
that streams streamlines the process
makes it less con uh complicated and is
understandable I have looked at Michigan
Oregon Maine and a few
others producers are now recognizing the
importance of their role in reducing
trash from the products they produced
prod sell and from which they generate
profits this trend is called epr
extended producer
responsibility it transfers disposal
costs for their packaging from
municipalities to the
producer in the ENA committee on which I
serve yesterday an epr bill for
packaging was
introduced although it is recognized
that the bill needs work
industry is supportive of the concept of
epr and bottle bills have a long history
as the foundation of epr with the
Michigan bottle Bill going back to
1978 another reason why I've introduced
this bill is because tipping fees
continue to increase as landfill space
becomes scarcer on the ENA committee we
do a lot of work in terms of of landfill
um and landfill uh citing issues tipping
fees are based on weight any item uh any
items that can be taken out of the waist
stream help decrease the cost to
municipalities the conquered monitor on
Sunday had an article on recycling in
one case tipping fees have gone up from
$30 a ton to $90 a ton with
municipalities having no control over
this
cost New Hampshire has not even met the
recycling goals the legislature set in
1993 we are swimming in trash and we
really have to look at a way to begin to
control this um as a society we must
understand that mineral resources are
finite and that some of what we call
trash has value even now we are
importing primary aluminum sheet because
we no longer have the
resources in the United States to
produce a produce primary aluminum sheet
um for
cans aluminum cans can be made of
secondary aluminum sheet which comes
from recycled cans a bottle bill has
shown to increase recycling rates
dramatically while increasing the
quality of the recycled material
something the industry welcomes I spoke
Rec recently uh with a govern government
relations person from the manufacturing
can Institute and they would welcome a
bill like this because it would in
dramatically increase the recycling
rates of aluminum and therefore they
would have more material to work with
and would have to import less so what's
the advantage of this bill it puts the
industry in Char in charge by allowing
them to create a PR a producer
responsibility organization to manage
the program previous bills that have
been presented um were of concern uh
because they had um government agencies
in charge of the program and it didn't
appear to be coste effective so one
we're putting uh producers in charge of
the
program it puts Dees in charge of
oversight and covers and PR cover all
cost of this oversight
responsibility so the cost to the
taxpayer is um non-existent because it's
going to come out of the the Redemption
uh
payments it transfers the cost of
disposal from the
municipalities and therefore the
taxpayer to companies that produce
it it gives retail outlets to discretion
in where to locate redemption centers
and it compensates them for their
space it enables other entities to
become redemption centers if they so
choose because we understand that um the
the needs and requirements in the North
Country may be a lot different uh than
what we're seeing in let's say Nashua
Manchester or or other uh
cities murfs which are material recovery
facil facilities okay receive 50% of the
Redemption value per container type they
also receive an annual payment of 5% of
scrap value from the beverage container
material the organization sold the
previous year okay so we're trying to
make a bill that is fair in which
everybody is probably going to take a
little bit of a hit but um they you know
they it will be done fairly and uh you
know do it in a way where um you know
the in the end the environment and the
economy can also
benefit um this bill will trigger the
lowering of the beer tax from 30 cents
per gallon to 18 cents per gallon
thereby giving industry the option to
reinvest those savings or pass them on
to
Consumers and although there are other
um important points in this bill I will
say lastly that there is a grant and
education program
requirement um and it is really
imperative that we continue to educate s
uh successive Generations on the value
of reduce reuse and recycle what we have
done in the past is done you know um we
blast out an educational program and
then nothing happens for a long time the
other thing is is we don't have what I
would call a point of sale education
program and I think something like this
a bill like this could begin to do point
of sale as well as the broad um
marketing programs that have happened in
in the past the other thing that I was
thinking about which I think could be
very interesting um right now what you
have in several communities in New
Hampshire is they're not even recycling
uh plastic plastic they they've just
stopped it okay if we are going to have
a Redemption value on on plastic okay uh
one that helps the consumer okay but the
other thing is is that there will be
more money going into the fund and I
think one of the things that we really
want to push for going forward is to be
able to have uh more recycling um more
industry come to New Hampshire um that
can hand hand Le recycled um uh recycled
material and I think the biggest thing
is any municipality that you go to will
say the biggest issue that they have is
glass glass is heavy uh it doesn't
produce a lot of money on the recycle
markets okay and they would love to get
rid of glass out of their um Municipal
streams and I think this right now my
understanding with the northeast
regional
Recovery
Association is that um recycled glass is
going in in two ways one it's being
crushed and put in um roadways and the
other thing is is that organization is
sending it to Canada uh for actual
recycling I think they melt it down and
they make new um glass bottles out of it
we are also um running out of or have
runed out of the silica maybe that we
used to to make glass so I think that
would be an excellent opportunity for us
to be able to use some of the money from
this fund and maybe have a glass
recycling processing facility in New
Hampshire um that could benefit maybe
just New Hampshire or the entire region
if we needed to have more um re you know
more um glass to go through that so in
closing I would like to say that for
those in the industry that say they
support epr but this bill is not the
vehicle I say let's use HB 1636 as a
template to make epr a reality in New
Hampshire it is a fair bill in that
everyone must make some concessions for
the good of the economy and and the
you okay uh represent
spear just a question uh do you know of
any state that is doing something like
this and how successful they might
be that has a bottle bill that yeah that
has a bill similar where producers are
responsible for collecting well a
producer responsibility is really is
really gaining um uh momentum okay and
the one thing that like I said before a
lot of the other bills had problems with
is that it put the government okay so
we're at actually you know we this bill
uh wants to um and the word Escapes Me
want wants to come together with
industry okay and and I will say to you
this is you know this is a a template
after I end my talk it will become your
bill but I think what's really important
here is to think
about we need to start someplace okay we
we need to start someplace and this bill
as it's presented you know may not be
the bill that gets passed but I think we
can start to look at it and to continue
to educate ourselves this is this is a
very complex issue and I and My Hope was
in presenting this is that we could work
together to craft a bill that would work
for New Hampshire and when I saw the P
um model that was being presed I really
felt that that was a key part in our
moving representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um as with
the previous Bill uh I support the idea
of of this bill but I have two questions
one minor and one major and more General
uh the first question the minor one has
to do with lines 13 and
um and it says uh a beverage container
means a prepackaged container such as a
carton pouch or as septic packageing is
there some reason why can and bottle are
not in
there okay uh what page oh you're saying
first page the first the first page of
the bill lines 13 and
14 uh let's see and definition of
Beverage
container and it's a
definition it's it's Roman numeral 3
is yeah I'm sorry representative you're
saying it's page two I'm going to show
you no no okay it's page
two
one bage yes it's the defin it's under
definition of beverage container okay
okay so it's it's
page
um but I think it's it okay I would say
it's under
here uh where it says um is made uh is
made of any multimaterial or material
including but not limited to glass
plastic or
metal it I notice that honestly it's
confusing um but and if I were a lawyer
representing a a um uh a seller the
first thing I would argue is this
doesn't cover cans and bottles they're
excluded
um so that's something you might want to
take into account I mean that's clearly
something that we could uh work SM no
point it out yeah uh okay the more
general question and I have to say that
after reading this whole bill I had
planned to ask why is it so excessively
complicated why is there so much if it's
a then we do B and if it's C then we do
D and if it's e then we do F uh but
after hearing you say that the this was
the Least Complicated bottle Bill you'd
ever seen uh I have to ask how could it
complicated representative Gibbs I can I
can show you the Michigan Bill trust me
I have I have gone through a lot of
bills uh Oregon being one of them
Michigan being one of them Maine be
being another one and I have tried to
map out how the money you know is
distributed I can truthfully tell you
okay um this is a dream compared to
those other bills it's a
dream and and I wish we could make it
even more simple maybe the subcommittee
could do that but um it it's really a
complicated it it's really a complicated
process because you have so many
different players okay not not only do
you have I mean so think about the
transfer stations where they separate
their recyclables think about you know
uh NASA and gtown that have single you
know single
stream um then think about um the Cassel
the republics the pinards you know that
have a a a piece of the action um you
know um think about the transfer
stations that might you know uh uh want
to keep things the way they are it
sorry repr bar just a quick question
because I don't I didn't hear an answer
to representative Spear's question has
any other state passed this this uh done
the
PR's you you mean yeah um I can check
for you okay um yeah I'm not I know that
Illinois that that this bill was be a
similar bill was being being introduced
in Illinois and in Maryland I don't
think it's passed but um you know Oregon
might have maybe but but let me check
and I'll I'll get back to the committee
on that I thought that Maine and Oregon
both had it you know I'm not I'm not
sure yeah
okay uh
yes so
uh if you're talking about cost savings
the taxpayer and going on I guess the
problem I have right out of the block
and and not sure I can it can I can cure
this problem is that we're asking
everyone who buys a six-pack to pay an
extra uh it looks like 10 cents 60 cents
okay so we're raising the cost of uh
beverages in no the there the fiscal
note I I the fiscal not is incorrect
okay well I'm just looking reading the
law it says no no no except on each
bever sold or offered at sale and the
state shall have the following
Redemption refund value of 10 cents y so
theoretically that 10 cents has got to
come from somewhere so it's going to be
added to the sale of the product right
and you will only pay for that if you
choose to uh throw the can in the
garbage right if you choose to redeem
the can
okay then you get that 10 cents back I
understand that okay and and believe you
me I started out um in college uh
actually my first job in Vermont and
they had the bottle Bill and so I've
known about the value it was great I I
had a dormatory because it was a private
school and at Christmas break I went
through and got all the empties in all
the kids' rooms and B bought myself a
turkey and had a good old thanks thanks
to the bottle bill but it does require
people to then take these things back it
requires people to collect it and take
it back okay so not withstanding that
even today when I was down you know
eating at our restaurant here and I
looked at the garbage can and they're
full of bottles and cans even though
right next door to it is a place to put
bottles and cans but people still throw
them away go so my problem is is that
we're raising the cost of beverages to
everybody in New Hampshire right now the
beer tax which as you duly noted is
going to get reduced by whatever this
does yeah the beer tax is so flat we're
only making like $5 million a year it is
like nothing we're our collection at 30
cents of gal is so minimal we're barely
having a profitable and you think about
all the new products that on the market
you know all these spritzers and all
these other stuff but the beer tax is
still that flat $5 million my my concern
is that what you're actually doing is
just making it for all New Hampshire
citizens taxpayers and all to pay
more for their six-pack for their pay
everybody's going to pay more you're
assuming everyone's going to duly turn
them in okay I'm assuming they're not
I'm assuming they're still throw them in
the garbage can okay and this thing is
just a boond doggle for the people who's
that processor or wherever the this
entity that that that
doesn't have to collect them because
people aren't going to turn them in well
there's also Targets in the bill okay so
the the producer responsibility
organization has to meet certain targets
I believe the first Target is 75%
redeemable within five years and what
happens if they don't reach the target
if they uh then at there's uh penalties
and more penalties so the cost of the
beer is going to go up some more no it's
in the B it's in the bill I know but you
were saying every everything is just all
you're doing is raising the cost theen
up front when a person buys that
sixpack that's what you're raising start
there I'm not even going to all the
other savings and money savings that
you're talking about I'm talking about
why are we
raising beer and water anything why are
we raising the cost of them when there's
so much other trash that's out there
there's so many other problems we
haven't solved way but we're take we're
picking on people who want to drink
liquids and we're making them pay more
money but rever on the reverse side
we're only making them pay more money if
they choose not to redeem it and you
have to recognize those who choose not
to redeem it those costs are then being
uh uh transferred over to the taxpayer
because they become a tipping fee so
somebody's paying it one way or the
other and I would prefer that it be paid
you know I mean that people who are
irresponsible pay it rather than the
responsible
taxpayer and what we have in this bill
is redemption centers anybody can become
a Redemption Center okay so most likely
you will redeem them at the grocery
store where you go every week okay
that's what my brother does in Michigan
you know you get a little ticket and it
says okay you just got $2 or $ three do
you go to the check out and you know you
get two or three dollars off so
representative somebody's paying one way
or the other and I would you know choose
um to reward people you know who um uh
feel that they have a responsibility you
know to our planet to our environment
and to the economy I mean because we can
create new
manufacturing uh facilities and new
technologies are coming down the road
and New Hampshire should be a part of
that because we aren't right
now fair
enough and can I just say one thing um I
have the total beer tax revenue in
fiscal um July 1
9961 and uh reducing the beer tax would
reduce it by about 5 million uh $5.2
million and you know as we all know um
the New Hampshire legislature last year
or uh last session uh passed a bill to
eliminate the uh dividends and interest
tax which I think is going to eliminate
$57 million so if we feel that
eliminating a tax is in the best
interest of the taxpayer then I think
you know redu in the beer tax from 30
cents to 18 cents is also in that same
Gibbs uh back to the uh question of
penalties As I understood it the
penalties are on the seller who runs the
collection center but the penalty will
be if the Redemption targets are not met
but how can the seller force people to
return the bottles and
cans
well I mean that it's it's on the P to
be able to create marketing programs
okay and in and incentives so that
people will want to return um you know
their bottles and cans to get the
Redemption money back I think part of
that also you know is being smart in
terms of uh making it easy for people to
redeem the their bottles and cans so for
example I mean right now you have people
that take their bottles and cans uh you
know to the transfer station and you you
know so a transfer station could become
a Redemption Center and and they could
just redeem them there or they could
continue you know to put them in the
recycle bin and then their money would
just go to the
iset uh further question thank you uh
when the bottles and can are returned
could they be returned as is that is
when you finish drinking the beverage or
would they have to be washed no no they
do not have to be washed and and thank
you for raising that point because one
of the things um uh bottle bills do a
number of things first of all they not
only improve uh the number of bottles
and cans that are um returned but they
also uh improve the quality and for
companies to be able to recycle bottles
and cans it's important to have the um
the quality the other thing is it's been
shown over and over again that having a
bottle Bill overall um increases the
amount of um recycling that takes place
you know right now uh New Hampshire is
at
23% okay repres Ammon thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking our questions I
just want to focus on the labeling
requirement piece of the bill uh could
you explain what kind of uh potential
burden that would place on the the
container manufacturers and then just a
second part what happens if bottles come
from out of state that aren't labeled
can they be recycled so two parts uh the
bill indicates that the the only uh
containers that can be recycled or
redeemed uh have to be sold in the state
now we know you know that that doesn't
always happen but um you know that's
what the bill states that it has to be
sold in the state um there would be
virtually no cost to the manufacturer
because if you look at your you know for
example I just bought a juice bottle um
the other day and I was I was stunned to
see it it's already there okay because
there's a Redemption value from Hawaii I
think you know so they have the things
on their Hawaii 5 cents you know
Connecticut or or whatever so all they
have to do is has changed uh their
software to add um NH 10 cents so
already Okay any more questions see none
thank you very much okay thank you uh
just to hear the other side let's have
Bri Dei come up from the New Hampshire
beverage Association American be uh
Hampshire beverage and the American
Beverage
Association
thank you Mr chairman my able assistant
problem I'm for the record my name is
Bri deatley I'm a principal of Breezeway
Consulting in Somerville Massachusetts
and I am here today representing both
for New Hampshire beverage Association
and the American Beverage Association uh
who represent the New Hampshire bottlers
and Distributors of non-alcoholic
beverages in the state um the um
beverage industry is uh an industry that
has for a long time supported the
recyclability and sustainability of our
packaging um and we have been uh
diligently working for the decades that
I've worked for the industry uh on
improving the recyclability the
sustainability and the recycling rates
of our package packaging um the majority
of our packaging is in pet bottles and
aluminum cans both of which are
lightweight very efficient um also
highly recyclable and also have a very
high recycling value that's not by
accident we've invested in the design of
those packages and in those materials to
make sure that when they at the end of
their life um they are recycled and
recyclable back into something a new
container that's valuable and is
valuable for the recycling stream and
can help pay their way through the
system they're couple of the few
materials in the waist stream today that
can pay their way back through the
system because of the value that they
have um I will say that uh the industry
has been directly involved in promoting
recycling through direct investment uh
our every bottle back program has
committed $100 million nationally to
investment in infrastructure which is
really more than anybody has committed
including the federal government to
those programs um over the last several
years but we have come to realize as a
result of the industry's commitments to
in use of recycled material in our
packaging uh and meeting other
sustainability goals that we need to do
more and that more includes in
involvement in policy and discussions
about around policy whether it be
extended producer responsibility as
yesterday or discussions about container
deposit or bottle Bill systems like
we're talking about
today um I want to be clear that um as
an industry because of the need to get
those containers back to turn into new
bottles and cans we do support
well-designed policies that are designed
to improve the recycling quantity and
quality of material um that said we are
in opposition to HB 1636 today because
we don't believe that this is an
efficient system that's outlined in this
piece of legislation um we believe the
infrastructure that's laid out uh it
would be specified through the bill is
redundant um we think the targets that
are established are unrealistic um we
think it's the bureaucratic system and
it would really adversely affect our
members ability to do business in New
Hampshire um let me just talk briefly
about each of those points and then um
because I do uh work on these issues
around the country and have worked on
these issues uh around the world um
happy to take questions about scope of
these programs where else they operate
how they operate and things like that if
if that's useful um uh representative
Duty talked about the central management
and the use of a producer organiz ation
to manage and direct this program and
that that is something of a novelty
amongst deposit systems and that is true
um only Oregon in the US has a program
that's similar to that but from our
perspective um you can't just simply say
well the producers are in charge so it's
good bill um as was noted earlier by
representative Gibbs this is an
extremely prescriptive Bill putting the
producers in charge of the system and
then prescribing the size of the signs
in the windows of the stores where they
take back the bottles and cans is pretty
prescriptive doesn't leave a lot of
flexibility for the producers and the
retailers to work out a system that's
efficient for consumers so when you walk
out the front door of a Hanford in in
West Leb and you look across the street
and see six other stores that have
exactly the same infastructure to take
back the same bottles and cans you're
not going to have a very efficient
system and that's one of our concerns
with this program um it's it's
inefficient it would result in a lot of
redundancy a lot of excess cost that
would ultimately be borne by
consumers um I mentioned the Targets in
the bill there are very high recycling
targets that are established in this
bill High both for Redemption rates and
then for the recycling of the material
that comes back it's early referenced
that uh the the bill would include
cartons aseptic containers uh and
pouches as well for which there are very
few if any markets in this part of the
country a lot of that material would be
collected and simply thrown away because
there's nothing to be done with it in
Vermont for example there deposits on
pouches they're collected from
redemption centers and thrown away
because there's nothing to do with them
um so um you know we don't need to be
paying the money to collect materials
like that and bringing those back when
they don't have value um the system is
fairly bureaucratic as I mentioned Dees
has more to do than it needs to do in a
system like this uh there should be a
lot more discretion left to the
producers in far as making a proposal
and having DS evaluate it um and and I
would just sort of point out the uh
representative Gib talks about the if a
then B then C then d uh if you are a
transfer station or a materials recovery
facility and you take back bottles and
cans that have deposits I defy you to
figure out in this bill how it is you're
supposed to get some kind of
compensation because it get
extraordinarily complicated to do that
um I I think it's important to finally
highlight and Mr chairman you sort of
talked about this about raising prices I
think it's important to realize and
recognize the impact of a 10 or 15 cent
deposit on a container in New Hampshire
I manage a Redemption system for about
85% of the returns that come back in
Vermont I managed the Redemption system
in Maine for about a quarter of the
redemptions that come back there's an
extraordinary amount of crossborder
redemption that happens a lot of people
in Vermont Massachusetts and Maine buy
their beverages in New Hampshire and
they take them home and they consume
them and they bring them back here uh
they bring them back to their to to
their deposit states to get them to to
get the refund um that means that
consumers in New Hampshire sort
of consumers outside the state you know
have a 5cent disadvantage if they buy
the product in state now we're talking
about here just to be clear is New
Hampshire would put itself at a five or
10 cent disadvantage to those
neighboring states reversing the flow of
both sales which sends the sales outside
of New Hampshire and reversing the flow
of the rid redemptions which would bring
the redemptions into New Hampshire
Connecticut has just gone to a 10cent
refund value and is surrounded by New
York and Massachusetts which have 5
cents the lines on January 1st and 2nd
at the redemption centers to get in to
capitalize on that difference were you
know extremely long people will do
ridiculous things for 5 cents um we as
as administrator of that system in
Vermont we had to send a letter from the
attorney general in Vermont several
years ago to all of the New Hampshire
border towns the Connecticut River
Valley reminding them that it was
illegal for them to collect bottles and
cans at their transfer stations and
bring them into Vermont for Redemption
they're still doing it they just hire
somebody to do it for them instead of
doing it with Town trucks but it is a
chronic problem um with that said um you
know we are interested in policies that
improve recycling we have invested in
New Hampshire's recycling system for
decades through new hure the beautiful
and directly through our companies um we
are certainly open to discussions about
better policies but we don't think this
you yes can you define New Hampshire the
beautiful what what the nonprofit does
um yeah my experience with New Hampshire
the beautiful is it is an organization
of retailers and beverage companies who
voluntarily made contributions to a fund
over the years who have paid for
equipment at transfer stations signage
at transfer stations um promotional
education most importantly the bags the
blue bags right bags so I know myself
because I do for my town of rench I come
up once a year to the resour here in in
Epson and get our five bags or five
boxes of you know 500 $100 500 bags and
we use that for our Earth Day in ringe
and which everybody goes out and picks
up along the roadsides so when you see
blue bags along the roadside which the
state highway department picks them up
but those are blue bags that they
provide it's not a big
deal
just thank you very much thank you okay
I have uh five cards here in support so
please uh be brief and to the point and
hopefully say something we haven't heard
already uh Bonnie
Christie
hi I'm Bonnie Christie from hopkington
thanks for taking the testimony I'm
delivering it today for Susan Richmond
who couldn't be here I hope that's all
right I'll just read what she's
written um and I think she has sent it
to the committee as
well dear members of the committee
please please accept this written
testimony urging you to support passage
of 1636 FN which would be of great
economic benefit to New Hampshire
residents I urge your support relative
to creating the New Hampshire container
deposit refund recycle and reuse system
I'm a member of my Town's she is from
Durham I'm a member of my Town's
Integrated Waste Management advisory
committee so I know firsthand the
expenses of dealing with our residents
waste even items that can be recycled
such as beverage containers represent a
cost when they are trucked to a
recycling center in Massachusetts or
when a resident has carelessly tossed
them in with their solid waste and they
must be trucked to the landfill where
they're charged a tipping fee our
residents pay these costs with their
property taxes but the costs have been
generated by beverage distributors who
created the containers but have not paid
for their
disposal HB 1636 would hold beverage
distri distributors responsible for
recycling these containers so they are
not a cost burden for municipalities and
taxpayers we have examples of programs
currently implemented in 10 states so we
know that they work locations in the
United States with the most successful
container deposit systems have found the
system pays for itself with deposits
that are not refunded meanwhile the
percentage of containers that are
recycled can be expected to exceed
85% as opposed to the average return
rate of 33% in states without a
container deposit
Bill additional benefits decrease in
roadway litter decreased expenditure of
energy and raw materials when the the
materials of these containers can be
recycled glass containers in particular
can be upcycled because they are not
contaminated in a bottle return system
as opposed to their usual contamination
in general recycling CL collection
aluminum can be recycled almost
infinitely in contrast with the high
cost of creating aluminum containers
from raw materials for the above reason
reasons I urge you to support hb1 1636
OTP ought to pass I view the bill as a
win for all thank you for your
consideration from Susan
Richmond okay you did I'll take that you
did I didn't get a copy okay yeah can we
can we take that
copy thank you
that's thank you very
babber thanks again for taking this
testimony
today on the fourth Saturday of each
month my husband and I join with other
volunteers in the don't trash do group
to pick up trash plastic bottles cans
and other waste items in one area of our
community so we we aren't doing it just
on Earth Day we're doing it every month
um for one hour and we use one hour
because because it's easier for people
to make commitments to that we pick up
all the trash um all the
recyclables that we can find and we have
collected up to 14 to 15 huge of the
blue bags um full in that period of time
although over the years that we've been
doing
this the residential neighborhoods have
shown a decrease in in litter it's
really nice to go back to some of these
areas and find that there's not a whole
lot to pick
up however in commercial areas and along
the roads and highways there's a
tremendous amount of discarded waste a
lot of this litter is made up of cans
bottles and other containers and most of
those are so dirty or so damaged that
they are not appropriate to put into
recycling according to bottle
build.org beverage containers make up
about 40 to
60% of litter on our roads and
highways um I went on the bottle Bill
resource guide this morning I don't know
if you've checked that out but it's it's
worth looking at um and this is a
project of the container recycling
Institute on there they have a
counter representing the number of
Beverage cans and bottles that have been
landfilled littered and incinerated in
the US so far this
year 20
24 I started to write the number down so
I could include it in my
testimony it was moving so fast that I
literally had to use my camera to take a
photograph of the counter so I could
write it
down that number was 2
trillion
88,000 26 containers and that was for
like a millisecond before it moved on
9th HB
1636 offers an opportunity to reduce
trash and litter across New Hampshire 10
state and Guam have similar container
laws with Oregon being the first state
1971 so we've had a lot of time to try
to think this through I I think it's
unfortunate with so many people that
seem to embrace the basic idea the basic
concept that the
industry and the leader leadership in
our state can't figure out a way to work
issue Oregon's Redemption rate now
Oregon has a container deposit bill so
Oregon's Redemption rate in
86% and do you remember what
representative Duty said New Hampshire's
78% so it it seems
clear that having a bill like this would
increase the capture of these
containers and they then could be
handled appropriately and hopefully um
reused the current system of handling
bottles and cans in New Hampshire is one
that puts the responsibility on
residents and
municipalities I expect you know we
could ask other people in this room and
we would find others that go around
their community and pick up these
things so it is our responsibility then
to try to get the containers recycled or
to spend time and energy picking up and
dealing with the litter and filling our
landfills traditionally the
manufacturers and beverage Industries
has opposed changing this and some even
claimed that consumers found found
inconvenient however Susan Collins of
the container recycling Institute told
NPR when there's a poll done in any of
the states that have existing deposit
laws we've seen support between
70% all the way up to
95% in I think Vermont and um one of our
previous testifiers may be able to um
verify that so much so these numbers
were so high that the pollsters had to
double check their numbers because they
didn't believe what they were
seeing once a program is in place
they're popular with
consumers like more than motherhood and
apple pie Susan Collins
says so let's do what's best for New
Hampshire residents and our environment
I urge you to vote ought to pass on this
you okay any
questions thank you very
Burke
Betty Hall Betty Hall yeah Betty bet she
put a bot she put a botle bill
in my name is Bruce bar from the town in
Pittsfield I'm not going to deliver my
prepared remarks because uh it is
running so late and we have a really
important bill that needs to be
discussed today which is p i I would
just say two things maybe three speakers
ago somebody gave an articulate uh
position why this bill should not go
through clearly well informed I would
ask her to be on the committee or the
subcommittee to help us pass a bill that
she thinks is manageable that seems
common sense to me the second thing I
would say is I don't think these bills
are necessarily going to pass today but
I would ask the commit I would ask this
committee to honor them enough to take
them into a subcommittee to study them
because we have a plastic problem we all
know that I'll give you one fun fact and
I'm done uh plastic bottles supposedly
take about 450 years to completely
decompose so when the pilgrims came in
1620 and they dropped their plastic
bottles at Plymouth they still haven't
completely decomposed thank
you uh just for everyone's uh
edification this is the Commerce
Committee and and I as the chair have
traditionally always had a subcommittee
on all bills in this committee and which
subcommittee Heidi
Foundation good afternoon again good
afternoon Heidi trarco with the
conservation law Foundation we have
written comments and so I will submit
those um and not get into um too much
detail but I we are here to urge the
committee to vote ought to pass on the
bottle bill and when I was here earlier
today I spoke about this legislature's
waste reduction and diversion goal
and just to remind the committee you
know that is we are as a state are to be
reducing our waste by 25% by 2030 and
45% by
2050 it has to come from somewhere
something has to be reduced is it single
use plastic are we going to be recycling
our bottles and so in addition to those
waste reduction goals we have the waste
management hierarchy also established by
the legislature and reinforced by Dees
in the latest Solid Waste Management
plan and this bottle bill would fall in
that hierarchy second which is Recycling
and reuse so the bill before should be
the top priority this would be the next
approach to managing our waste in a
responsible way um and I'm going to
provide Our Testimony which has a lot of
citations to where bottle bills have
been implemented successfully in the
past and there is some data here you
know showing how it vastly increases
recycling vastly reduces litter um I
think a lot of times we talk about the
increase in recycling but the reduce in
litter there's numbers that say litter
is reduced from 70 to 84% that is a huge
number um and saves municipalities money
and the other thing I'd like I'm so
happy that people brought this up
earlier you know just to remember that
there is a cost in these bottles not
being recycled we are when we keep they
you know as we all know when we put them
in the trash they don't go away they sit
in our landfills we have limited
resources for those landfills they sit
there and they are there forever so
let's make some smart decisions and
recycle what we can and we know that
bottle bills work and it's really proven
technology um and similarly I have very
fond memories of being a teenager and
collecting lots of bottles in
Massachusetts and taking them in uh
nothing incentivizes a kid or a teenager
more than 10 cents or 15 cents you
collect them all and um take them to the
grocery store and get some money back so
um it worked for me and I think it can
work for the rest of New Hampshire so we
urge the committee to vote a to pass
thank you yes this is just a what
jubile city of
Manchester burns the recycling they burn
their recycling we have recycling bins
they're blue we put all our recyclables
in there they pick it up I don't know if
it's um I don't know where they bring it
but it they burn
it which is yes incineration is not a
solution no we have a waste problem we
need alternatives to land filling our
waste and burning our waste and the the
top tier alternatives are to reduce the
waste that we're creating and then to
recycle what we can and uh some of the
easiest things to recycle are aluminum
and glass and so let's start there let's
adopt this technology that's been
happening in other states for decades um
and and move
forward thank you thank you uh one last
card
Walter
Walter more more R uh yeah so I don't
want to thank you so much for staying
here and being here at all and taking
this testimony I will try to make it
even shorter um to avoid repeats U I
want to make a couple points first of
all that that there is a huge quality
difference and income and opportunities
for more New Hampshire businesses when
this can goes into a Redemption Center
in New Hampshire which it does not now
because we don't have them this can can
then be the Recycled reused in
definitely as you've heard but I want to
emphasize the importance of new
businesses for New Hampshire in taking
these high quality perfectly clean um um
um aluminum cans we try in New in in my
city to put these cans in these bins but
they don't stay there they they move all
Al of places because they're so
lightweight and so they end up being
wasted and they end up being collected
by you know people who run around
collecting them and then they end up
being put into the trash this plastic um
can also have that same negative fate I
don't have a third bottle of glass but
again that glass reuse in my town we
used to collect the glass and reuse it
in in our um in our city uh uh sidewalk
committee they're all glitering all our
sidewalks are glittering with old glass
from the 1950s and so on it's beautiful
but there's no business to do that now
we can have that business back in my
town with those new jobs if we that
glass doesn't get messed up with all the
mixed use stuff but instead it goes
there I want you to see the business
opportunities with this program and I
also want you to understand that it was
because of the fine print and the
complexity of the bill perhaps you
didn't understand that the
pr is not locked into as many strict
ures that might have been described by a
previous opponent to the bill um perhaps
we again this the kind of thing that
needs to get worked out in subcommittees
or or any other structures you have that
the pr can have a good amount of
flexibility to be um um in Innovative in
keeping New Hampshire beautiful and
economically growing with new businesses
um the last thing I wanted to mention is
please remember this is Revenue neutral
on the big scale and remember that the
evidence from these Decades of other
states show
that there is no cost impact on prices I
so much appreciate that that you the
chair are concerned about us charging
more and more for bottles and cans and
so forth if we have this system I
appreciate that concern but if you
actually look at the actual numbers
which you haven't had time to do I'm
sure but those numbers have been
examined and there will be no impact on
this because these companies want to be
competitive and they're not going to
dump the 10 cents on us um they're going
to keep their products affordable um and
therefore um it's it's it's not a it's
not a danger so thank you again for your
concerns and uh um and I hope we can
move forward to uh to save waste thank
you okay
you have any quick questions or I guess
we're all set okay all right I have no
more cards uh representative Alin SEC is
opposed uh Michael
Granger uh uh I guess he for it uh
against it I scribbl it out I don't know
representative Daniel V is for it uh and
uh Rod Li is for it Patricia beod Nini
is for it John Tuttle is for it Ken
dagel of New Hampshire Grocers
Association is opposed uh Bonnie chrisy
from hopkington support Bruce he always
spoke Heidi she spoke Scott shy for the
beer distributors is in opposed mark
armaganian from the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission is opposed Kristen Coke of
the business and industry Association is
opposed Josh joken uh is opposed Tom
perasol represent ing the New Hampshire
retail association and the international
bottle water is also they're both the
post and finally Mike Somers New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association is opposed and with that we
close the hearing
bill
[Music]
hello
individual
[Laughter]
um
read
oh my good tell me when you're ready
yeah okay clerk is ready we're
ready okay well thank you very much to
the committee for hanging in there and
for the for the to the folks that want
to give testimony today um for the
record my name is Karen eel um I
represent the towns of New London and
Newbury that's marac District F uh seven
um many thanks to the committee for the
work that you've already done on the
carpets spill uh we learned a lot
through that process and I'm extremely
pleased to bring before the committee
today a new broader fully bipartisan
bill on P added products as you can tell
from the sponsors and I want to start
out by saying that this bill is really
unlike most bills that you're likely to
see before you there are a few things
that would Unite the solid waste
industry the wastewater treatment folks
drinking water
municipalities Public Health officials
environmental Advocates and our citizens
to speak with one voice I don't think
you'll see that very often P
contamination is a huge problem P should
not be in the air we breathe the water
we drink or the soil we walk on it
shouldn't be in the blood of our
children our grandchildren
our parents or in us I feel quite
confident in saying that every single
one of us as we sit here today have a
cocktail of past chemicals variously
constructed in our bodies as we in New
Hampshire in the US and globally
struggle to understand the magnitude of
an attempt to mitigate this problem the
answer is really pretty clear we have to
stop using products with P it's really
that
simple I would not want to sit here and
tell you that we should continue to
allow uh past products to be consumed
because I think that is not really
hearing what people want
today as we start the hearings I really
and I I realize it's a late hour but I
really can't um speak about this without
talking about the people who have
battled this before in our our state I
really ad admire them for the work
they've done and it's really been a
privilege for me to uh participate with
them in this uh battle and build on
their efforts I don't have a written
statement to share today but I did
provide the committee with informational
packets and I really uh thought it would
be helpful if I kind of talked about
this and walked through them to start
with I have to say that I come here
today as the chair of the state's
stakeholder group on solid waste the
solid waste working group and we
represent all facets of solid waste and
the solid waste IND industry its repre
representative membership is Broad from
landfill owners operators to
municipalities construction and
demolition debris handlers a waste to
energy plant and hospitals to M name a
few and its responsibilities include
bringing forth legislation to further
the goals of our recently adopted Solid
Waste Management plan one major goal is
the reduction of toxicity in our waist
stream our support of that goal led to
that bill this bill so it's important to
understand where the bill originated and
it's out of very real tangible concerns
of the broader stakeholder group on
behalf of our state and in furtherance
of the state
plan one of the most important things to
understand today as we start the
discussion is the interrelationship of
our solid waste and Wastewater systems
and the graphic that I have shown that I
brought here for you really tells the
tale and I won't take a whole lot of
time explaining it but what I want you
to see is that um what goes into the
landfill comes from and the and the
title as you see is past sources what
goes into the landfill comes from
industry and it also comes from us it
goes into the landfill the landfill has
leachate that comes out of it just
because of rain and some decomposition
the lee8 then has to go to the
wastewater treatment plant at the
wastewater treatment plant you also have
uh sewer um you know water you have
septage from our own uh tanks
and you have uh water from industry they
process that and what comes out of the
wastewater treatment plants stay with me
on this is
sludge and sludge much of what comes out
of the sludge include I mean is included
with the sludge is p some of the sludge
is turned into biosolids which is
treated and can be um uh put out on soil
but the sludge with the pasas uh to the
extent that it gets it goes back into
the landfill again so you've got the
trash the landfill the leachate the
wastewater treatment plant the sludge
back to the landfill again but in
addition wastewater treatment plants
release water to surface waters and at
this point it's not really being tested
for p but the requirement for p testing
is probably coming very soon and this is
going to be really expensive for um our
municipalities the other issue here of
course is drinking water and drinking
water is taken from ground and surface
waters and it's processed and it's being
tested to uh very very minuscule levels
for peace fast at Great expense and
being filtered and then something has to
happen with the filter and many of these
filters also can end up in the
landfill and then you know it rains
again and then there's Le so it's all
really interrelated and I think that's
why um when I come before you today and
you probably haven't had a chance to
read your emails but I have support
letters from the wastewater treatment
plants drinking water
municipalities um and public health
officials they're all really interested
in this um subject there's a letter of
support here from the New Hampshire
Water Pollution Control Association the
granted State Rural Water Association
and New Hampshire Waterworks Association
they bear a huge burden and it all comes
back eventually on the on the taxpayers
um from the solid waste folks we're uh
anticipating a national waste and
recycling Association letter that's the
national uh Solid Waste trade
Association and I'm looking forward to
receiving that letter um soon uh so the
next thing I want to talk about is money
in your packet you'll find an argu uh
article that summarizes the results of
the uh Minnesota pollution and
environmental um control agency that
analyzes um Minnesota as far as
remediation costs and the numbers really
are
breathtaking um they estimated that for
every one pound of past that's purchased
it can for 15 to ,000 it can cost $2.7
to18 million to mitigate the effects
under you know circumstances when it
gets into the environment and they also
estimated just looking at Wastewater and
biosolids 14 billion to 28 billion
dollar over 20 years to remediate p F
that's the estimate that that you know
their government um put together and
that's described in the article that I
gave you um as everyone knows there's no
real accepted affordable method yet on
how to destroy P once it's out in the
wild um you can look at it later but I
wanted to go back to our own LBA and
talk to them about how much State money
has been expended what I have for you
there is a summary of the Pas um
response fund it's about $75 million
there's other related costs that aren't
included in that but I think it's safe
to say that the state has probably got
around hundred million do into
this who knows how much municipalities
and wastewater treatment and drinking
water treatment facilities have already
expended on this so when you're thinking
about the cost maybe to the A agency um
of something like this it's just really
important to keep these numbers in
mind um I also gave to you if the
copying got done a picture of the USGS
map that shows that every single place
they tested for past they found it in
the
state um I so that just showed the
widespread
contamination um I don't have a map of
it here but there's also a past water
sampling map that map that's available
on the dees website again the spread of
the stuff is absolutely
breathtaking um I also have given you a
p fact sheet that was prepared by Dees
that tells you an awful lot about the
circularity of the of the P um getting
into our system how to avoid it and how
it affects
us
um I am not going to talk a lot about
the health effects today they obviously
are very real and very concerning um
there are other people here that can
speak more intelligently about that and
also in the interest of time I thought
that I wouldn't go into that I hope you
have all seen an excellent letter that
was prepared um by Dr Romano from the
dart Geisel Su um school of medicine
she's an environmental epidemiologist
she's being doing she's done studies on
past and health issues um and it's
really
elucidating there's also a letter and I
don't want to steal her Thunder but we
also have something here from the New
Hampshire Public Health Association um
in support of the
bill so um we can talk about the bill um
I'll just kind of give the highlights
because I'm anticipating that this is
probably going to go to a
subcommittee but as I said uh based on
all the incontrovertible facts that I
have just been talking about we come to
one conclusion we need to stop the
influx of these chemicals in the first
place I think a lot of us aren't really
used to thinking about this issue in
this way because we're we're focused on
testing limits and
Remediation but if we really want to
stop what's been going on we've got to
stop it at the front of the pipe and not
have the unbelievable burden on our
health and on our taxpayers of dealing
with it at the end of the pipe so on the
list of things that I'm seeking to ban
you're going to see carpets upholstered
furniture food packaging Cosmetics
juvenile products dental floss yes
dental floss and PPE this is a targeted
past added ban product ban it's not
across the board Maine had an across
theboard ban Vermont um Minnesota has a
band that's targeted initially and then
it moves on to um across the board
Vermont has um very identified products
there are different things going on in
different states but I really don't want
this bill to conf be confused with um
with Maine which was really a across the
board and a huge lift for the state um
and and there's a lot going on there um
I really feel like I need to pause here
and say that there are essential uses
for past and I'm sure you're going to
hear about something of some of them
today but in crafting the bill I was
cognizant of this and I really really
wanted to carefully select products to
include um that really there wasn't an
uh essential use for uh pasas and dental
floss for instance and it really puts
less of a burden on the agency and its
staff to work through a whole bunch of
exemptions the products that you were
chosen as you can see um in your
information packets that I chose bulky
items furniture and carpets in
particular because they carry a huge
load of pasas into the landfills and
we've become in the working group really
sensitive to the to the burden of P you
know for for the landfills who aren't
asking to have the stuff in them but
they're the recipients and they have to
um deal with them so that's one side of
it um I also provided for you a chart
from an organization called swana and
that organization has identified the
products from which we are most uh con
it's okay from which we are most uh
exposed food packaging uh Cosmetics a
lot of us don't have to worry too much
about that but it's a very real thing it
reminds me of the days when Queen
Elizabeth put lead on her face but
anyway so food packaging uh foundation
and lipstick dust carpets which I've
included here um and those things are
that's how I started to craft what I
wanted to include in this bill and
lastly and
100% uh not least is I really wanted to
focus on exposure of children to these
products so I've included juvenile
products in here and I also have PPE in
here um our First Responders and Health
Care Professionals shouldn't be subject
to past to do their jobs and
unfortunately he had to leave but this B
Bill does have the full support of the
union for professional firefighters I
spoke to the lobbyist earlier um today
I've had really good discussions with
them and they're extremely concerned
about pasas in the Pro things that they
wear to protect us we all handle sleep
and walk on Floors we consume these
products in our everyday lives at work
at business I mean you may hear that
businesses are opposed to this bill um
or the you know the workers are hand
handling these things our Municipal
workers are handling these things we
handle them in retailers we handle them
in schools daycare centers restaurants
and even swimming in our lakes and so
it's just unavoidable for us so I don't
know how much detail you want me to go
into on the bill I just really want to
talk a little bit about the definition
the definition is Broad um it's
intentionally broad it's broad because
as there are various iterations of these
chemicals that come through you know you
don't want everything Twisted one way or
another and it also um basically tracks
the definitions that are used in 22
States and also by our Department of
Defense which is a really important
Point um in addition the um the statutes
that we have now in New Hampshire I had
OS look at it the defin that we have of
p is in our firefighting uh foam uh
section and we've banned firefighting
foam with intentionally added pasas and
that so it tracks within our own um
within our own statute and I have been
told that businesses really prefer
consistency in
application um so that's it on the
definition I've walked worked a lot on
the understanding of
chemistry I hesitate to even go into
this at this late date but I just really
I need to say this so we all our eyes
don't glaze over I talked a long time to
our toxicologist and he was really
helpful there are longchain and short
chain past they're polymeric and
nonpolymeric these molecules all contain
at least one carbon with Florine
attached and these carbon Florine bonds
are incredibly strong and that's why
these chemicals have their staying power
it gets confusing but on a really basic
level let's not lose sight of this
nonpolymeric pasas are long and short
chain pasas chain refers to the number
of carbons polymeric molecules are Daisy
chained long and short chain past
molecules and that's how you get to
something with with a polymer like
Teflon I would argue that you can't
exclude polymeric molecules from the
definition because polymeric the long
ones are built with the Daisy chains of
the short ones so that's in the
manufacturer and it's also the
degradation produ project um uh product
so that's kind of it in a
nutshell I think you need to keep your
eye on that particular ball as you
consider the definitional issues
intentionally added is intentionally
added we're not going after anybody that
didn't on purpose put the pasas in their
product to serve a purpose the Clearing
House it's late there's so much to be
said about the Clearing House it really
is the mechanism by which states um
enforce their uh their laws um I had a
long discuss discussion with the folks
uh that run the Clearing Houses they're
more than happy to talk to the committee
members um but the clearing house that
would probably be used for this is
called the
ic2 I was told that the startup cost are
going to probably be born by Maine and
Minnesota their effective date is before
hours um and that to participate in it
it might not cost much more than
$25,000 that may seem High compare it to
I mean I don't even know what minuscule
percentage that is of hundred or100
million that the state's already spent
and last but not least these effective
dates are
long-term um the the there's a
notification provision for products to
be prohibited for sale that is July 1st
2026 the prohibition doesn't come
effective until July 1st 2028 there's a
labeling section it wouldn't become uh
for things that aren't banned that
wouldn't become effective until
2029 I feel the public deserves to know
what has been buying these are like
Parts the notification part the labeling
part the ban part you can look at them
sort of individually as you're looking
at the bill so that's it the bills
attempt to this is a bill that attempts
to stop the influx of these dangerous
chemicals in our state there's really no
other way and if there 's any state that
has suffered from past contamination
it's ours we need to be brave we need to
take a bold step like this to stop it
and we can't always wait for other
states to take necessary action we
should lead like we did with Mercury why
like we did with the uh MCL testing
levels which is the past testing levels
and I will stop there and if you uh want
to ask me any questions I'd be more than
happy to answer them and thank you for
your
consideration okay thank you
Karen okay uh so I have a pile of reps
so uh given the tradition we do reps
Boyd good afternoon Mr chairman thank
you very much much and through you to my
esteemed colleagues on the Commerce
Committee for the record my name is Bill
Boyd I represent Hillsboro 12 in the
great town of marac and I rise in
support in support of House Bill 1649 as
a co- sponsor looking to restrict
certain products made with posos um I
would certainly want to amplify uh the
com the comments that have been made by
representative uh eel and I want to
amplify I with just a couple of thoughts
uh for your consideration as you
deliberate uh this
bill I currently chair the New Hampshire
drinking water and groundwater advisory
commission the commission was formed
back in 2016 after the state one an MTB
mtbe settlement and $277 million was
entrusted with this particular fund
currently the trust fund has already
expended $140 million to
granted State Community specifically
targeting pollution contamination Source
water development
infrastructure um groundwater protection
anything as it relates to water we've
had a positive impact on communities
that have made application to us looking
to improve uh portability issues that
they have in their particular
Community my community in marac has been
Amplified by posos
impacting our particular water wells
that that occurred through a company
that is no longer no longer in my
Bain we have made a commitment in the
town of marac to the tune of $17
million in providing clean portable
water to clean up the mess that sang go
ban has had I say this because my
commission has made an investment in to
these communities who have sought to
provide their communities with clean
becomes it becomes prohibitive if we do
not begin to take the necessary First
Steps regarding products that get tossed
into our local landfills from from
leeching into our groundwater we will be
spending more money in the long run
trying to clean up the mess than being
proactive and trying to begin to put
specific rules in place that can have a
positive impact on ensuring that the
groundwater in our great state is clean
and pure not just for us but for future
Generations that come to the Granite
State the one last thing that I would
bring to your attention is the town of
miramac has a landfill and there are
three houses that are but the landfill
and currently in marac we have
testing Wells that are currently
monitoring those particular Wells not
just for past but for every known
carcinogenic chemical that may exist
underneath that particular landfill a
couple years ago prior to me becoming a
member of the uh honorable General Court
served on the Town Council and three of
those houses were impacted by leech
eight from our landfill that got into
the groundwater that impacted their
personal drinking Wells with the help of
the Department of Environmental Services
the town of marac proactively accepted
responsibility they have monitoring and
they have filtration at those three
particular houses now my community is
very lucky it's three houses if we look
at the communities that reside over by
KAG landfill and by pe Air Force Base
the impacts that have occurred with
within those particular communities are
far more dramatic than what has occurred
in my own Community but it should
serve and I would hope it would serve
and I I don't like to use dramatic
language but I would hope that it would
serve as a claring call to all of us
that we have a responsibility to take
the necessary first steps of making sure
that when when products are being made
that they're not using that they're not
using Posas so that we we're allowing
those future generations to be able to
drink clean portable water and I would
be remiss two years ago uh this is the
third attempt at trying to pass a bill I
introduced one representative Boer thank
you very much because I was the only
sponsor on that particular Bill and you
were kind enough to ask me did I ask
anybody else and I sheepishly told you
that I thought I ought to go at it alone
but here the third draft this is the
third go around and look at the number
of co-sponsors that we have on here and
I think that's a Testament of the
commitment not just to representative
email and my colleagues from marac
representative Thomas representative
Murphy representative Rong
representative Healey uh representative
Ned that have sounded um that have
worked hard to bring this issue to the
Forefront and I sincerely hope in your
deliberations that you'll give 1649 it's
due deliberation and hopefully maybe
begin to take the necessary First Steps
so that we can ensure that landfills are
not filled with PE us which ultimately
will leachate into our groundwater let's
let's have the impact now and take the
first steps and as representative evil
so aply put it take the necessary first
steps to to attack the issue like we did
with Mercury I thank you very much for
your time and I certainly would
entertain uh any
questions uh I think at this late hour
we're not going to be asking too many
questions you know what I I certainly
appreciate the uh the latitude that the
chairman gave me and I'm mindful of the
hour as well so thank you very much all
thank you chairman hunt and members of
the Commerce Committee for the record my
name is Rosemary rang I'm a state
representative for Hillsboro 12 which is
the town of marac I speak to you today
as a former chemist a former chair of
the New Hampshire pasas commission and a
40-year resident of marac who who has
seen my neighbors and Friends suffer a
statistically elevated rate of kidney
cancer and other cancers that may be
linked to past contamination of our
groundwater contaminated Wells continue
to be discovered throughout Southern New
Hampshire Beyond
miramac in July of 2020 New Hampshire
was one of the first states to set
aggressive maximum contaminant levels
for several pasas and drinking water we
were Le leaders in the country in taking
action to protect the health of granite
Staters and that leadership has proven
to be the right decision since then
other states followed and the uscpa is
on the verge of finalizing proposed
mcls I'm asking you to take a leadership
position
Now by supporting HB
1649 there is overwhelming evidence from
around the globe of the carcinogenesis
from pasas last year the National
Institute of Health's National Cancer
Institute working group upgraded one of
the first past p
pfoa as to a human carcinogen level and
I expect other P to
follow this threat to human health is
compounded by the fact that past do not
go away they bioaccumulate in nature so
we will never reach reduce the amount
currently in the world we can only stop
more from being released HB 1649 does
just that it prevents unnecessary pasas
from entering New Hampshire in the form
of carpeting rugs Cosmetics fabric
treatments products for children dental
floss and other products in which P
serves no essential Purpose By
restricting these by restricting these
past containing products in New
Hampshire we restrict them from our
landfills and landfill leate we restrict
them from entering the air through
incineration and we restrict them from
Human contact we reduce cancer-causing
exposure to Granite sters with this
bill now this isn't the first time
chemicals bans have been passed and
those were likely met from opposition
from
businesses makers of electrical
equipment Transformers opposed the PCP
ban it was a tough uninstallation
manufacturers when asbestos was
banned the cost of replacing hazardous
substances with safer Alternatives is
costly but it's much more costly to get
them out of our environment it's much
more costly to address the health
impacts that hazardous chemicals create
create so it is going to take strong
leadership on your part and the part of
the New Hampshire General Court to pass
this bill and show but it will show the
rest of the country that this can be
done and it can be done effectively but
we are leaders and we've taken strong
actions and sent strong messages before
Let's Do It Again by passing HB
1649 and I have all night to answer your
questions
thank you very much thank
Thomas thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee uh I had emailed you my
testimony um because I thought there was
a conflict with me being an executive
session in my committee I'm not going to
repeat that that um you you're going to
be hearing things about persistent
environment environmental pre pressure
uh presence bio accumulation things like
that I was asked to bring it down to the
real
world so recently thech who has declared
that pooa is a carcinogenic substance
we've all suspected this um we now have
proof and it's very likely as uh
representative rang just mentioned p is
carcinogenic as I've testified before I
live three miles from St gobain which is
the industrial polluter in the town of
marac and by the way I am representative
Wendy Thomas from the town of
marac uh and originally we were told
that only the residents that lived
within a half mile of s gobain had to be
concerned about water contamination then
they did some testing they moved it out
to a full full mile we live 3 miles from
s cabain we have a private well we
decided to get it tested in
2016 the results came back so high that
we had to shut the well down
immediately I have six children and they
all grew up drinking that
water on my street I I border the the
very edge of an old neighborhood they
all have private Wells there are four
houses on my street that have private
wells in house number one
the dad has died of kidney cancer in
house number two the dad and the adult
son have died from colon cancer in house
number three which is right next door to
mine the dad is dying right now of stage
four prostate cancer house number four
is my house I've testified before that I
have breast cancer and the oncologists
at Dartmouth Hitchcock because of my
blood tests which indicate I have 12
people fast chemicals in my blood that
are above the toxic limit that's allowed
for
humans the the oncologist said darith
hitok have have as much as they are able
to have linked my breast cancer to past
contamination because I have so much
pasas in my blood they have said that my
body is a quote ticking Time Bomb for
more cancer and because of that I had to
have my ovaries and Fallopian tubes
removed prophylactically that's the way
we survive in a town that is in
contaminated with pfast chemicals we
amputate parts of our bodies to keep
ahead of any potential
cancer my husband has heart issues at
age 55 he had several heart attacks and
had to have a quadruple stent that's
connected to past contamination he has
cholesterol issues he has weight issues
obesity is big in our town and it's not
because were lazy people it's past
contamination they are endocrine
disruptors hormones Rule the World um if
you upset those you're going to get
added weight um my husband has kidney
issues he just uh had kidney stones
removed he has bladder issues I
mentioned I have six
children I have an adult son with heart
issues he's in his late 20s uh several
of my kids have cholesterol issues
several of my kids have autoimmune
issues the majority of my children have
immune
dysfunction in the last 15 years I've
had to put four dogs down to cancer in
my
house so there is a huge impact it's
huge this is a poisonous carcinogenic
substance that is killing people in my
town and it is killing my family but it
is also impacting our town
economically how do you think I'm going
to be able to sell a house where you
can't use the water who's going to buy a
house in a town that is forever
contaminated let's talk about health
care costs even with insurance to to
have a disease like cancer I have to
take time off I have to drive I have to
pay for parking and I have to pay for
co-pays and I have to pay for
medication because I have The Misfortune
to be exposed to a carcinogenic
substance what we're telling people in
our town is to filter your water just
even if you're on public water filter it
keep you and your family safe when we
put in our whole house filtration system
in
2016 it cost about
$5,000 now that price has come down a
little bit but they're still upkeep to
replace the filters every year is about
$500 this is an added cost that we are
paying and whoever lives in my house is
going to have to pay for the rest of
time because this was done to
us lastly there's there's bottled water
costs people in my town are afraid of
drinking the water and so they're buying
bottled water it adds up especially if
you've got kids so the only way to
address this is to do something called
stop the tap and that means to stop the
flow of P gas chemicals coming into our
state into our lives and this bill is an
important step to make that happen it
must be considered and it must be passed
thank you very
up
uh Carrie spear ward 3
Nashua I took a different tact and what
I wanted to do uh is look at the actual
research both in the United States and
in Europe because Europe actually if you
can imagine has more P Fest than we
do
and so I wanted to go to sources of
research so I went to the National
Institutes of Health to find out do they
act do people actually understand how
pasas attacks the various organs of our
body and the research is
there uh I learned about how it attacks
uh fatty acids in the kidneys I learned
about how it attacks the uh the
connective tissues between our bones how
it destroys our bones I looked at a lot
of research on this and I presented some
of it in the paper that I gave you so
I'm not going to go back and I've saved
all the links and I've saved all the
papers so if you really want to weigh
through some of that stuff it's it's
pretty heavy so to say that it's just
statistically known that's really not
accurate the research is really starting
to come out ever since 20
around 2000 when this stuff became
obviously
bad uh all kinds of agencies have
decided to actually do the research on
this and so I think the information is
there what I did want to do is address
the fact
that the FDA doesn't really test this
stuff at all and so when uh various
chemical companies present their data
they only present what they feel
is appropriate at the time breakdown
products are not
discussed and so as a result of that we
don't see the whole picture for instance
we were talking about
non-polymeric uh chains but when they uh
I'm sorry when they
uh let me get this right I don't want to
be
wrong when we talk about polymeric
chains they break down into
non-polymeric chains so originally the
polymeric chains were considered the the
The Cure All well they're not because
when they break down they break down to
the bad ones the same thing with
hfc's were replaced by hfos when hfos
break down they release a a chemical
called tfas tfas is just another version
of
PFS and the problem is they stay in the
environment for decades and so we're
just polluting with another product it's
a breakdown product but that wasn't
presented
where I found the research for that one
was in Germany they did extensive
research on tfas and it's it's they're
working on rules to ban it in in in
Germany so the these are the kinds of
things I wanted to look at and I
presented a little bit of that in the
paper and so I'll just leave you with
that one of the thoughts I have given
the brand n uh the uh the huge nature of
the problem it's time that the
manufacturers themselves stop putting
the cost on the taxpayer who never even
knew these products were bad even though
the known uh based on lawsuits that it
was known by 3M and and uh Dupont for 30
years 40 years 50 years they started
seeing their own employees get sick and
die and this is the first time it wasn't
until 2000 that that information became
public so it's really kind of time that
the
manufacturers kind of paid their due
diligence that we've been suffering with
for all these years and take
responsibility and find Alternatives and
I think that it's about time that they
did that now we saw some Bill from
someone who was in the motorcycle group
and they said well they make junior
motorcycles for little kids or small
children and then they shouldn't be
banned and they're very safe and all
that sort of thing and we're not Banning
motorcycles but I will tell you that the
headliner for the motorcycle helmet
is made out of past laced chemicals that
are sitting on children's heads and that
the idea that that's what they want for
their children when there are
alternatives I I can't even begin to
Fathom why somebody would want that so I
think that the fact that we paired the
bill down to a set of
products and I and I've seen products in
Hairspray I've seen products in face
wash it doesn't belong on our faces and
the product s will break down and when
they break down they go into the
groundwater eventually through uh
getting absorbed through the ground
so everybody else has a whole lot to say
about it and I don't want to say anymore
I just wanted to leave you with the idea
that there is real research that has
been done and has proved the mechanisms
and it's being done both in the United
Walter okay you just we'll just pass
Murphy good afternoon chairman hunt and
honorable hble members of the committee
I'm Nancy Murphy I represent the town of
March Hillsboro District 12 um I've
submitted my personal testimony on to
the committee online and with your
permission I'd like to share testimony
and support of hb1 1649 from
environmental scientist Public Health um
uh excuse me public health scientist
author and former representative The
Honorable Mindy Mesmer over the past
several years con consumers have
discovered that many of the everyday
household products they use contained
per and polyfloral alkal substances or
pest in addition many have discovered
that their municipal or Community
drinking water or private Wells have
been contaminated with PS these
chemicals do not break down in the
environment and once they are in our
body they
accumulate even if you stop drinking
contaminated water exposure from other
sources continues to contribute to the
body burden of
pasas in addition consumers are being
exposed to regrettable substitutions
that are virtually untested for safety
before they enter the market in a wide
variety of consumer goods past chemicals
have been found to cause a variety of
health effects um and are linked to many
others including testicular and kidney
cancer ulcerative colitis thyroid
disease hyper cholester Almia and
pregnancy complications as well as
female breast prostate and thyroid
cancers low birth weight immune and
endocrine disruption reduced childhood
vaccine efficacy and cardiovascular
impacts the problem has been that
consumers have no way of knowing how to
avoid additional exposure because the
presence of PS is not listed on the
label companies hide behind confidential
business claims to avoid disclosure of
the presence of pasas in their products
less cancer has recently called upon the
Food and Drug administ rtion to reain in
this widespread use of past chemicals in
products like waterproof mascara and
other cosmetic products residents from
many cities and towns across New
Hampshire for example the Sea Coast in
marac Lichfield London Terry and Bedford
have been inadvertently exposed to high
levels of pasas in their drinking water
those residents can control their
consumption of drink of contaminated
drinking water once they knew about it
but they cannot control additional
inadvertent exposure from additional
consumer products and cosmetics I fully
support this effort with numerous
communities in New Hampshire grappling
with the repercussions of widespread
pasas contamination in their Drinking
Water Supplies we must take action to
minimize their unintended exposure to
past chemicals um I just lastly wanted
to mention also that on October 13
2023 the HB 737 pest commission voted to
support the limitation of non-essential
use of pfast containing products in New
Hampshire's Commerce to ensure the
protection of human health and the
environment thank
you thank you so is it possible you can
have
that actually was all submitted it was
submitted online online you got it
online okay thank you all right thank
you all right I have I got all the
Reps
speak okay uh testimony that we all been
you good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee I will uh be brief in
the interest of the time here um I do
have a letter of testimony that I
provided uh for the record my name is
Mike win that I serve as director of the
waste management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services I appreciate the opportunity to
testify um on house pill 1649 this
afternoon uh the agency is not taking a
position on this um but I do want to
offer some some guidance and some
concerns that we have um first of all I
want to say that Dees has been dealing
ever since the discovery of uh
contamination from p uh out at P trade
port in 2014 and then in Southern New
Hampshire in 2016 DS has been working
nothing short of feverishly to address
the the the problems associated with
contamination by P and to try to reduce
human exposures to these
toxins um we
uh uh really determined in 2016 when we
really began working on Earnest in this
very quickly um we did while we were
dealing with the problem in Southern New
Hampshire we realized that we came to
realize that Pats were very widely used
so we we did a lot of work to evaluate
where they might be being used and and
released from manufacturing and
Commercial operations and what we really
learned is that they are so widespread
they're in not just Industrial and
Commercial processes but they're in um
consumer products and so what we came to
quickly conclude is that if we're going
to address the human exposure problem
we've got to significantly reduce the
use of past in Commerce so we absolutely
support the the intent of this bill to
try to make steps towards that we
believe the steps that this bill would
Implement will will will go a long way
towards achieving that goal of of
reducing its use in Commerce um we do
have some concerns about our ability to
administer the bill as presented um and
they may mostly Center on the fact that
it's some pretty expansive notification
requirements likely to involve thousands
of products and in order to do that cost
effectively and and really to be able to
afford to do it and and be able to
handle the workload associated with it
um we believe that the use of a of a a
multi-state clearing clearing house is
really important for that and uh
representative eel mentioned the ic2 I
think that the the Interstate Chemicals
Clearing House currently administers a
high priority chemicals database and
that database they're working with a
couple of other states that are already
have laws and they will uh likely either
amend that or or stand up a separate
framework to try to kind of in a in a
Consolidated and comprehensive way serve
multiple States who are implementing
these programs we don't really think
we're at the sort of critical mass state
yet where where that'll be able to
happen so that New Hampshire doesn't
have to make a huge investment in
setting up that framework so we think it
may be that we need a little time for
that to happen but I want to emphasize
that we we recognize this bill is likely
to undergo some study and we're
certainly happy and and interested in
participating in that discussion and
I'll leave it at that and field any
questions well needs to say some of our
committee members are anxious to not
study this anymore and move forward sure
so um obviously I do see in the bill
this you know the Clearing House right
issue um so the question is then is in
terms of the effective
dates uh in this bill in terms of how
working with that Clearing House model
is is that appropriate right we have
some sorry yeah go ahead we have some
concerns that uh the the the pace at
which these other few states are making
progress is a little slow and that we
might be in the early implementation
phase for that and and it's just
important to understand that that will
take a lot more effort on the part of
the state of of Dees as well as cost um
having said that I think that the much
of what the Clearing House would do for
us would be to deal with the specific
notification Provisions in the bill
right so as this bill makes its way
through if it were amended potentially
to even remove those it's possible you
could do this without having those
notification requirements I'm not saying
I'm advocating for that but it could
happen it might change that analysis so
I I what I'm guess I'm trying to say is
the agency would like to be part of any
discussions moving forward as this bill
makes its way through the process well
dare I say this but I I have with other
departments that is uh yeah we would
love to see a marked up version from
you sure well I I I would say I'm not
sure the agency is prepared to mark up a
version and tell you what what would
work for the agency but certainly we're
prepared to work with the sponsor and
other interested well I only say because
you know we do insurance and Banking and
liquor and and yeah we we is it look to
you to be the enforcement entity and so
therefore we yes we look for you to uh
mark it up to tell us what you can
enforce and when you can enforce it I'd
be ha the agency would be happy to work
with the sponsor towards that end
absolutely EX excellent representative
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you for
uh taking my question could could you
just give uh someone uh like me who's
still studying this issue just a sense
of I know there's hot spots in our state
that had past contamination uh and this
bill is talking about consumer products
that's right um so the hotspots what
percentage of them are from some kind of
industrial or even military or
firefighting Bill and which which are
the result of landfills with consumer
products in the landfills because that's
what this bill would address so I I I
don't know if I can put a number on that
the three biggest hotpots are industrial
or commercial so there's peace trade
Port where was a firefighting P problem
during the operation in the air base
there's the Saco ban and the and the and
the tox textiles coded International
facilities in Southern New Hampshire
that were manufacturers who had air
emissions that impacted drinking water
um but what we've learned through
looking at other facilities we do have
have a number of old online landfills
that have contaminated groundwater
locally as a result of the release of
past from the landfill uh we do have a
number of um firefighting facility or
excuse me fire stations that that you
know are using the materials
appropriately but didn't know that they
were when they were maintaining their
equipment they were releasing
contaminants to the area around their
fire stations or at their fire training
sites um but we also have examples where
you know a carpet cleaner one person
that works out of a van goes home at
night to his house and dumps the wash
waterer out and he contaminated several
wells around his house of his neighbors
so those are you know I would I guess
you can call it commercial use but
certainly similarly someone maintaining
their own carpets or floors could
potentially contaminate groundwater
around their home so we do see p in many
different locations um in terms of the
use in consumer products it isn't just
about contaminating groundwater it's
that these exposures occur as a result
of you know Cosmetics um getting into
food and ingesting it um household dust
um that sort of thing so the the the
path the pathways to exposure are are
water great well we look forward to be
working with you all right thank you
thank
you okay uh actually what I'm going to
do is I'm going to do the two uh cards I
have in opposition just to get them out
of the way and then we can take up the
rest of it so jod rimus representing the
Council
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is jod
grimas I'm here representing the
American chemistry Council um I have
presented a letter for you all to have
it is signed by not only the American
chemistry Council but a number of other
industries that have also raised
concerns about the bill as written um we
have had uh very good conversations with
the
sponsor
no hold the microphone close to your M
sorry can you hear can you hear me
now we've had discussions with the
sponsor Before Christmas um we'd like to
continue those discussions um certainly
um the American chemistry Council has
released its own model legislation which
covers a lot of these products as well
so trying to work through those things I
will tell you as the sponsor mentioned
years ago there was an issue of of
firefighting Foams in 2019 we worked
with Senator Tom Tom Sherman and all of
the stakeholders including the
professional firefighters to come up
with the statute that's on this books
today so we'd like to have that
opportunity we will continue to work
with the subcommittee and the sponsor to
see if we can find some way to find
consensus thank you so is it over the
polymer issue uh there's some
definitional issues that they'd like to
discuss I think they also want to
discuss kind of those notifications and
U timing requirements as well different
Industries have different um okay issues
but thank you okay thank you
Andrew
beamus representing
span yes sir what is
that no because you have to turn the mic
good um well chairman hunt and members
of the committee uh thank you very much
for allowing me to testify today my name
is Andrew beamis I'm with the
sustainable p P Action Network uh span
for short we're a coalition of past
users and producers who are committed to
sustainable risk-based past management
our members advocate for responsible
policies that assure long-term human
health and Environmental Protection uh
while recognizing the critical need that
certain past play as contributors to US
economic growth so that's a summary of
of who we are um very happy to be here
today we've been involved in the past
discussion in New Hampshire for going on
a couple of years now and I'll I'll just
begin by saying we've had some very
productive conversations and continuing
dialogue with um some of the members
here um and others um like Dees and we
very very much look forward to that
continuing today um I'll just be brief
um just a couple of issues to to mention
here quickly today uh We've touched on a
couple of issues with um the definition
uh and we would like to say to begin
that there are aspects of the bill that
we are supportive of um and we'll touch
on those briefly as well um with the
definition we'll just say briefly that
um as has been mentioned the definition
is uh far too broad um there would be
about 14,000 compounds included in the
legislation's current definition um just
to give a little bit of um reference to
that definition uh recently the US
Environmental Protection Agency released
final rules for a past reporting program
pursuant to epa's past road map that
they released in
2021 um the definition that they use um
EPA States contains uh less than 1,500
compounds of which less than 800 are
expected to be commercially active um
and so it's important to consider and in
other states as well such as Delaware
Virginia and West Virginia have also
adopted more uh targeted definitions so
um span would consider uh or encourage
consideration of those federal reporting
rules and some of the other factors that
go into the definition as well um we'll
also just touch on briefly as I
mentioned span is supportive of the
Bill's focus on consumer products um it
is very important that past legislation
focus on non-essential consumer product
uses especially in some uses in which
the pasas can be phased out so we
applaud the Bill's focus on that uh we
would like to emphasize though that the
bill um or bills focused on consumer
products are most effective when the
definition is targeted to high risk and
high emissive compounds that are
commercially active as well so um those
are my my comments I'll keep it brief um
so thank you very much for the time
today there's any comments or questions
I will be happy to take them all right
thank you question representative Spirit
we've
talked we have yes we've talked in the
past and the problem that we have with
limiting the
definition is that the products it's
like playing whack-a-mole every time we
turn around there's another product and
we don't know what the breakdown product
is if we start limiting the
definition we're afraid we're going to
miss what it is we're trying to protect
over
here and one of the things that that one
of the most immediate things is the
compounds that make up uh
hfos the fact that they're using
Refrigeration fine the fact that they
using industrial places fine they don't
belong on our hair because they break
down and the breakdown products are bad
so it's very very difficult to to narrow
that um that
definition and the
EPA has been
driven has had taken a lot of
information from the industry and they
haven't really they they've narrowed it
to such an extent that we don't know
where to go with that definition to
protect ourselves into the future so why
do you think we should do that that I'm
not clear on what the benefit of that is
when all we're concerned about our
consumer products which we don't even
know what's in them and and we've talked
about trying to get the definitions for
what's in them and we can't sure all
representative spe thank you for the
comments and the question I appreciate
that um we'll say quickly some of the
products in the bill like food packaging
um the past content is relatively well
understood that one is right and we
applaud the bills focus on that and I I
will also comment that part of the
purpose of the epa's reporting rules is
to address exactly what you've mentioned
is certainly and a lot of compounds that
have entered Commerce in the last
several years or so have undergone
pretty rigorous toxical testing at the
federal level um but others have not and
part of the purpose of the EPA reporting
rules is to figure out which ones have
not which ones are commercially active
which ones might be responsible for the
contamination issues so agreed there are
holes in the research and that is
ongoing um and we look forward to that
data from EPA and would just encourage
that the committee consider that when it
becomes
available any other questions
representative Bilo thank you thank you
for taking my question do you think
there's a problem here with pasas in the
state
absolutely that mean yeah we acknowledge
that there are issues with past
contamination and that's part of what
our group is intending to do
is focus on identifying contaminated
sites and remediating
them right thank you all right any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you and next we'll
call
Hanan from the New Hampshire Public
Health
Association and if you could give your
you so thank you for the opportunity to
testify today um my name is Hanan B um
shorter version uh and I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire public
Public Health
Association
[Music]
um on behalf of the New Hampshire Public
Health Association we're here to urge
the committee to support House Bill
1649 um pasas uh poses a public health
concern as you all know pasas is um our
man-made uh synthetic chemicals that can
last within the human body for a long
time and and in the environment for a
long time evidence indicates that
certain exposure to past can reduce the
ability of the body's immune system to
fight infections decreases uh fertility
increases uh high blood pressure in
pregnant women cause developmental
effects or delays in children increase
the risk of some cancers uh an example
is kidney cancer and a lot of things
were mentioned earlier today it
interferes with the body's natural
hormones and just to name of you uh this
bill will protect will reduce the
exposure of Pat and it will protect
Granite states protect our children it
will protect our families it will
protect our community from health and
environmental threats of pasas we ask
you to uh support this bill and vote uh
ought to
pass thank you for protecting the health
of our community that's it all right
thank you for your testimony any
questions for the
guest all right thank
you and next we'll call
Stephen
pug pugy py uh from representing WM if
okay good afternoon members of the
committee uh my name is Steve py I am
the uh area director of disposal
operations for Waste Management uh I'm a
professional engineer registered in
state of New Hampshire I've been dealing
with solid waste management issues for
more than 40 years uh most of that in
the state of New Hampshire uh we
currently operate the turnkey land in
Rochester it's um the larest landfill in
the State uh we manage about 40% of the
solid waste that's currently generated
in the state of New Hampshire uh so
we're the recipient of a lot of solid
waste that gets generated in the state
and we are managing lee8 coming off the
bottom of that landfill we've got a
double lined landfill there and we have
a pre-treatment facility onite site that
we treat for these compounds along with
a number of other things we haven't been
required to do that um by the
regulations yet but we know they're
coming so we've gone ahead and put in a
uh reverse osmosis treatment system and
uh recently an iron exchange system to
remove these chemicals from the
Wastewater before it gets discharged to
the city of Rochester where they treat
it again um we're in support of this
bill uh we think that there needs to be
something done to remove these compounds
uh from the waist stream uh they're
extremely hazardous and you heard
testimony today uh and if you look at
the research it's pretty compelling um
just looking at the standards that are
being proposed by EPA for drinking water
that's coming out fairly soon uh it's
going to be the pop P trillion range
limits are often set in pot per million
pot per billion pot per trillion I can't
think of of any other compounds that are
set the PO patran range to give you some
context on that I just looked up sitting
here how much waterers in Lake wazaki
625 billion gallons so if you took I did
the quick math cup and a half of these
compounds poured into when it Baki you
couldn't drink the
water and if you look at things that are
under your kitchen sink which I did my
wife had result carpet cleaner and you
look that up majority of that is
past and that 16 o container which is
you know sold and available at Lowe's
for
$7.98 a container you pour that in wiip
you can't drink that water so these
things are extremely hazardous uh very
costly we spent millions of dollars over
the last five years to manage these
chemicals and I can tell you they're in
everything we we do um we manage uh as
individuals what we buy in the stores uh
what we discard so I would uh really
encourage the committee to to move this
forward and look to try to eliminate
you representative buroughs thanks for
taking my question just a quick question
I was just kind of startled when you
said that that I don't know what the
name of the the product was that you
pour down the drain resolve it's stains
on your carpet yep Resolve Carpet
Cleaner what does that do to people who
living in the house when you use that
it is resolve this is the one with the
red jar with with the brush thing on top
I use that all the time right and we a
lot of us have it it works great I will
tell you that the materials work great
for what they're intended but they're
extremely hazardous and we we have them
everywhere so that's not on the list
maybe representative evil will consider
that but there are a lot of things that
could be added to that list I think it's
a good start um is that the pet cleaner
no it's a fabric cleaner it's a rug it's
a rug cleaner yeah and just on that real
quick um carpets and uh Furniture are a
problem for us we take those materials
for disposal obviously but uh stain
Master that's what that is yeah um works
great but in bulk we there's a lot of
material that comes into these sites for
disposal we're managing it on the back
that okay thank you thank you uh d
District good evening I appreciate you
uh having us here tonight my name is
Donald preventure I'm a civil engineer I
am the um chair of the meramac village
District Board of
Commissioners um the MVD is a uh water
district that supplies water water to uh
meramac in portion of Bedford um we know
firsthand the challenges of past um all
of our wells all of our six wells in
town are contaminated we've got three
treatment plants that treat those six
Wells uh it was uh at least uh $20
million worth of pasas
treatment um our customers fund MVD
fully they're on the hook for that 20
million
over the next 20 years
basically um I have a letter that I
submitted to you on record already it's
signed by all five of our Board of
Commissioners I've got one behind me
wolf Von Shan that that joined me today
and the uh
superintendent um but the one thing I I
wanted to mention is this very
legislature in 2019 passed some very low
uh maximum contaminant levels for uh
Four Past comp compounds those are very
low
concentrations um the reason that
they're that low is because of their
toxicity um that is a main root of uh
exposure is obviously drinking peat uh
water because everybody needs water um
but in my mind uh
having those levels Solo in this
legislature taking the responsibility
of creating those mcls at that low
level it's it's common sense that any
other roots of exposure should be
treated as well and I think this bill
addresses a lot of that
um in meramac there's something that I I
dubbed the uh the P Trifecta for those
of you who think that um not all past
may be um harmful but um we have one of
the largest polluters in town
uh that's that's number one probably the
largest polluter in all of New England
if not the whole country or one of the
largest in the country uh in 2017 the
Department of Health and Human Services
tested the blood of
217 uh MVD customers and found the
average customer to have double the
national average of pfoa and then just
recently in uh January of 23 a year ago
dhh came out with a cancer study that
indicated
42% higher occurrence of um kidney and
and bladder cancer in miramac than
anywhere else in the state so when you
add those three together I find it hard
that it's a coincidence so um these
things are important they need to be
dealt with um and I think it's time
maybe to have the chemical industry
instead of us having to play the
whack-a-mole approach why don't we have
the chemical industry prove that past
are safe
before we let them back into our
consumer products and I think putting a
pressing the pause button on that right
now is an appropriate thing to do so
that was it I wanted to keep it brief
there's more information in the letter
that I sent you but you have that so you
can read it at your own Leisure
appreciate
it
yeah could you tell me I don't know if
you can but if um my girlfriend lives in
Bedford right across the street from uh
the Manchester Country Club and
and her well is polluted with P so she
hasn't been able to drink the water and
could you tell me if the Manchester
Country Club is dealing with P issues or
if they even
know I don't know if they know or if
they're dealing with that um I will say
there's a groundwater management Zone
delineation that goes as far as into
Southern Manchester which is where I
grew up and then I moved to meramac so
I'm personally Liv my whole life in a
groundwater management Zone um but I
know meramac Village District doesn't
serve water to that part of
Bedford um but it it is inside the
groundwater management zone so there's
there's a good a chance that all of uh
the groundwater in there should be
tested within that boundary and uh it's
not surprising to me that it's found if
it is elevated it's not surprising yep
thank you
Strand you had to leave
okay uh Christine uh babber she's left
yeah
Heidi I know she's constellation V are
you from around here or are you from uh
me
so I'm with clf in our conquered office
and I'm from the Upper Valley from
Handover okay so aren't you glad we
scheduled all these bills today well I
hear the snow has started up in the
Upper Valley so I will be driving there
uh next heading home but uh thank you
good evening thank you to the chair in
the committee um for my third appearance
I will keep it brief um for the record
Heidi trarco for the conservation law
Foundation um I will start by uh I have
testimony from
uh a group of organizations that um had
to leave early they have submitted a
letter um but this is testimony and
support of the bill from the New
Hampshire Association of conservation
commissions the Appalachian Mountain
Club New Hampshire audabon the forest
Society Connecticut River Conservancy
New Hampshire Lakes collaborative Solid
Waste strategies and the nature
conservancy and all of those
organizations support the bill and urge
the committee to vote ought to pass and
you should have their
um testimony with uh the committee
should already have
that um they speak to pfas being
widespread harmful to human health and
the environment the high costs of pasas
pollution and the need to reduce P to
avoid the harm and start solving the
pfas crisis that we face um similarly
the committee should have clf's
testimony and I have copies and I'll
hand those out um but we strongly urge
the committee to um vote a to pass on
this bill
1649 um and I will you'll just find in
our testimony hopefully some of the
references that provides the committee
um with some of the documentation to
support things that you've already heard
today about the high costs of PS
contamination the serious health health
effects um and you know the
pervasiveness of pest in our bodies and
in our
environment and I'll just um close on a
personal note I began my career as an
attorney 15 years ago representing
people a a class of people whose
drinking water was contaminated by P and
pfoa in um West Virginia and in
Minnesota and in New Jersey and at the
time it was um we were just discovering
these these things and trying to figure
out what they were and learning that the
companies had known about them as you've
heard
from worker studies you know for decades
and maybe since the 1940s since the
1970s and so we were discovering it then
um and it it is exciting that New
Hampshire has an opportunity to um not
just react but to take a positive step
towards protecting people and protecting
the state from these chemicals so I urge
the committee to vote out to pass thank
you thank
you safe drive
right hi I actually filled out the pink
card that I was going to speak for Susan
Richmond who couldn't be here right
instead I turned in her uh short
testimony to you already yes so you have
that but I hope that I could say just a
few words for myself and for the town of
hopkington sure um
um we have a $4 million pasas and toxics
cleanup that we're going to have to do
in hopkington it's at our transfer
station $4 million is a big number for a
town of our size for any town for that
matter that cleanup does not include
what we're going to have to do to treat
the sludge in our wastewater treatment
system so it's going to be 4 million
plus plus plus um I just thought it
would be good for you guys to know what
we're facing in in other towns um in the
process of putting together the plan for
that I've spoken several times with
Anthony drwan who is the residuals
management supervisor at Dees and he's
been incredibly helpful and I've learned
a lot about PS and on a personal note I
didn't realize that pasas was going into
everybody's septic system the town
Wastewater system I had no idea I had no
idea that the sunscreen that I've been
using for decades as a fair skinned
person I use the waterproof
version full of pasas I I I've been
putting it all over my body and then I
wash it off and it goes into the
groundwater and I'm like oh my God you
know who knew
so another thing regarding Hopkinson is
that we in in the Hopkinson Village I'm
sorry the kukuk village Precinct we have
our water comes from a pond in Warner so
it goes through a treatment system
before it goes out to the residents that
treatment system is really Antiquated
and so we're doing a study now to see
whether we can upgrade it rebuild it or
what may be a lot more coste effective
for us is to turn to groundwater as our
source instead of using the surface
water and as we've just said the
groundwater you know we just did a
natural resource inventory for the
Conservation Commission we've seen the
extent of our aquafers and our
groundwater and that's all being
contaminated potentially just by
people's own backyard septic systems
so it feels like we're cornered we're
cornered as individuals we're cornered
as a town we're
cornered by the producers of pasas and I
really hope that you guys will pass this
ought to pass um so we can move forward
on doing something about this disaster
thank you very
Hatfield T left
sheet shouldn't have grabbed it on my
way
by okay okay I'm going
to uh skip over the people who spoke in
po p for
it well let's just say everybody on this
page is for it except
for Christen Co in
Bia oh yeah of
course and everything everybody else
so that's enough put in the file okay uh
with that uh I can assure everyone that
um we will be doing a subcommittee in
the first week of February uh this bill
has is an early bill so we have to have
it out before then and with that I will
hearing